this beginner's course will teach you
html and css through building and
deploying five awesome projects and you
will learn by solving over 75 coding
challenges
pair is your instructor pair borgen has
created many extremely popular courses
and is also the co-founder of scrimba
this course makes it easy to learn html
and css
hi there free cold campers and welcome
to this interactive scrimba course where
you are going to learn how to build
beautiful looking websites using html
and css we're going to go from scratch
so there are no prerequisites required
however the special thing about this
course is that it's fully challenge
based which means that you will need to
get your hands on the keyboard again and
again as you progress through this
course and if you now are a little bit
afraid or like setting up your local dev
environment don't worry for that reason
we have created an interactive version
of this course over on scrimba.com there
you'll be able to solve all of the
challenges directly in your browser so
just click on the link below and you'll
get to that interactive version now if
you prefer to instead solve the
challenges locally i've created a github
repository that you can clone and there
you'll get access to all of the starter
files for the challenges one final thing
if you like this course please give it a
thumbs up here at youtube that is highly
appreciated and if you have any feedback
for me just reach out to me at twitter
at pierre borgen
with that let's get started
hello there my dear internet friend i am
so happy that i get the opportunity to
teach you two of the most important
technologies on the world wide web html
and css and who am i my name is pierre
i'm the ceo of scrimba and i'm also a
front-end developer and coding teacher
and over a million students have gone
through my tutorials when i'm not coding
i enjoy posing in front of fast cars
but enough about me let's talk about
what you are going to build with your
own two hands throughout this course
the first project you'll build is the
world's most popular website
thegoogle.com homepage you're also going
to build a space exploration landing
page a digital business card and even a
birthday site which we are going to
deploy to the web so that you can send
it off to your best friend on their
birthday to make them feel special
because check it out it has these
virtual birthday presents that reveal
themselves when you hover over them so
this gift says here's how happy i am for
you today and when your friend hovers
over it boom they will feel your love
flowing to them through the magical
tubes of the internet
and we are going to build all of this in
html and css
so now you're probably wondering well
what is html it is short for hypertext
markup language
oh my god i'm getting tired of all this
theory let's instead say that you're
gonna build a car well then you'd start
with probably gathering the contents of
the cars like tires doors steering wheel
mirrors and stuff like that and that is
kind of the html of your car when you
stitch it together you at least have the
shell of a car the next step is probably
to paint the car so that it looks good
and that's the css and finally if you
want your car to drive you've got to
give it an engine and that is kind of
the javascript of your car or very often
referred to as js
now in a world wide web context the html
is then the content of the website that
is buttons images text and so forth the
css sd styling and the javascript is
what allows your website to solve
problems so that users for example can
check off tasks communicate with
databases you can also handle payments
and so forth now we're only going to
focus on html and css in this course and
then you can learn javascript and
another course i've created here on
scrimba as well
but knowing html is already hugely
valuable in today's job market and is
also the most natural first step as you
embark on a journey into the world of
web development so i hope you are ready
for this let's get started
the french philosopher rene descartes
once said three clever words pogito ergo
zum which translates in english to i
code therefore i am
so let us prove to ourselves that we
actually do exist by coding this out in
html and the way we do that is actually
not too different from how you would
write this out in a regular text editor
as there you would simply write out the
sentence and then if you wanted it a bit
more prominent you'd probably highlight
it and then click on normal text here
and choose another content type for your
text
you can see heading one heading two
heading three let's hover over heading
one and then click on it and there you
can see that the text became a lot more
prominent it became a heading 1. now if
we want to do this in html we'd simply
create an html file which you can see
here it's called
index.html as that is a common name to
give your html files
and here i would write
icode
therefore
i am
now if we open up a browser and point
this browser to our html file and then
run it then we can see that the text
indeed appears in the browser
however it's pretty small so if we
wanted to turn it into a heading 1
instead what we do is wrap the text in
html tags
so before the text we'll do this
two angle brackets with the text h1
inside of them that's short for heading
one
and then at the very end of the text i
would do the same h1 but since this is a
closing tag and not an opening tag i
would also have to give it a slash
before the text
and now if i rerun the code
there you go we have made our text a lot
more prominent
now i think our website should give
proper credit here so let's write rene
the cart underneath the h1
like that if we now rerun the code you
can see that
the text is just normal it's not an h1
that's because it is only the text which
is within the opening h1 and closing h1
that gets formatted
as a proper heading in the browser in my
view this line right here should be a
bit bigger i want it to instead look
something like this where the name is
pretty thick and big but not as big as
the heading one and that brings me to
your first challenge i'm going to paste
it in here so what you are going to do
is try to make our web page look like
the design in the provided slide and if
you are struggling to think of what kind
of html tag you'll have to wrap this
name in well i've got a little hint for
you what comes after one
so pause this scrim jump into the code
and try to solve this challenge right
now and then when you return back to me
i will of course show you the solution
as well
good luck
okay hopefully that went well way to
solve this is by instead of using the h1
using its smaller sibling the age two
like that it has the exact same
so-called syntax as the age run so
instead of a one you use a two
if we now run this
there you go we have achieved the design
we wanted so great job let's move on
before we move on to the next challenge
there's one thing i want to make sure
that you are aware of and that is that
if you have an html file locally on your
computer and you have a browser what you
can do is simply drag and drop that file
into the browser and then it'll be
rendered
so that is actually more or less the
same thing that's happening here on
scrimba though here we have a mini
browser and the text editor inside of
well your browser because scrim by
itself is browser based so a little bit
meta but it's essentially the same thing
okay now it's time for you to get some
more muscle memory on how to write html
tags and also get to know two new tags
because i want you to create a news
article and more specifically this news
article right here which has a title
that says humans have reached mars it
has a subheading right here and also
some regular text
and the html tags are h1 for the title
h3 for this one you haven't used an h3
for but i think you know how to do it
and then there's finally a p tag for the
text at the bottom p is short for
paragraph
and i have provided a little syntax
example for you here however if you've
understood the logic of how to write
these tags by now it shouldn't come as a
surprise how you do that
okay here is also the text so that you
don't have to write all of that out you
can just copy paste it instead so now
starting here on line 13 write the html
we need in order to create this news
article
okay hopefully that went well let's
start with the h1 i'm going to create
the open and closing tag and then paste
in the text like that running the code
yes
it works moving on to the h3
copying the text
then rerunning the browser and there we
go
finally there is the paragraph
like this
re-running the code and there we go we
have achieved this exact layout great
job let's move on
now you're going to learn about images
because i really think our mars article
needs an image the way to do that is by
using the img tag
so we start with our angle brackets and
then write simply img inside of those
and what's unique about this tag is that
you don't need a closing tag so there is
no closing img as there is a closing age
run or closing paragraph this is simply
not needed so it's often called a
self-closing tag and some people use the
slash at the end of the opening tag like
this just to signify that it is closing
itself however it's not really needed so
we can skip it and i think in general
that less code is better code so i am
just going to skip it however if you
prefer to have it like this that's
totally fine as well okay enough syntax
how do we get this image to work because
right now if we re-render this page
nothing has happened and that is because
we haven't told the image tag which
image we want to render and the way to
do that is by writing src which is short
for source and then we write equals then
two quotes because inside of these two
quotes we're going to specify the image
we want to render and here on the left
hand side you can see i have
mars.jpg it is in the same directory as
our index.html file meaning i can simply
do mars
dot jpg then run the code and there we
go we have our image that is super cool
however you can see that this image
behaves a little bit differently from
our paragraph for example because
where's the paragraph take up the entire
width the image just take up whatever
width it needs leaving us with white
space on the right hand side if the
browser is too wide or cutting off the
image if the browser is too narrow and i
actually want this image to behave like
our other paragraphs so i'm going to
show you a little hack to do that
because normally you'd use css for doing
this but there is a little trick we can
use by simply utilizing the with
attribute that is an attribute just like
source is an attribute and it uses the
same syntax we'll do with equals and
then two quotes and then inside of the
quotes we can write for example 100
percent we now rerun this you can see
yes our image is now scaling with the
size of our browser looking super neat
now as i said this is a hack so if you
show this around to people you might get
this annoying guy saying well
actually that's not valid html according
to the specification but you know what
let's not care about that at this point
you should not give a darn about
specifications validity in aka correct
html you should instead look at yourself
like a hacker who grabs whatever tool
you need in order to get the job done so
now we're going to use this even though
we know it's a hack because later down
the line you're going to learn the
proper way of doing this using css the
language we use for styling websites so
with that out of the way i want to show
you one more thing before i give you a
challenge because one thing that's super
cool is that you can actually borrow
images from wherever you want online so
if you find an image you like you can
borrow it and use it in your project let
me show you how so if we google mars for
example
and click on the images tab and then
click on whatever image we think is cool
for example this one right here and then
in this image view on the right hand
side here you can right click and choose
copy image address once you've copied
that you can simply paste it into the
source attribute so i'm going to remove
mars.jpg and paste in the image address
which i just copied if we now run the
code you can see there we go we have
borrowed this super cool image from
another website online
so it's time for a challenge what i want
you to do now is add a second image to
our article i want you to find one via
google and then place it under the h1
element but above the h3 element so that
is right here and finally remember to
use the width attribute to make the
image as wide as the other elements
i'm going to leave you here with the
mars image again and wish you good luck
go ahead and solve this challenge right
now
okay hopefully that went well what you
need to do is write the angle brackets
img and set the source to whatever image
you found online i'm going to reuse the
one i found earlier like that if we're
rendering this
this is a really wide image by default
that's not what we want we want to scale
with our browser so we need the with
attribute with equals a 100 percent like
that and now we have two super cool
images in our article
both scaling up and down
with the size of the browser great job
let's move on
okay now you're going to learn about
something called nesting which is the
act of nesting html elements inside of
other html elements so let me show it to
you in practice let's say that we want
to group all of these elements here
together what we then do is above all of
the html tags write another html tag and
in this case we'd use the so-called div
which is short for divider however i
don't think that is a very good name i
would rather call this for example a
container though div is what it's called
so we're just going to have to stick
with that now in order to nest elements
inside of this div we'd write the
closing tag below all of the html tags
in our article and then for readability
purposes we'd indent all of the tags in
our article so now our h1 image h3p and
image here are all children of this div
tag right here this doesn't change our
layout at all so this div tag here is
invisible however it has now given us
the ability to target the entire article
just by targeting this div right here
and that is useful if we for example
want to add some styling to our entire
article using css or somehow manipulate
it using javascript which is the
programming language that you use in
browsers and very often you'll actually
see a ton of divs on a page so for
example you'd see another div around
this image element here which then would
have been indented yet another time in
order to signal that this is indeed a
child of this div which again is a child
element of this div now if we were to
visualize an html document it would look
something like this you'd have for
example a div up here and it would have
two children which could be their own
divs like this
and then this left hand div here for
example have an image tag as its first
child and also an h3 as his second child
the other div on the right hand side
could have an h1 tag as its child p tag
as its child maybe even another div as
its child and then if we go yet another
level deep this paragraph tag might have
its own child which could be for example
an a tag which you haven't learned about
yet but which you'll learn about soon as
that is the so-called anchor tag that
allows you to create links on websites
and looking at this visualization you
might think well this kind of looks like
a family tree and yes it does and that
is exactly why we call this structure
the html document tree because we are
inside of an html document and how they
are nested inside of each other becomes
kind of like a tree where you have a
trunk and then branches going out from
that and then yet again new branches
going out from those branches and so on
and so on
so now that you know that let's move on
to the next grim
okay now we're gonna use your newly
acquired internet super powers in order
to perform a little practical joke
because you might have a friend who is
far too obsessed with a sports team for
example i myself am a manchester united
fan and one of the worst things i can
imagine is if some rich billionaire buys
the club and changes its name that would
make me truly outrageous so what we're
gonna do now is change the news on bbc
sports so that you then can show this
page to a man united fan and thus make
them really upset while you get a good
laugh
so let's go ahead and do this here on
the bbc sports page on this top article
here i'm going to right click on the
text and then you can see it gives me
the option to choose inspect
now note that this is on a chrome
browser as that is what i'm using if
you're in a different browser there
might be slightly different steps here
or a different wording but overall in
general the steps are the same so i'm
going to click on expect and then you
can see that it opens up this
panel on the bottom of the browser this
is called the developer tools and here
you can see we are in the elements tab
and that shows us the html elements that
are on the page
and here the one we have chosen now
which happens to light up this area on
the bbc site contains the title of our
article and it is an a tag which i've
just briefly mentioned and that you're
going to learn more about later now we
can't see any text here so i'm going to
click on this age tag and there you can
see it contains an h3 tag nested inside
of it if we click on that one as well
you can see that there we see the text
that is rendered in the browser so here
we can double click on that text and
change it for example to something as
awful as jeff bezos to buy man united
and rename the club after himself oh my
god that is about the worst piece of
news any united fan can read so if we
now hit enter there you can see boom we
have changed the text on bbc now let's
click on this paragraph here as well
open it up because there we can also
change the text that is written
underneath the title let's paste in the
u.s billionaire says he doesn't follow
the premier league but wants to own the
club to grow his personal brand
this just gets worse and worse so now if
we hit enter that is also rendered in
the browser now i'm going to scroll a
little bit up in the dev tools here and
hover over this div tag here because as
you can see that highlights our image so
it seems to be that our image is nested
inside of a div tag let's open it up by
clicking on this triangle and there we
can see another div tag well okay still
highlighting the image let's open up
that one as well oh wow
there we have yet another div tag a div
inside of a div inside of a div this is
web development in a nutshell let's open
it up again and there yes we can see our
image tag i'll scroll a bit down and you
can see there are tons of different
attributes here we're going to ignore
almost all of these and then instead
direct our attention towards the src
attribute that one we know because that
is the one we need to change in order to
change this image so now let's open up a
new window search for jeff bezos click
on an image we like for example this one
right here right click on it and choose
copy image address then can do now is
double click on this source and then
remove the existing source inside of the
quotes like that and then paste in our
image of jeff bezos however if we now
hit enter you can see nothing changed
and that is because bbc is a little bit
fancy here they use another attribute
called src set which helps the browser
render different sized images on
different types of screens depending on
what kind of image is appropriate for
the given screen the website is rendered
on so what we're going to do here is
just double click on the src set so that
everything's highlighted and just delete
all of it and then hit enter and boom
there you go we have jeff bezos looking
pretty ready to acquire this football
club and rename it bezos united finally
i'm going to close this panel by
clicking on the x in the right corner
here and there you go we have our
article so now the final step is just to
take this site show it to someone who is
a manchester united fan and get a good
laugh
now a final notice if you refresh this
page you will lose your changes because
you only made your changes locally and
when you refresh it the entire page gets
the fresh data from the database of bbc
and not from whatever local changes you
did and since it is local that also of
course implies that your changes only
happen on your computer you don't change
bbc in production of course so go ahead
and play around with some sites online
see if you can come up with a fun little
practical joke for a friend
have fun and i'll see you in the next
scrim
now you're going to learn about your
very first interactive html element and
that is the button tag because the
buttons are all over the web so to
create a button simply start with your
angle bracket and a button opening tag
and then a button closing tag like that
and in between the two tags you write
whatever text you want inside of your
button
now as you can see it's styled with a
background color that also has a border
around it and you can even click it now
this button doesn't do anything in order
to hook this up with some kind of
feature for example trigger a purchase
then you'd have to learn javascript and
that is outside the scope of this course
but something you'll learn later in the
front-end developer career path so for
now our button will just be there and
pretend to do something while actually
being pretty useless now that you've
seen this once i want to put you on the
spot and give you a challenge i want you
to create a layout according to the
design in this slide so imagine that you
are building a website where people are
to sign up then it would be very natural
to have something like this where you
have an h1 at the top welcoming them a
paragraph with a little message and then
a sign up button so i want you to create
this layout you don't have to write the
text because i've provided it here just
make sure that you set up the html tags
correctly so that it renders properly on
the page
good luck
okay hopefully that went well let's now
do it together i'll start with the
welcome h1 tag like that paste that in
and boom there we go
next up there's the paragraph
opening tag closing tag then pasting the
text in between running this code it
still looks correct
finally the button like that with sign
up written inside of it and boom there
we go we have our completely useless
signup form that doesn't do anything but
in the next scrim we're going to add on
to this so stay tuned and then i'll see
you there
the sign up section we have here is
actually pretty useless because there's
no way for our users to add for example
their username or password so in this
script we're gonna fix that which leads
us to the input tag the input tag is
just like images a self-closing tag so
we only write the opening tag and not
the closing tag like we do with buttons
for example however we have to specify
what kind of a type our input should be
so it has this type attribute
just as the image has a source attribute
and the value of the type can be a range
of different options but we're going to
start off with the most common one and
that is text
if we run this you can see we get this
nice little text box in the browser
another handy attribute is the
placeholder that's where we can give the
user a hint about what kind of data
we're asking for so for example enter
username like that if we run this you
can see it says enter username okay
let's do a mini challenge we of course
want them to enter their password as
well so i want you to create a new input
field on line 4 which is identical to
the one on line three though it should
say enter password in the placeholder as
opposed to enter username and don't just
copy this line and change this word i
want you to get some muscle memory here
so go ahead and do that right now
okay hopefully you did like this input
type equals text
placeholder enter password like that
and there we go now you can enter a
username and a password however in the
real world passwords are never exposed
like that the characters are always
masked and the way we achieve that is
simply by changing the type from text to
password like that if we run the code
now you can see the username is shown
but the password is a mask really nice
and speaking of this type attribute here
it can take a range of different values
which turn into really interesting
interactive elements on the page
for example you can do type equals date
let's say you want the user to add their
birth date during sign up and then you
get this nice little date picker or you
can do type equals time for example if
you want the user to be able to
configure when they should get some kind
of notification that gives the user a
nice time picker
or let's say you want to give the user
way to configure the theme of their
profile with colors then you can do type
equals color and then you get this
powerful color picker where the user can
add basically any color there is through
moving around on these dots so the input
tag is a really versatile tool in your
toolbox
okay let's move on to the main challenge
because i want our users
to have profile pictures which means
that you need to add an html input field
that lets them upload image files and
i'm not going to tell you what kind of
type that input field has
i'm just going to show you how it looks
or just like this you've probably seen
it online before it's basically a button
and when you click it it lets you choose
an image from your local file system and
the reason i want you to figure out what
the type attributes should be here is
because being good at googling is
actually a huge part of being a good
programmer and the two are actually not
that easy to separate from each other so
this gives you a way to practice those
googling skills and i'm going to give
you a hint that the keywords you should
use are found in this last sentence
right here
so go ahead and solve this challenge
right now and then i will of course show
you the solution when you return back to
me
okay hopefully that went well let's do
this the keywords i think are important
here are html input because we know
we're looking for an html input tag and
then what is our intent well it is to
upload image files and i think google
can handle this just by combining html
input upload image files if we just
paste that into google let's see what we
get and as you can see when we search
for that we get a first hit from
developer.mozilla.org
let's click into that and here you can
see the title is input type equals file
and we get this little code snippet here
it also says input elements with type
file let the user choose one or more
files from their device storage sounds
pretty good so far let's zoom in on the
code here and there you can see that
they are actually using the profile
picture example themselves choose a
profile picture with this button which
looks suspiciously similar to what i
just showed you a couple of minutes ago
so i think we've found it what we're
looking for is type equals file
let's add this up above the sign up
button but
type equals file like that we run this
code yes there we go we get this button
which looks like exactly what we're
looking for
okay now we're gonna move on from using
google to building google i mean how
cool is that you've learned html for
just about 30 minutes and now you're
gonna build the most visited website in
the world that is just amazing as you
can see here on the similar web overview
google is at the very top amongst the
most visited websites in the world
beating sites like youtube facebook
instagram wikipedia and all the way at
10th a pornography site of course
and by the way it's a little bit sad to
see that this adult site has almost
three times the average visa duration of
wikipedia so a pretty deep insight about
humankind right there
anyway we are going to build google.com
and it'll look like this
however now you're probably wondering
how can we make a page look like this
this doesn't look like regular html and
that is because i've cheated a little
bit and added this line up here which is
a link tag to
styles.css and if you look at the file
menu in the left hand side you can see
that actually we have a file called
styles.css which contains exactly that
cascading style sheets which is the
language for styling websites and which
you're going to learn all about a little
bit later in this course however for now
i want you to completely ignore this
what you should do instead is just
create the four html tags we need in
order to create a google.com clone and
then this css will be pulled in and take
care of styling the elements as they
should be so that it will look like this
and to give you a hint this is an image
file pointing to google.png the file
i've added here and png is just a file
format just like jpeg you can use it in
the exact same way as we used jpegs
earlier on so you should know how to do
that and this is an input field you have
to figure out what kind of type it is i
think you might have a clue
this is a button on the left hand side
and this is also a button so basically
it is these four tags you need to create
in order to build a clone of the world's
biggest website so go ahead and do that
start down here and ignore the line up
here and then when you return back to me
i will of course show you the solution
as well
good luck
okay hopefully that went well
if not no worries let's do it together
so starting with the image tag for the
google logo
i'm going to do
imd like that and it's a self-closing
one so i don't need a closing tag but i
need a source attribute and it should
point to the google.png file so i'll
just do google.png
like that and let's run this and oh
there we go we got the logo
okay moving on
let's do the input field also a self
closing tag
running the code and there we go we have
a input field looking pretty good
okay next up there's the two buttons one
saying google search and one saying i'm
feeling lucky so i'm gonna add both of
these
button google search
and then since i'm lazy i'm gonna copy
it
and do i'm feeling lucky like that
let's run this
and there we go we have a google clone
with just four html elements
so if you did this give yourself a pat
on the back it is fantastically well
done you should really be proud of
yourself and if you didn't manage to do
it just try it again and i think you'll
make it
at this point it might be a good idea to
take a little break and digest
everything you've learned and then when
you are ready to continue i will see you
in the next scrim
okay now that you've built google.com
you probably want to showcase your
project on some kind of a portfolio page
so let's pretend we're creating exactly
that
here we have the index.html page the
main page of our portfolio and as you
can see it says pierre harold borgen
developer teacher procrastinator so a
really good description of myself though
what it lacks is some kind of page or
section which describes my projects
though i have actually created the
underlying page for exactly that over
here on
work.html as you can see this is a few
tags that describes my google.com
project however there's no way for the
users to know this the only way they can
get to this page now is by actually
typing
work.html up in the browser here and
then it is rendered we don't want that
instead we want some kind of link from
the index page that is this one that
points towards the work.html
and in order for us to achieve that you
have to learn about anchor tags aka
links an anchor tag is simply an html
tag with an a so let's open and close an
anchor tag and write for example
check out my projects
here
like that if we run this
it seemingly looks just like our
paragraph and we can't click it either
and that is because for anchor tags you
also have to provide it with an href
attribute that's short for hypertext
reference really fancy scary looking
word right there don't worry about it
all this attribute does is decide where
the link should point to so if we do
equal and then two quotes we can inside
the quotes simply write work dot html if
we now run this you can see that it
renders as a link and when we click it
boom we're taken to the work.html page
really nice
now another thing i want to show you
with anchor tags is that you can nest
them inside of other tags and actually
inline in a text block so let's say that
we want to link to google.com from this
site then we'll create a paragraph which
can say something like check out the
live
demo here
and we only want the here word to be a
clickable link well then we'll simply
wrap the anchor tag around here as well
and we'll close it before we close the
paragraph and then we'll do the href
paste in the url to google.com
now this is a link that points to an
external website not to any of our pages
so if we run this you can see that the
link is now only over the here word
however if i click this link now the
scrimba mini browser will try to head
over to google.com and we only allow the
mini browser to render scrimba projects
at the moment so that won't work instead
what i'm going to do is make this link
open in a new tab the way we do that is
through a new attribute so first i'm
just going to break this into a new line
just to improve the readability a little
bit
and then here i'm going to write target
equals
underscore blank
now that is a cryptic way of saying that
you want the link to open up in a new
tab i know but if we now run this if you
click on this link what you'll see is
that in your main browser a new tab will
be opened at the google.com homepage so
i'm not going to go deeper into why it's
called target equals underscore blank
but this is the way to do it i of course
wish that html had a better solution for
this for example new tab equals yes that
would have made a lot more sense to me
but this is how it is you just have to
accept it okay that was a lot of talking
from me now it's time for challenge
i want you to create an anchor tag that
links back to the index.html page
because if user ends up on this page
they also need a way to get back to the
main page so create that link here
however you want and then i will show
you the solution when you return back to
me
okay hopefully that went well let's
create this anchor tag i'll wrap it
inside of a paragraph and right turn to
home page and then i'll simply wrap the
homepage word in an anchor tag like that
and point that anchor tag
to
index.html if we run this you can see
return to homepage and if we click that
we are back at the homepage
great job let's move on
okay we're back at our google example
here and now i want you to add a anchor
tag to the page because sometimes you'll
see that google ads a little text
underneath the buttons for example
something about privacy like we protect
your privacy and then with a learn how
link then you can click on to read more
about that so that is exactly what i
want you to do
i want you to add an anchor tag that
points to blog.html
as you can see i've added a blog.html
file up here and i want you to wrap the
link inside of a paragraph tag so just
as it is here you can see it's an entire
paragraph here
but the anchor tag is only wrapping the
second sentence so go ahead and do that
right now
okay hopefully that went well let's do
it we'll start with the paragraph
opening and closing tag and then we
protect your privacy like that here
we're going to add the anchor tag inline
so i'll do a
open and close
and do an href as well point it to
blog.html
and the text should be
learn how let's run this and boom there
we go we have added a nice little link
here if we want to learn more about
google privacy then we can click this
link but
not much to see here turns out that
privacy probably isn't as important for
a company who makes money by showing ads
to users
anyway we can click on this link return
back to google and there we are great
job solving this challenge let's move on
okay now we're going to talk about how
to structure html documents because the
structure we have here isn't actually
correct it's a very simplified structure
compared to how it should be though it
does work so i didn't want to give you
all of these theoretical boring
structure things up front i wanted you
to build stuff from the get-go without
the added complexity of the proper html
structure as my philosophy is first make
it work and then make it better however
now we're at the point where we should
make it better
so let's have a look at how to structure
html documents properly and html is
actually quite like us humans it has a
head and a body and what do you place
inside of these elements well in the
body that's where you place the tags you
see on the page and that is these ties
here so our image our input button
paragraph and our anchor tag because
these are visible on the page now of
course the css styling up here also
results in a different layout but the
link tag in itself is not something that
is rendered on the page so it should not
be in the body tag
so let's just add the body right here
ravi starting tag and then the closing
tag down here on line nine and then
we'll indent everything inside of the
body like that
so moving on to the head that's where we
add metadata and what do i mean about
that well it can be many things for
example styles so this link right here
should be inside of the head
we'll do head
and then close it off here like that
other things we'll have in the head is
the title tag so let's have a look at
what that is
if we navigate over to the bbc football
page and zoom in on the top you can see
up in the tab it has a icon it says
football dash bbc sport
and all of this data both the fav icon
at the beginning here and this sentence
is controlled by elements we place
inside of the head tag so if we want to
add a title text in a tab
simply write title and then for example
google.com would be natural to write
here though we haven't implemented tabs
in the mini browser here on scrimba so
you won't see that but had we done that
it would have looked like this though it
of course would have said google.com
instead so we don't need that so let's
just remove it another thing that is
controlled by tags inside of the heads
tag is how articles are shown on social
media so if we zoom out a little bit
here and click in on this article at the
top here and if we now were to take this
url and share it for example on twitter
what we then would get is a different
heading on the twitter card than what
the article natively has and also a
different image than the main image on
the article so this is metadata that has
told twitter that if this article is
shared on twitter we want you to use
this heading instead of the heading that
is inside of the article and also this
image instead of this image right here
so that was a lot about the head tag
we're not going to use the head that
much but i wanted to give you an
understanding about why it is important
now there's one more html tag we need
and that is the html tag in itself which
should wrap all other html tags so we
need to up here at the very top right
html and at the very bottom close it off
and also then indent everything inside
of it
like that
and then there's one more thing which is
to me a little bit annoying that we need
that is the doctype declaration because
you have to tell the browser that we're
actually using html5 and not html4
that's just a version of the html
specification and that is done by this
line up here you can see it's blue and
it starts with an exclamation mark so
it's actually not an html tag it's just
metadata for the browser because if you
don't do this browser will assume that
you're not using html5 but an earlier
version of html and that might result in
some quirks on the page though in 99 of
cases there will be no difference
between adding this and not having it so
at times you'll probably see tutorials
on scrimba where i've forgotten to add
this because for the purposes of our
example it won't make any difference but
if you have something that you want to
deploy to the world and have in
production then you just have to accept
that you need this sign up at the top
and sometimes you'll see people write it
in capital letters as well doesn't
really matter i prefer having lowercase
letters okay that was a lot of theory
it's time to get your hands on the
keyboard
and luckily though we have a blog.html
file which doesn't have the proper html
structure so your challenge is simply to
add the proper html document structure
to this page and i don't want you to
copy paste my tags but write them out on
your own instead so that you build up
that ever so important muscle memory go
ahead and give this one a shot right now
and then i will of course do it myself
when you return back to me
okay let's do this
i'll start with the body
as that should wrap our visible elements
on the page
like that
then i'll do the head though we haven't
linked to the styles on this page so the
head will actually just be empty like
this so i'll keep it on one line moving
on it is the html document and that
should wrap everything
so i'll do like that and at the very end
i'll add the doctype html to tell the
browser that we are working with html5
and not html4
so if we now navigate over to the
blog.html site you can see that nothing
has seemingly changed and as goes for
the main page itself this structure
we've added doesn't result in any
visible change we just have a more
correct underlying code file to work
with great job let's move on
now you are going to learn about lists
because let's say that you for example
want to create some kind of a tribute
site it could be for whatever for
example
uh i don't know the beijing winter
olympics
if that's one of your interests you
might want to create a tribute site
where you list out the top nations who
competed or something like that and if
so you would have to use an html list
so let's first just figure out which
nation actually won the most medals in
the beijing olympics so i'm gonna click
on the medals tab here on the olympic
site and here we got it and zoom in a
little bit and oh wow
it turns out that actually norway
my country completely
obliterated
the other countries with 16 gold medals
over other nations like
germany china and the us
that is
really astonishing especially
considering the fact that the size of
the norwegian population is this
compared to the other nations here i
mean way to go norway we gotta create
this list in html okay so how do we do
that well we have to use two different
tags one tag for wrapping the entire
list and another tag for each list item
the wrapper tag
is one called ol that's short for
ordered list
and then inside of the ordered list we
place the list items the li tags
so when we do this and write no right
here
render this you can see that the browser
gives us a number as it is the first
item in the list and also indents it a
little bit from the left hand side
so adding another one
here
it then gets the number two and is
stacked below the first one
so let's add the final ones
like that
looking pretty good we have a list just
like on the olympic site
now if we wanted to be a little bit more
diplomatic here and not brag too much
about this insane victory by norway we
could change this ol to a ul
that is an unordered list
and as you can see then the numbers are
replaced with dots
now you might ask yourself well why do
we need these unordered lists they look
like kind of boring elements you just
use in word documents or something like
that well once you learn about css
you'll be able to style your list
however you want and thus make it much
more usable if we for example head over
to bbc sports here and right click on
the navbar here and click inspect then
we'll see that actually this entire
navbar is an unordered list item
with each of the categories being its
own list items so lists are all over the
web and important to learn
okay now i'm going to remove all of this
and give you a quick little challenge
because i want you to create an ordered
list inside of the body tag
and then fill it with your top three
favorite foods
so go ahead and give this a shot right
now
okay hopefully that went well let's do
it so we start out with an old tag
that we're opening up and closing
and as for the list items even though
norway is a great winter olympics
country it is a truly mediocre country
when it comes to food so my favorite
food is definitely from other places
than where i'm from i love italian pasta
i love japanese ramen soup
and lately i've been really into podtai
so there we have it rendered out on the
page really good job learning about html
lists let's keep up the pace and move on
with the course
okay now you have arrived to the main
project of this section you are going to
build a website about yourself and we're
going to personalize it as well plus
deploy to the world so that anyone
around the world can visit this website
it is going to be so much fun
and here is the website itself as you
can see it's pretty simple with hardly
any styling by default just a little bit
on the button and the input field here
as with the border around this image and
building this lightly styled design
is the first part part one of the
challenge and then in part two of the
challenge we are going to go crazy on
the styling with just a few parameters
that you are to tweak and it's going to
look so cool but let's not get ahead of
ourselves here let's first just run
through what kind of tags you need in
order to build this website
so first off there is an image tag and
the image you should use should be added
to the file system on the left hand side
here as you can see there is a pair.jpg
image here and the way to add an image
to this file system is simply by drag
and dropping it over this section
next up there's an h1 here as well with
the title
of course you should write your own name
not my name and then there's an h2
heading as we need some fun facts about
you the fun facts itself are built using
an unordered list plus list items inside
of the ul element then there is a
paragraph with a link nested inside of
it that should go to your linkedin
profile
so the point here obviously is to
replace all of this information with fun
facts about you with your name with your
image your linkedin profile so that when
you share this with the scrimba
community other people will be able to
get to know you better
and then finally we have an input field
here and a button that won't really do
anything because we're not hooking this
up with a real newsletter we are just
pretending that you have a newsletter
that people can sign up to so once
you've done this you've completed part
one of the challenge and you've also
filled up this body element here with
html tags
next you'll move on to part two of the
challenge what you'll do there is take
your existing design and modify it
so if we head over to the
index.javascript file you can see that
there are a bunch of so-called
javascript functions which probably look
really scary at this point but don't
worry the only thing you're going to do
here is take the word that you see
inside of the quotes right here and
replace them with one of the words that
are commented out in the line above
because this will give you the
opportunity to change the styling on the
page
according to what word you change this
argument to so what you are to do here
is look at the name of this function it
says favorite movie genre and what is
that do you like space movies scary
movies military movies romantic movies
cowboy movies and so on and then just
take your preference and change it like
this so if you choose cowboy for example
what then will happen is that the font
on the website suddenly became like a
western movie that's pretty cool
and moving on
here you are to answer what is your
favorite fruit is it watermelon tomato
banana if it for example is banana then
you should replace regular with banana
and what will then happen if you run the
cold then suddenly your page is banana
colored
really nice
so now you are a cowboy banana that's
pretty cool
finally there's two more parameters you
can tweak first tell me is your favorite
mode on your computer light mode or dark
mode if you choose dark
and run the code again then you can see
the colors have flipped and now it is
primarily dark with the brown background
and the light yellow color
as opposed to how it was previously with
the yellow background and brown text
color
and then at the very end you are to
choose what kind of style you like your
edges to be
sharp soft or round let's say you like
round well then you'll simply replace
sharp with round and there we go we have
a nice round layout where the image and
the input and button
now have a much more round feeling to it
so what happens here is that these are
javascript functions that execute code
which you can see further down in the
index.js file and change the layout
accordingly
though you should ignore everything
below this line don't even try to
understand it it's far outside the scope
of this course and you're gonna learn
javascript later in the front-end
developer path anyway so it's nothing
for you to worry about right now
now i'm going to reset all of these
set these two to regular and these two
to light and
sharp as that is the default styling
that we should have and then i'll leave
you with this image right here as it now
is your turn to build this layout
personalize it with the javascript
functions so that you have your very own
completely unique website
so go ahead and do this right now and
then i will see you when you return back
to me
okay hopefully that went well let's now
do this together first we need the image
tag so i'm gonna do img
the source is the
pier.jpg which i'd already added
yes there we can see it is rendering
properly
next up there is an h1
hi my name is pear like that
very good
moving on we have the h2
fun facts
about me
like that and then there's the
unordered list and the list items
so i'll do ul
close that ul because the list items
need to be inside of the ul and the
first one is 36 years old
i'm gonna copy this one
like that and
i live in
norway
and i sing
in a choir
and there we go looking pretty good
next up there is the paragraph with the
inline anchor tag
here's the paragraph
connect with me on
linkedin like that
oops it should say let me on linkedin
here and then
we are to wrap linkedin here
into an ahref
like that
and then i'm going to paste in the url
to my linkedin right here and if you
actually want to connect with me on
linkedin
feel free to click on this link as soon
as i've added the target equals
underscore blank so that it opens up a
new tab
okay finally we we need to add the input
and the button
input type
text like that and button
with join
newsletter as the text
yes that worked and we finally just need
the placeholder in the input
and here we're going to write enter
email
enter email
like that and
that actually
looks pretty good to me that is what we
were looking for yes
okay next step we are going to
personalize it this will be easy for me
i really love movies about space so i'm
going to choose space here as my
favorite movie genre it gives me this
really neat sci-fi-ish font and i am a
huge avocado fan so gotta do that
looking pretty good
i tend to prefer both light mode and
dark mode but let's try dark yeah
not bad
and as for favorite edge style i'm not
gonna do completely round not completely
sharp but something in between
as i think the answer often is something
in between
and yes there we go pretty cool website
now the final thing i want you to do is
head back to your note where you created
your website and then click on the
bottom right icon the cog wheel and
choose download as zip because that'll
download your project through your local
machine and we need that in order to
deploy this project over the next few
scripts
so what i'd recommend you to do is on
your computer create a dev folder
and move that zip file you just
downloaded to this dev folder double
click on it to open it that'll give it
this long obscure id so if i were you i
would change that to something
understandable for example personal site
and just save it so that you have your
project neatly placed with a good name
on your local computer so that we are
ready to share it with the world over
the next few scrims it is going to be
epic so i look forward to see you in the
next room after you've done all of this
i'll see you there
in order to get your personal site live
on the world wide web we are going to
use a service called netlify as it is
both free easy to use and powerful as
it's used by tons of professional
developers so if you're following this
course on scrimba.com just click on this
slide right here and you'll be taken to
netlify or if you're following this
course on youtube just head over to
netlify.com and you'll get to the exact
same page once you're there i want you
to click at the sign up button as
that'll take you to an authentication
screen where you can choose a bunch of
different options i am going to go with
the email option so i'll click on that
and fill in my email and also choose a
password then i'll click sign up which
again will trigger netify to send a
verification email to my inbox so i'll
head over to my inbox and click on
verify email that'll take me to the
netlify onboarding page where i have to
tell them a little bit about myself so
here i'm going to say that i'm using
netlify for personal reasons and opening
up this select box here i'm going to
classify myself as a hobby developer and
my first project will be a personal
slash portfolio site then i'll scroll up
it down and give my team a name i'm just
going to call my team peer as it's
common to use your first name but you
can choose whatever name you want on
your team once you're done with all of
that click on the setup and continue
then you are taken to the page where you
are to deploy your first project you can
either import an existing project start
from a template or deploy manually and
that's exactly what we are going to do
so what i want you to do here is return
back to the folder you created in the
previous scrim called personal site and
then mark all of the files and drag and
drop them into this rectangle once
you've done that your browser might ask
you if you actually want to upload the
files to the site just confirm that by
clicking on upload and then netlify
starts its magic at this point they are
working under the hood deploying your
site to the web so here you might have
to wait for a couple of minutes until
you see this icon right here turn into a
screenshot of your personal site now if
that doesn't happen within a couple of
minutes just try to refresh the site
itself as that'll probably do the trick
then you can simply click on this url
right here and boom you have deployed
your site so that anyone in the world
can access it that is a phenomenally
great job and you should truly be proud
of yourself
the final step i think you should do now
is to share your creation with the world
i would recommend you to use either
linkedin or twitter as both of those
have huge communities of developers so
what you should do is basically what
jolene and jess are doing here share a
link to your personal site write a
couple of sentences about it and also
feel free to mention anyone else who've
been involved in this project and add a
relevant hashtag like jess is doing here
for example 100 days of code that is a
great hashtag to follow and to use as it
puts you in touch with a bunch of other
people online who are going through the
same learning journey as you are so i am
looking forward to see your personal
site either on linkedin or twitter and
i'm also looking forward to see you in
the next scrim
guess who is my favorite person in the
world right now you are because you have
just completed the html section of this
course and that is really well done now
let's have a quick look at what you've
learned starting off you learned about
the core html tags that is for example
the heading tags like the h1 and h2 and
also the paragraph tag next you learned
about nesting which is how we place
certain tags inside of other tags which
again are inside of other tags creating
this tree-like html structure
and you learned about buttons and input
fields which are two tags that help us
make our website interactive so that
users can perform actions on our website
we also learned about the important
anchor tag as that is what allows you to
create links in between different
websites or internally on a website in
between pages
another thing which we had to look at
was the document structure because a
proper html document requires a doctype
an html tag a head tag and a body tag
and then of course you learned about
lists both the unordered list you can
see here and also ordered lists and then
at the end we did something super cool
which was to deploy our website using
netlify so that it lives out on the
world wide web so at this point you
might be a little bit overwhelmed that's
totally okay feel free to take a little
break now and when you return back you
are going to learn about css aka
cascading style sheets which is the tool
we use in order to make our websites
look good so that is going to be a lot
of fun i'm looking forward to see you in
the next section
welcome to the second section of this
course where you are going to graduate
from html into the world of css or
cascading style sheets as it stands for
this is super exciting because now
you'll be able to make your sites look
beautiful as well
so the main project of this section is
actually the google.com homepage because
this time around you are going to
write the css as well
and this probably looks a little bit
frightening right now but don't worry
i'm going to take you through it step by
step and actually before we get going
with google we're going to get you
familiar with the syntax here and have
some fun destroying wikipedia.org so
it's going to be a lot of fun and we
have no time to lose let's just get
started
okay so let's get you writing your first
lines of css
straight out of the gate
as you can see here we have an html file
which has a body that simply has please
accept our cookies as text directly in
the body tag and that is rendered here
in the mini browser however as you'll
notice the style doesn't exactly look
like default browser styling and that is
because we've added this line here which
says link meaning it's linking to
something and what kind of relation does
this link cast to our html well it's rel
stylesheet it is a sheet that contains
styles
and where does this sheet live well that
is dictated by the href attribute which
you probably recognize from anchor tags
and it's pointing to styles.css
and lo and behold in our file system we
have a styles.css
file and there we can see a few lines of
scary looking codes you've never seen
before perhaps however don't worry we're
going to go through this
so what happens here is that this css
code is being pulled into the html file
by this line 3 here and then it is
applied to the website when it is
rendered so if we were to comment out
this line three here and re-run the
example it'll look very boring like this
so let's undo that it doesn't exactly
look great now either but
it's at least some styling although this
cookie widget is a little bit weirdly
designed in my opinion which leads me to
your challenge you are going to redesign
this cookie widget by
changing the values inside of this body
selector and now you might ask well what
is a selector
okay let's go through that because that
is the basic css syntax you need to know
in order to solve this challenge
so css works by selecting certain
elements on the page that is html
elements and then styling them however
you want
and the element you select is what you
start with when writing a css rule here
we are selecting the body that is the
exact same thing we're doing here and
what's our body well that is this tag
right here
then in order to apply some specific
styling to the body tag we write an
opening curly bracket and a closed curly
bracket and then inside of those
brackets we have something called a
property which in this case is color and
a value which in this case is red
so here we're saying that the color
which is actually text color that's what
color means here the text color in the
body should be red so if i now change
the color property from blue to red you
can see in the mini browser we have
changed the text inside of our body to
red because if we head over to the html
this text is indeed inside of our body
now
as you might have noticed as well the
property is followed by colon and the
value is followed by semicolon and you
have to have that notation
otherwise you'll break the example
so what i want you to do now is redesign
this cookie widget
make sure you change all of the listed
css properties that's background color
font size font way text align and margin
top and what you'll change it to is up
to you but i've given you the hint of
what kind of values the properties
expect here in the comments on the right
hand side you can see comments in css is
done with this star and slash character
so the grayed out text as in with the
html is not interpreted by the browser
it's just help text for you in order to
solve this challenge
and i'm intentionally not giving you any
more information about what each of
these properties mean because i think
they're pretty self-explanatory so i
want you to experiment with changing
them and draw your own conclusions as to
what for example the font size does to
the styling on our page and then once
you've done this once you've redesigned
the cookie widget move on to the next
scrim and then i will show you how i
would do it as well
good luck
so really good job writing your first
lines of css that is no small
accomplishment now i'm going to show you
how i would design my cookie widget so i
want my widget to have cookie colors so
for my background property which is what
sets the background color of the body
which fills up the entire browser at
this point i'm going to choose a color
called
saddle brown like that and you might
wonder well how do i know that saddle
brown is a color that css supports well
you might have noticed as you wrote css
values that vs code or editor starts
suggesting values for you as you start
typing so that is how i found saddle
brown
this suggestion box here isn't recorded
by scrimba itself so you won't see it in
recording but you will see it as you
interact with the code yourself so we
have the background now let's move on to
the color here i don't have red i want
to have something a bit more cookie-ish
and it just happens to be a color called
chocolate like that starting to look
pretty cookish
the font size i want to be larger so i'm
going to set that to 25 yes that's
pretty good okay font weight that
dictates the thickness of the font can
be lighter normal or bold i want it to
be
bold like that because we want to state
clearly to our users please accept our
cookies and text align can be left
center or right
let's first see what it does if i do
left you can see now it start on the
left hand side will be a bit more
visible if i enlarge in the browser and
i can do center yep there it is centered
and right there it is pushed all the way
to the right hand side let's center it
for this time
which means that we only have the margin
top left and that is also a pixel value
as the font size was but it's set to
five pixels let's remove that let's
bring it down to zero and see what
happens oh you can see the text jumped
up a little bit and now there's no
spacing in between the top of the
browser and the text itself
so it adds margin that is spacing to the
top so this means that we can use this
in order to push the text down to the
middle of the browser kind of centering
it vertically let's try for example 20
not fully centered let's do 40 yes that
looks really good
now before we move on there's one thing
i want to mention which is that normally
when you deal with colors in css you
likely won't see these plain english
descriptions of colors instead you'll
rather see is something like this so
this weird
six character long expression with a
hashtag in front of it and this is
called a hex color code and that is a
description of the color it's a recipe
for how much red green and blue this
specific saddle brown color consists of
because as you can see nothing changed
in our browser when i did this but if i
change the recipe for example changing
this 8 to 1 boom you can see that the
color is suddenly completely different
now we're not going to go into how these
hex color codes work on the inside as
that's outside of the scope of this
lecture and it's certainly not expected
that you remember what kind of colors
the different hex codes refer to so now
you might be a little bit confused and
overwhelmed about all of these
properties don't worry about it you're
not expected to remember everything
right now i just wanted to dip your toes
into the water so that you were exposed
to them and then you'll certainly get
plenty of practice with all of these
properties later down the line so let's
just move on
now that you know enough css to be
dangerous
let's use your newly acquired superpower
in order to destroy wikipedia
and for that we need a wikipedia page
and about the coolest one there is is
this list of helicopter prison escapes i
mean oh my god how insane is that so
click this image and you'll be taken to
this article and then i'll show you step
by step how we can destroy it with css
so the first thing you need to do is to
right click that'll open this menu where
you can choose inspect and once you
click that the dev tools will open then
choose the icon in the far left as that
allows you to use your cursor to select
elements on the page so that when you
hover over an element like this one
you'll see that the dev tools select
sets for you so if you move your cursor
over to the logo you'll see that one
selected and if you move your cursor
over to the main part of the screen here
you can see it selects the entire
article
once you're on that selection i want you
to click because that'll select the
specific html element here in the
elements tab
and don't worry about all of this you do
not need to recognize the tags and
attributes and everything you see here
what i instead want you to do is head
over to the right hand side where you
see element dot style click there and
you'll be able to actually apply css
directly to this page so you can for
example write background red and boom
there we have really ruined this article
then if you select another element on
the page from this body content element
here you can do the exact same thing
click on the element style and now for
example write font size and 30 pixels
and there you go now you can click on
the x icon in the far right corner here
and then you can read about these
helicopter prison escapes with a really
bad background and huge text if that's
what you prefer so feel free to spend an
hour in this article and i will see you
in the next scrim
okay so now it's time for you to yet
again build the google.com homepage but
this time around you're also going to
write the css so that you'll understand
everything that goes into building this
elegantly designed search engine as you
can see i've set up the basic skeleton
here in the html file for you
in the body tag we have an image
which is pointing to the google.png
image which lies in the same directory
as our index.html folder up here
and we have an input type text which is
our search field and we're only going to
start with these two elements and then
later move on to the buttons now as you
can see in the mini browser here this
looks horrible it has no styling so the
logo is far too large the input field
doesn't look very good so in short
there's a lot of work to do here but
before we can start writing css you need
to link to the css file you can see i
have a style css here which just sets
the background of the body to red as a
way of testing whether it is actually a
link to the html currently it's not you
are going to have to link to the css
file on your own and if you remember a
couple of scrims back i showed you how
to do that though please don't look back
at that scrim in order to solve this
challenge instead google it because i do
that almost every single time i have to
link from an html file to a css file so
you should not be ashamed for googling
such a quote-unquote simple thing
instead just do that right now because
it's important practice and then when
you come back i will show you how i
would do it as well
okay hopefully that went well
now let's have a look at how we can
solve this
so i would simply type how to link to
css into google and click at the top
result this happens to be a w3schools
article here you can see that there's a
few different ways you can import css
into the html file but we're only going
to worry about the first one here called
external css
as you can see if we scroll a bit down
what we do is we type link rel equal
style sheet and href with a pointer with
the css file itself so
we'll do
link l equals
i'll sheet
href equals
styles.css
and then closing it and if we now
refresh the browser boom there we go it
is red looking horrible
so we can remove that so that it looks
white again but now we know that we have
linked the css and the html together so
we are ready to move on and start
styling our page
the first thing we want to fix in our
example here are the widths of the
elements because if we compare it to the
finished sign you can see that the input
field is meant to be wider than the logo
however in our example that's not the
case quite the opposite actually the
logo is much wider than the input field
so we need to shrink the logo and then
make the input field wider so i'm going
to start and do one of these and then
you will do the other
i happen to know that the width we want
to have on this input field is 400
pixels
what i'm then going to do is
target the input field
using the element name
and create a css selector just writing
input then open and close curly bracket
and then simply write
with and 400 px and boom there you can
see suddenly the input field widened
quite a lot and as you might have
noticed we're using this pixels value
here again which we've used a couple of
times already actually and if you're a
little bit confused as to what a pixel
is you can think of it as the smallest
unit of space that our screens can
render so a pixel is just a tiny square
so tiny that we actually need 400 of
them stacked up besides each other in
order to get a width
of this size
so with that i want you to fix the width
of the google logo
select the image tag and set the width
of the logo to 300 pixels
go ahead and do that right now and then
i will show you how to do it as well
when you return back to this scrim
okay let's do this i'm going to break
this down into a few lines so i get some
space above the input field and then
target the img element the image element
open up the curly brackets and do with
300 pixels like that
we're not quite yet at the finish design
but the ratio between the logo and the
input field is now a lot better great
job let's move on
okay i've discovered a problem with our
google site which is that if we make the
browser really wide you can see that
suddenly the items stack up besides each
other on the same line and that's
obviously not the kind of behavior we
want we want them to always be stacked
on top of each other and in order to fix
this you have to learn about inline
elements versus block elements and
that's best understood through the lens
of an example so let's say that you for
example have a collection of things you
want to showcase you could be like
george franson for example and collect
dinosaur poo he actually has the world's
largest collection of fossilized feces
and naturally he wants to exhibit them
in a posium and if he were to use
display inline on his images they would
stack up besides each other like this so
kind of like in a line horizontally
however had he used display block on his
images then they would stack up on top
of each other so rule of thumb is
display block stacks on top another way
to look at this is that the block level
element blocks out the rest of the
available horizontal space so that
nothing else can be placed there and
that is regardless of how wide this
image is the content itself this play
block requires control over all the
horizontal space in its given container
so when this block image is placed here
and you add a new image it would have to
be placed underneath the previous one
and if it does display block as well
it'll block out the rest of the
available horizontal space and the next
image have to be placed below that one
again and so on
so the solution is obviously to turn
these elements into blocks and i'm just
going to give you the syntax here this
is how you write it display colon block
go ahead and do that for both of these
and observe what happens to the example
when you make the browser wide good luck
okay let's do this
so i'll do display
block up here and the same
here if we look at the browser seemingly
nothing has happened
however if we now make it wide you can
see yes no matter how wide the browser
is these will always stack up on top of
each other
so great job let's move on
the next thing we need to fix is the
lack of white space above our google
logo because if we take a look at the
design here we want quite a lot of space
in between the top of the browser and
the logo and i'm not going to tell you
how to add that but if you can think
back to the very first scrim in this
section we added some space above the
text in our cookie widget
and that specific space is called margin
or margin top to be specific so your job
is to add some margin on top of our
image
right here you can start on line seven
so there are example here get some
breathing room some white space above
the logo and the input field go ahead
and give this one a shot and then i will
of course show you the solution when you
return back to me
okay hopefully that went well if not no
worries i really pushed you out on thin
ice here so it's completely okay if you
didn't remember that the
property is called margin top and what
you add there is a pixel value so for
example 100 px and there we go we've now
added a margin on the top of our image
and while we're still quite far off from
our provided design here we are getting
closer great job let's move on
now while it totally works to add the
margin top directly on the image here
you'd most likely not see professional
developers do this
because what they do instead is wrap
these two elements in some kind of
container and then control the
positioning of these elements indirectly
via that container and in order to do
this you have to learn about the div i'm
going to create an opening div and then
indent these two and then a closing div
below here
now if we run this code seemingly
nothing has happened because the div
actually does very little in itself
though it is indispensable for web
developers just to show you how
important it is let's take a look at
facebook and my timeline here i've
opened up devtools and inspected one of
the timeline items and you can see it is
actually a div inside of a div inside of
another div inside of yet another inside
of the inside of a div
divs really do rule the world so it's
important that you learn about them and
the way we'll use this div now is by
removing the margin top styling from the
image and then add it to the div itself
and the reason this is important is
let's say that for example google
decides to create a video here instead
or a interactive doodle or some kind of
game they often play around with the
google logo well if so it's a really bad
idea that it is the image itself that
controls the margin from the top of the
browser and down to the content
because that image might be removed so
it is a solution that will get you into
trouble in the future so what we'll do
here is we'll simply instead target the
div
and then remove the margin top from the
image and boom it has popped up now we
lost all of our white space but if we
add it back to our div we are back at
the design we started out with seemingly
nothing has changed but as you know
we have a better html structure so we
have definitely made good progress here
so with that let's move on to the next
scrim
the reason you need to learn about
classes now is because our current setup
where we simply have the elements like
this and then selecting the element
using the element selector in css will
give us bugs down the line because when
we add the two buttons beneath the input
field
we'll actually wrap these two in a div
as well and let's see what happens at
this point
what i'll do now is simply add the html
for these buttons down here beneath the
input field
so it is a div with two buttons inside
of it
and then you can see we are closing that
div
the inner div
and then we are closing the outer div
let's run this code and oh wow
what you can see is that the spacing
between the input field and the buttons
is totally off and that is because our
css element selector here selects any
div it can find in the html document and
applies the margin top to it
so it doesn't just select the first one
but it can select thousands of divs so
this is a very generic solution and
likely not something we want to use as
we want to have multiple divs with
different types of styling in our html
element
so let's now instead fix this by doing
the following i'll write class
equals
then for example main
this here is an attribute called class
so it's built into html and this here is
the name i'm giving my class i want to
call this div my main element
and now the way i select that in the css
is by instead of just writing the
element name simply doing dot
main like that
now if i rerun this code you can see now
the margin top is only applied to the
outer div our main class and not to the
div which wraps the two buttons
so that is exactly what we needed
now i'm going to remove these two
buttons here because we don't want to
deal with them just yet and then i'm
going to give you a challenge
first you're going to add a class to
each of these two elements that is the
image and the input you have to decide
what you will call the two classes but
make sure to give them different names
and then you're going to in the css
replace the element selectors with class
selectors so that is the img selector
here and the input selector here and
obviously
the css class selectors you're going to
replace them with is the ones you have
added to the elements right here so go
ahead and do this right now
okay hopefully that went well let's now
do it together
so for the image tag i'm simply going to
do class equals then i'll call this
logo dash
img
so here i'm using a convention where i'm
first giving my class a descriptive name
and then using a dash and then
specifying the element as well this is
an img element but it could have been
for example an svg or something else
now i don't expect you to have followed
the same convention there are plenty of
css conventions and it doesn't matter at
all what you used in your example you
can call your classes whatever you want
okay for the input we'll do class equals
search dash
input like that okay let's move through
the css then i'll replace this with bot
now you can see it broke the layout
because this styling now is not applied
to any element
so we need to do logo dash img
like that and here do dot search
dash
input
and there we have the exact same example
didn't change at all but we now have a
more flexible solution that scales
better so great job solving this
challenge let's move on
now it's time to take a closer look at
margins and you've already dipped your
toes into this as you have used margin
top so you might have some intuition
about what margins do however now you're
going to learn it properly through
creating flags with css because flags
are just awesome i mean take a look at
this flag here for example from the
republic of venice estate which existed
for over a thousand years in europe and
it contains of course a flying lion
holding a book i mean what's more
natural than that
or this one right here for the isle of
man i mean have you ever seen a more
creepy creature than this three-legged
thing right here imagine having that
thing running after you
that would not be fun and this flag
would be really hard to create in css
actually so we're not going to create
this one we're going to start off at a
much easier level with just some very
simple shapes so let's have a look at
those actually
here is what we're going to work with as
you can see there's simply three divs
inside of the body tag and each div has
a class red blue or green if we check
out the styles.css you can see that
these three classes apply a background
color to each of the elements and sets
the height to 100 pixels and here we
have the result three rectangular boxes
that are stacked on top of each other
and that tells us that these are display
block because display block stacks on
top there's one thing that bothers me
here and that is that we have a little
bit of white space around the three
items why is that well actually it's
because our browser is trying to help us
here it's assuming that we want a little
bit of space around the body tag
so that these three don't touch the
edges of the browser so what's actually
going on here in code is that the
browser
targets the body and sets a margin of
eight pixels if you notice when i added
this nothing changed so if i remove this
it's still the same meaning that this
style here is applied automatically so
that means that margin is actually the
space around an element because now if
we change this to zero boom there you
can see suddenly our divs touch the
edges of the browser
now here at the bottom they stop after
300 pixels since we've told them to so
this margin zero here seemingly didn't
change anything at the bottom because
the bottom contains white space anyway
if we make our browser tall enough but
anyway that's a digression let's get it
back so that the browser is completely
filled up with these three items and now
let's play a little bit around with
margins so what do you think will happen
if i add a margin top of 10 pixels on
the red here
take a guess
okay
margin top
10 pixels boom it added 10 pixels on the
top what do you think will happen if i
add margin left 10 pixels as well
let's try
it
okay so it added
10 pixels on the left hand side
it's only on the red rectangle not the
blue or green rectangle likewise if i do
margin
8
and pixels it adds 10 pixels to the
right hand side as well
if i do a 100 it eats up almost a third
of our red rectangle okay so now it's
your turn
i want you to add 100 pixels of margin
on the bottom of the red box so go ahead
and give that a shot right now
okay
if you did margin
bottom
100px like that
i want to congratulate you because you
just created the flag of monaco really
good job creating your first css flag
now let's do that yet again
here is your challenge you are going to
create the flag of the gambia and here
we have that flag however there's a
catch you can only do this by applying
styles to the blue box so by adding
margin to this css rule right here so go
ahead and give that a shot right now
okay hopefully that went well the way to
do it is by doing margin top let's try
10 pixels and see
actually i think we want our white space
to be a little bit more than 10 pixels
so let's do 20 like that then
margin
bottom as well
20 pixels and
there i think we have a pretty good flag
for the gambia
now before we move on to our google
project there's one little weird thing i
want to tell you about margin top and
bottom
because what do you think happens if i
add for example margin bottom of 15 to
this red element here well according to
my logic the margin right here would be
35 pixels because we added 20 pixels on
top of the blue and if we add 15 at the
bottom of the red one
that should be
total
however
now that i added this nothing happened
and that is because margin top and
margin bottom will in many situations
collapse into each other so that as long
as this margin is smaller than this this
will take precedence and it's only when
this one becomes larger for example 25
that it will kick in so let's take it
back to 15 and to make things even worse
there's actually scenarios where this
doesn't happen however digging into that
is outside of the scope of this lecture
i just want you to be aware of it
because if you're suddenly in a
situation where your margins don't seem
to add up it's probably because of
so-called collapsing margins okay with
that let's move on
okay we're back at our google project i
want to give you a quick challenge i
want you to add some space between the
logo and the search field because as you
can see here there's some spacing in
between the elements in our design
however in our project now they are
crammed together
there are two ways you can do this using
margins and i want you to think about
which two ways that is and choose one of
them go ahead and do this right now
okay hopefully that went well let's do
it
so you can either add a margin bottom to
the logo or you can add a margin top to
the search field i'm going to go with
adding margin bottom to the logo as i
think either way is as good as the other
at this stage margin bottom and how much
do we want to add well let's try 20px
and yeah as you can see we've got some
spacing the bottom of the g is not
touching the top of the input field and
if we compare that to the example i
think it looks more or less the same
so great job let's move
on okay now you are going to learn about
centering elements in css and that is a
scary topic for a lot of developers so
scary that this stack overflow question
about how to horizontally center an
element has been viewed 4.5 million
times
so if you think this is a little bit
confusing you are in very good company
so don't worry about it
so with that in mind let's move over to
our example
you are going to center this dinosaur
poo
as you can see in the css it has just
one property set at this point which is
a width of 200 pixels that is because
the image is so wide originally that if
i don't set that width it'll just take
up more space than we have available
and setting the width of it is actually
an important thing in order to center it
because there are three things that need
to be in place when we are to center
elements with the technique you are
about to learn aka centering with
margins and these three components are
first the element needs to be display
blocked because how is an element
supposed to center itself if it doesn't
command full control over all the
horizontal space
if it's display inline and allows other
elements to stack themselves besides the
element well then it won't be able to
center itself because that space now is
busy with other things
so in order to center this poo it needs
to control
all the horizontal space
so it needs this
block like that now that didn't change
anything but under the hood the poo now
controls the full horizontal space
okay the second part is that it must
have a width
and that is what we've done here already
because how is this item supposed to be
centered inside the browser if it is
wider than the browser itself that's
often what happens with either large
elements or with some html elements who
just naturally actually expand to take
up all the available space in the block
so we have to make sure that our element
has a width
and finally we set the margin on the
left hand side and the right hand side
to the value auto
let's just do that
margin
left
auto oh wow
now it pushed the poo all the way to the
right hand side
because auto here means take up all the
available space and since this is a
block element the available space is all
the space that's left after the poo has
taken up its 200 pixels
so it just ate up all of this space and
turned it into margin
however at this point margin right
enters the party
margin right
and says i want the available space as
well and at that point the margin left
and margin right goes into discussion
and decides well actually since there
are two of us here pushing on each of
the side of the element trying to get
all of the available white space let's
just divide it evenly amongst both of us
and the result well it is that the item
is centered
so that was a long explanation of
centering with margins if you feel
confused don't worry about it right now
all you need to do is remember these
three conditions and just be aware of
the 4.5 million other developers who are
in or have been in the same boat as you
let's move on to the next scrim
okay we are back at our google project
now your challenge is to center the logo
and the search field using the technique
you just learned
so go ahead and give that a shot right
now and then i will of course show you
the solution afterwards as well
okay as you hopefully remembered the way
to center an element which is display
block and has a width is by adding
margin left auto and margin right auto
so let's do that margin
left
auto and as you can see that pushes the
logo all the way to the right hand side
because the margin left is set to auto
and it takes up as much space as it can
we'll do the same thing with the right
hand side margin right auto
then the right hand side starts pushing
back again and when they're both taking
up equally as much space the margin left
and margin right kind of decides yeah
let's not argue anymore now we have a
nice balance and whoa lo and behold our
element is centered
so
now what we can do is be super lazy and
copy that code and paste it in down here
and boom
our input field is centered as well and
our project is starting to look a little
bit like our finished design so this is
super cool let's just keep up the pace
and move on
we need to take a little step back and
learn a new css concept
which is the close relative of margins
called padding
and we're of course going to learn that
through the lens of an example
so here i have just a simple div
which contains a little bit of text or
specifically the two first sentences in
the white paper behind bitcoin and let's
say we want to turn this into a nice
looking card that people can read if so
we'd probably create a class can call it
card then of course in the style.css
we'd select that card and apply the
styling as for now it just has one
property set which is the color that
we've set to a shade of black that isn't
pure black but a little bit softer so to
speak that is because by default the
browser uses pure black as the text
color and pure white as the background
color and as a rule of thumb you never
want to have pure black on pure white
that's not a pleasant experience for the
eyes so instead we went for this but
that was the digression let's move on
with turning this into a nice looking
card
so a card needs a background color so
let's just
do background
light
gray for example like that and we also
don't want our card to be full width
because as you remember divs are block
by default and take up the full width if
you don't specify any width on it so
we're going to do with for example 300
pixels like that and then we also want
some space above the card that is of
course margin top
let's push it 50 pixels down from the
top and finally it should be centered so
let's do margin
left
auto and margin
right
like that okay so now we have something
that looks at least a little bit like a
card but there's one problem here
you can see the text is crammed all the
way into the edges of the which doesn't
look particularly good and that is where
padding comes into play
so now i'm just going to apply the
padding
by doing padding and for example 20
pixels like that as you can see
that created a little bit of space
basically some breathing room in between
the text and the edge of our div
container here and if i do 50 you can
see it's even more breathing room so
where's margin adds space
on the outside of our div the card which
we've selected here
padding will add space on the inside in
between the content and the edges of the
container or the div
so margin kind of lives
up here
and down here if we are to visualize
this in our html where's padding lives
on the inside of our element that is
here and here
and now you might wonder well why did i
just write padding whereas for martin
we're specifying each of the sides
and well you can do exactly that on
padding as well
this padding 20 pixels right here is the
exact same thing as writing the
following
padding top 20 bottom 20 left 20 and
right 20. so with these four lines we
can actually delete this one up here and
then we have the same convention as
we're using with margins
it's just that you can use
padding 20 pixels like that if all of
the values are the same it's basically a
shorthand
and now that we have all of them written
out we can play around a little bit with
it perhaps add a 100 pixels on the left
hand side looks really weird and 100
pixels on the top as well and suddenly
our card does not look very good but
let's get it back and now i want to give
you a challenge
i want you to add padding to make our
card look like the provided design and
the provided design is right here you
can see it's a completely broken card as
we've been ruthless about our padding
and i've actually removed all of the
padding rules from the css as i want you
to build some muscle memory writing
padding so go ahead and make this card
look like it does in the slide and then
return back to me once you've done it
okay hopefully that went well
if not no worries let's do it together
as you can see here it's completely
crammed into the bottom left corner
which means that it doesn't have any
padding on the left hand side or any
padding on the bottom but a ton of
padding on the top and a ton of padding
on the right
so i'm just gonna do padding
top
100 pixels something like that
yeah seems
pretty much what we have in the design
as well
and then do the same padding
right
100 pixels like that and to me that
looks actually pretty much like our
design
i don't need to write padding bottom or
padding left now so i could do it i
could do padding bottom
zero pixels or just zero
and padding
left
zero as well
though
that didn't change anything
so it's actually not needed because by
default the padding of a div is zero
so however you solve this great job
let's move on
so now you've learned about controlling
the space on the outside of the element
with the margin and on the inside of the
element with the padding but wouldn't it
be nice if we could also control the
border in between the margin and the
padding
and it turns out we can through you
guessed it the border property because
if i write border here and then specify
for example
two pixels thickness solid in shape and
then color red
you can see then we get a border which
is on the outside of the padding but on
the inside of the margin
and if we change any of these three
values here it'll update accordingly so
let's try eight pixels with instead you
can see it's much thicker now instead of
solid we can do
odded like that pretty weird
and instead of red we can do for example
fff
white in hexadecimal or just right white
like that
or just blue so it's a little bit
clearer
now there are many types of borders but
in 99.9
of the cases you want to use solid like
that
and also very often you'd want to soften
up these corners
and you can do that with the border
radius property and there you specify a
pixel value for example 30 pixels and
boom there you can see
we have this much softer corners
if we crank this up to 100 or a thousand
it stops at some point because then the
edges have simply turned into half
circles so at some point there's no use
going any higher
now this looks pretty bad so what i want
you to do now is fix it up so that it
looks like this
and i'm not going to give you any of the
values i've used here just a little hint
i took an already existing color in our
box and used it for the border so that's
a common web design trick to reuse
colors and not have too many different
colors so if you think this is pure
black
you are wrong
so go ahead and change the values of the
border and border radius so that our
example here matches the design i've
provided in the slide good luck
okay hopefully that went well so let's
start with the border 8 pixels here
looks a bit too thick for me so let's
try four instead
like that
i think that matches better yes
and the color
i gave you a hint was just the blackish
color we have for our text like that
and the border radius is much smaller
let's try 10.
it's this still looks a little bit
rounder
so
let's try 20 yes there i think we got it
great job
now a cool thing to do in order to
inspect the margin border padding and
size of the element in general
is to open up the dev tools which can be
done by right clicking on the nav bar
here and then clicking in spec and then
this dev tools panel will open
here clicking on the select icon on the
left hand side
and then hovering over the element
finally clicking at it
there you will see that we have selected
the element in the elements tab and
under the styles tab you can see the
styling we have applied using css so
here you can actually modify them if you
want but we're not going to do that
right now we're going to scroll down and
verify that our margin border and
padding are correct so if i hover over
the margin here you can see up here in
the mini browser it is marked in orange
and the values are provided down in the
box here if i move over to the border
you can see that border is now selected
in the browser and is indeed four pixels
as we code it up a minute ago if i move
over to the padding you can see that is
also indeed 20 on each side just as we
want it to be and finally if i hover
over the center here the content is
highlighted and the content of this div
is just the text and as you can see it
is 300 pixels wide just as we said it
has so it's working as expected and the
height is dictated by how many lines of
text are two sentences required
so using this technique of inspecting an
element and its sizing properties like
this is a really good way of debugging
if something for example looks wrong
because it gives you an ability to
verify if the numbers here match up with
what you've tried to write in your css
so now that you've learned all of that i
want to tell you the name of this and
it's actually called the box model and
to be honest i've never really liked
this word it sounds more complex than it
is in my opinion it's just spacing
around the element a border spacing on
the inside of an element and the content
itself but in web development we call
this the box model so you'll probably
hear this name come up from time to time
but you shouldn't fare it you know
exactly what it is and you've used all
of the properties in the box model so
don't worry about it actually let's give
you a new box model practice in the next
scrim
i'll see you there
okay now you are going to create a
really neat looking button namely the
following button on twitter let's zoom
in a little bit and here you can see it
this is the button you see if you
already are following someone and we
zoom out again this is the scrimba
twitter profile you should definitely
just click this image and follow us
because we share a ton of useful tips
and tricks and career advice for
aspiring coders here so it's definitely
worthwhile anyway now you are going to
use the things you've learned about
padding border border radius and so
forth in order to make this button right
here with the ugly default styling
look exactly like this
or not exactly as we're not going to
worry about the font it is a little bit
different but other than that you should
try to make it look identical
i've given you some hints here for
example the border color is this hex
color right here and the text color is
this one right here and also you need to
remember to adjust the font weight and i
don't think you've done that ever since
the very first scrim where you wrote
your first lines of css so you might
have to look back so that you figure out
how to adjust the font weight or you can
google it up to you anyway just go ahead
and give this your best shot and if you
at some point get stuck or don't know
how to do it no worries we are going to
do it together afterwards as well
good luck
okay hopefully that went well let's do
it together
i'm going to target the button just
using an element selector like this and
now let's pick the low hanging fruit
namely the ones we've gotten here
already for example by doing color
and then copying this
color right here okay that didn't change
much
at least not visibly then let's do
border
and i'm going to start with one pixel
solid
and then the border color right here
like that okay so it looks a little bit
different now but not quite
this
one thing we can clearly see is that
this image has a white background
whereas ours is still a little bit gray
so let's do that as well background
white okay yes
but our button is much more crammed
there's too little padding
whereas here you can see we have a
little bit of padding on the top and the
bottom and actually quite a lot of
padding on the left and right hand side
and that's actually a little design tip
right there what you'll often see is
that buttons have more padding on the
left hand side and the right hand side
and they have above and below
so let's try
padding top 5 pixels for example padding
bottom 5 pixels
and then we'll try
left
10 pixels and
write 10 pixels as well
how does that look not too bad but
actually it looks like this button has
even more so we've added half as much on
the top and bottom as we have on the
sides so let's crank up both of these a
little bit
i'm going to select both of these and do
eight top and below and select both of
these and do 16 left and right yeah i
think that's more like it
now one thing that definitely is
remaining is the rounded edges here
so that is the border radius added up
here with the border let's try 10 pixels
it's a little bit round now but not as
round as the twitter button
so let's do 16. yeah more like it
can we go higher yeah i think we can go
to 18
that looks quite good to me if we
compare to this one
and then finally we needed to remember
the font weight which i can do font
weight
bold like that
that looks a lot better
i think the final adjustment i want to
make is adding even a little bit more
padding around it because now that i
look at it it feels like this is a bit
more spacious so here we are really in
the nit picking area
but let's try 10 on both of the top and
bottom and let's try 20 on the left and
right and what's interesting now is that
since the box now has grown in size
because it's affected by the padding the
border radius can also be cranked up a
little bit i think actually we can do 20
now
yes because the bigger a box is
more pixels you need to add in order to
get this fully soft looking button which
essentially has two half circles on each
of its sides so
looking at the example and comparing it
with ours i think we have reached our
goal
and if your values are different than
mine that does not matter at all you're
actually creating the button of a huge
public company here you are just
learning basic css so it's totally not
expected that you create buttons as
neatly as twitter does as they probably
have a team of developers and designers
working just on this profile page so
however it went be proud of yourself and
get ready to move on with our google
project i'll see you in the next scrim
okay we are back at our google project
and now you are going to fix the design
of our search field and you're actually
going to get a design spec the proper
walkthrough of how i want it to look
so here i've opened up the dev tools
actually on the right hand side as i
want to inspect the box model of this
element with you and if you wonder how i
managed to stick the devtools to the
right hand side here just click these
three icons if you're in chrome then you
can choose the dock side so let's move
on down here to the box model of the
input field and if i hover over the
content in the box model here you can
see that it says 400 pixels times 24
pixels and you can see the content is
marked in blue in the mini browser here
so that means that our width is 400
pixels we know that because we set it
ourselves here and the height of the
content should be 24 pixels okay let's
move on to the padding if i hover over
that you can see it's green and it's
highlighted in green in the mini browser
the padding at the top and the bottom
are 10 pixels as you can see down here
and the left hand side and right hand
side have 30 pixels each and then if we
move over to the border you can see that
it's simply one pixel all around so
here is your design spec given to you by
your hipster designer down in the bottom
right corner here
height of content 24 pixels but do
remember that that is actually the
height of the inner box here not the
height of the total input field as that
also contains the padding and the border
but the height property should be 24
pixels the padding above and beyond as
said 10 pixels right and left hand side
30 pixels thickness of border 1 pixel
the color of border is this and then
finally also the border radius is also a
value that our designer has been kind
enough to give to you so
take this design spec and implement it
using css
okay hopefully that went well if not no
worries we'll do this together right now
so starting with the height of 24. there
i'm going to just write
8 24 pixels like that okay so it became
a little bit taller now
next step is the padding top and bottom
was 10 pixels so
padding top 10 px
bottom was also
mpx like that
okay the padding left and right hand
side were 30 pixels according to the
spec so let's implement that
like that and then we'll move on to the
border one pixel and this hex code right
here
so i'll do border and here we have to
provide it with three values so one
pixel
it is going to be solid and the color is
dfe1e5 like that looking pretty good
the final thing then is the border
radius and that should be 24 pixels
according to the design and look at this
it is starting to look really
professional so really good job if you
did this challenge if you did a couple
of mistakes no worries at all actually i
also did a little mistake here according
to best practices when setting heights
for input fields because actually i want
to show you that this height of 24
pixels here is actually not the way we
want to do it because if i google
set height of input field css and then
click the first link that is a stack
overflow question and here you can see
someone who's been having problems with
this so they've asked a question about
it if we scroll a little bit down you
can see that people are saying try with
padding and line height
line height that's not something we've
used if we scroll a little bit down you
can see that some browsers will honor a
css height rule some not so it seems to
be a little bit difficult to use height
for the input field
and this person's wall suggests line
height and likewise with this third
person here so i'm going to trust the
wisdom of the crowds here and use line
height instead
like that
didn't change anything but we are using
a property that more browsers apparently
will honor
and line height is actually just the
height of one line of text and since
that is everything we have inside of an
input field it's just one line of text
that'll be the exact same thing as
setting the height of the inner content
of the input field so if that was a
little bit confusing and you prefer to
just use height that's totally fine as
well it's more important that you are
using what you are comfortable with than
that you are doing it the 100 correct
way according to conventions so just use
whatever you want i just wanted you to
be aware of the fact that this is the
recommended way according to stack
overflow with that let's move on
okay now we're gonna add the first
button to our google project
so i'm gonna head over to the html and
here beneath the input field i'm just
gonna type
button
like that
and this will be the google search
button so there we have it it doesn't
exactly look good but don't worry about
that
now i want to give this a class as well
and a class name you'll often see used
for buttons is simply btn like that
okay
now that we have that i want you to
center the button and add some space
above it so go ahead and use the class
selector to select this button and solve
this challenge good luck
okay so what i'll do is do dot vtn to
select the button
here you might have been tempted to
simply do margin left auto and then
margin right
auto however that doesn't seem to do
anything
why is that well if you remember the
criteria you needed in order to use this
technique to center elements one of them
was that you need your element to be
display block whereas buttons are
actually display inline by default
so if we do display
block
boom there we go the button is centered
and now you might ask well what about
the width we also set the width on the
input field and the logo
well we could do that as well with this
one let's do with
200 pixels for example
however it's not needed because if we
remove the width you can see that it
still has a width which is certainly not
full width across the entire page so it
kind of has an implicit width without us
setting the width so even though it is a
criteria that your element needs with in
order to use this technique here in
order to center it you don't necessarily
have to set the width yourself if the
element already has some kind of width
so it works perfectly fine just doing
display block and margin left right auto
in this example
finally we are going to add some space
above it so let's do that i'll do margin
top and do for example 30 pixels yeah
looking pretty good great job solving
this challenge let's move on
now we are going to style the button in
our google project
because as you can see this is how our
button currently looks but
this is how we want it to look so we got
to do a bunch of changes however there's
one thing i want to change actually on
this google.com homepage because notice
how low the contrast is between the
background color of the button and the
background color of the entire website
it's hardly possible to see that there's
any difference and that's not good
because it reduces the accessibility of
the site and makes it hard for people
who are visually impaired to use it
actually to prove this let's take these
two colors the light gray here and the
white and put them into a contrast
checker online for example this one
right here on userray.org
they have this nice little contrast
checker where you can paste in the
foreground color and the background
color and then get a contrast ratio and
this
f8f9fa hex color is the one that google
is using
and if we scroll a bit down you'll see
that google indeed fails miserably on
this test complete failure
the ratio is 1.05 though it should have
been 4.5 or more so not good google
so what we will do instead is change the
background from this
to something like this here you can see
it's much easier to see that it is
indeed a button
so even though the real background color
is this one right here we are going to
use this one right here
so with that in mind i want you to style
the button according to the provided
design you now have
and the only hint i'll give you is that
these are the properties you are going
to use however i'm not giving you the
values of any of them because i want you
to practice looking at an example and
making your best guess as to what the
values for the css properties should be
as that's how you'll work out in the
real world when a designer for example
gives you a design file so go ahead and
do this right now and then i will show
you the solution afterwards as well
okay let's do this i'm going to bring up
the example here have it on the side so
that we can
see how it develops
and then start with the background color
as we have the value for that one
down here
round
like that okay next i would try to see
what is the most apparent difference
between this button
and this one right here well the border
is certainly different this button does
not have a border at all
whereas this one has got has a border so
let's just remove it
border
none like that okay good
now we can see that the text is much
more crammed into this box than there is
this one right here so that is the
padding and also you can notice that
there's more padding on the left and
right hand side than on the top and
bottom so i'm going to try to add for
example padding
top 5 pixels
ah that actually looks like this one
here has more than 5 pixels because this
space is still pretty crammed so i'm
gonna do for example eight
yeah i think that is more like it i'm
gonna give that on the bottom as well
like that
on the sides i'm just going to try the
double
padding left 16 pixels padding right 16
pixels and you know what i think that
button and our button looks pretty
similar in size
so next up is the border radius because
you can see this one is totally
rectangular
whereas this one has softer corners
so i'm going to do border
radius
something like 4 pixels so that is
pretty good
the final minor adjustments i'm going to
make is reduce the font size ever so
little from what it is here down to what
it is here i mean it's almost identical
but i happen to know that this one is
indeed 14 pixels
so i'm going to do font size
14 pixels like that and there we
actually have the buttons this one and
this one
identical
now if you chose any other values than
the ones i've chosen don't worry about
it at all the point was not for you to
reach the exact same values as me but
just in the same range basically so
regardless of how your example ended up
good job reaching this far let's just
keep up the pace and move on
now we are going to add the second
button to our google project this i'm
feeling lucky button right here
and i want you to do that on your own
first so that's your challenge add the
next button and do remember to give that
button a btn class so that it's styled
as our search button and once you've
done that and executed the code i want
you to take a look in the mini browser
and ask yourself
why aren't our buttons behaving as we
want them to because as you'll see
there's something wrong with the layout
at least when comparing it to this
layout right here we'll go ahead and do
that right now and try to think of why
our layout is wrong and then i will do
it as well when you return back to me
and explain what's going on
okay let's do this
so i'm lazy so i'm just going to copy
this one like that and write
um
feeling
lucky
run the code and as you can see
the buttons are now stacked on top of
each other
what we can do in order to figure out
what's going on here is actually use the
built-in dev tools in the browser which
you've seen a few times now so let me
show you this debug session using slides
i'm going to right click in the nav bar
and then choose inspect
open up the elements tab and then click
on the selector icon here so that i can
select this button by hovering over it
and then down in the styles tab i can
scroll down until i see the box model
for our button and what you'll notice is
that our button is taking up all the
available space on the left hand side
and the right hand side
and if we move down to the second button
you can see that that button is also
doing that that is because they are
display block
exactly this line right here if you
remember from previous lectures display
block kind of takes up all of the
available space on the horizontal axis
so as we said earlier display block
stacks on top we aren't able to get the
layout we want if our buttons are
display block and then you might be
tempted to do well let's just remove the
display block
however
if we do they will be on the same line
yes they are now inline elements but
they will just be crammed all the way to
the left hand side because
margin left right auto doesn't work if
you remember from the lecture about
centering you learned that display block
and margin left right auto works
together in order to center something
you can't have just one of them
which means that in order to go from
this layout to this layout we have to
use a different technique for centering
the elements and there's actually two
ways we could do this there's the simple
and inflexible way using text align and
then there's the slightly harder but
super flexible way using flexbox and
since you're going to use flexbox
several times throughout this course i
want you to get familiar with it right
away so in the next scrim we're going to
talk about flexbox but before we do that
i just want to show you the simple way
as well so that you've seen it because
as you might remember from one of the
very first scrims in this section we
used something called text align in
order to align our text either to the
left right or center now the text align
property actually works on all inline
elements not just on text so what we can
do is remove the display block from our
buttons
as you know that turns them into inline
elements and they are crammed to the
left
and as inline elements only take up the
available space they need according to
their content there is no available
margin to use so auto here which
basically means take up whatever
available margin there is serves no
purpose so we can remove both of these
two as well as you can see it made no
difference and then we can move up to
the main the parent will do text align
center like that and boom both buttons
are now centered so here we have told
the container the main element all
inline elements inside of it should
align to the center
so that was the easy but inflexible way
of doing this let's instead of using
this technique move on to do it how the
pros do it using flexbox
flexbox is everywhere let's just have a
look at twitter for example here the
menu on the left hand side is created
with flexbox as with the tweet options
menu and the timeline itself and guess
what the trends for you and who to
follow it's created with you guessed it
flexbox so this is something you need to
learn
let's imagine then that you have a
e-commerce website which you can see
here that sells shoes hoodies and
t-shirts well then you probably have a
navigation menu like this one where
users can click and then probably open
up a sub menu or something like that
as you can see the items stack on top of
each other that is to be expected as
these are divs and divs are display
block they want to take up all the
available space in the width and if
you're wondering how i styled these we
can head over to the styles.css and just
have a quick look at that you can see
i've aligned the text to the center
inside of all the items hadn't i done
that it would have been aligned to the
left
also there's a border as you can see
there's some padding on the inside and
there's some margin in between the
elements
now the question is what if i instead of
this vertical layout wanted a horizontal
layout which is more common for
so-called navigation bars
so something that looks like this well
this is where flexbox comes to the
rescue and in order to turn this into a
flexbox layout i would first have to
wrap these three items in a container
because a flexbox layout always consists
of a container and its direct children
so
let's wrap it in a div
and give this a class of
for example nav dash wrapper like that
if i run this now nothing happens
because divs as you know are invisible
unless you give them any styling or
content
so let's head over to the styles.css and
now target the nav wrapper like that in
order to turn this into a flexbox
container all i have to do is write
display
flex and boom suddenly we have forced
our three divs into one row now this
layout flows from left to right along
the horizontal axis and that is pretty
significant given that these items were
display block by default but flexbox as
powerful as it is overrides that and
forces them on to one line
however we haven't got quite the layout
we want yet as you can see it's centered
and there's also some space in between
the items
now let's start with the centering
because flexbox now has control over
these items and can decide where along
the main axis they should be positioned
so we can do justify content that is a
little bit of a weird name for a
property but that's just how it is and
then set that to center like that
now all of the items are centered and
the final step is just to get some
spacing in between these items and that
is done with our good old friend margin
so we'll do margin left let's do 10
pixels and let's add the same thing on
the margin
right
like that
and there we have the layout we wanted
now a final cool thing i want to show
you is that we can do for example end
here as well that'll push it all the way
to the right hand side or start
at the beginning or alternatively you
space that around that's pretty cool
now we've distributed all the white
space around each of the items and
another one is space between now all of
the available space is between the items
so they're spread out like this
now we are getting ahead of ourselves
here i just wanted to demonstrate this
to show how powerful flexbox is what you
are going to work with is the center
here so with that let's return back to
our google clone
okay we are back at our google project
and now your job is to center these two
buttons besides each other meaning
getting to this layout right here
and the way to do that is of course
using flexbox so you'll wrap the two
buttons in a flexbox div and then center
them
and then also
i want you to give the div a class of
btn-wrapper so you'll need to modify
both the html and the css here
now before you start i'm going to remove
these three lines here because they are
solely there in order to center our
buttons
using this display block and margin left
right auto technique however now we're
going to use the flexbox technique and
we don't want to use both techniques at
the same time because that'll just be
confusing as they will affect each other
so i will remove these lines
and now you're left with this left
aligned layout here
so please take over here do this
challenge and then return back to me
when you've done it or when you feel you
need some guidance good luck
okay hopefully that went well if not no
worries we'll do it now together
so i'm going to start with this flexbox
div that we want in our html
it should wrap our buttons and only our
buttons so we want to start it up here
if class of btn dash wrapper
at i'm going to indent my buttons
and then end the div down here so now it
is simply wrapping our two buttons
if i run this code seemingly nothing has
happened
but under the hood we have the button
wrapper which we can target using
btn.wrapper
like that and then we can do display
flex that's turned our div into a
flexbox and now we can use the
justify content and do
center like that
there you can see both our buttons are
centered however they are totally
crammed into each other now there's no
margin in between them
so in order to fix that we want to add a
little bit of margin left and right to
these buttons so i'm going to do margin
left
perhaps 4 pixels and margin
right
or pixels as well
like that
that's looking pretty good to me so if
you didn't do this no worries at all and
also if you are a little bit confused
about flexbox that is totally okay as
well we're going to work with that
several times throughout this course
you'll get more opportunities to
practice this just feel proud that
you've at least dipped your toes into
flexbox as that is a super important
tool for any front-end developer so
great job let's move on
now there's one final thing i want you
to know and that is that you are amazing
because you have taken your very first
step into the world of css and that is
more than most people ever do so take
this moment to feel great about yourself
and also let's take this moment to recap
what you've learned starting out you
learned about the css syntax that is how
you select elements and also use
properties and values and then you learn
the key concept about inline elements
versus block elements so block elements
stacking on top of each other like these
two and inline elements standing kind of
in a horizontal line like the buttons
here moving on you learned about margins
which is how you create white space
outside of elements for example above
the google logo here and you learned
about its close cousin the padding which
is how you create space on the inside of
elements for example in between the text
and the edges of these buttons also
borders is what is between padding and
margin and we use that on the input
field here we decided its thickness its
type and color and also the radius of
the corners so we didn't want the sharp
edges but rather soft circular edges
which we achieved with this border
radius property what we also did was
take a closer look at the div tag which
you saw briefly in the html section this
time around though you actually created
two divs one to wrap the entire project
and another to wrap the buttons and we
had to separate those from each other so
you had to learn about classes that is
the attribute you set like this and you
select by using the dot notation in the
css
also a big thing is centering in css you
learned three different ways of doing
this and the final way you centered
elements was through the use of flexbox
a super powerful tool that all frontend
developers need to be comfortable with
so you have learned a lot
now i think you should take a little
break you have to digest these things
recharge and then i will see you back
here when you are ready in the next
section
welcome to the second css section of
this course where you are going to build
a business card for yourself and it's
going to look more or less like this
though you're going to personalize it
make it your own not only with your own
information but also with a beautiful
color palette of your choice and a font
that you like so you are going to level
up your design skills as well as your
css skills meaning that this is going to
be a lot of fun so let's just get
started with it right away
okay let's start out by having a quick
look at the basic skeleton for our app
as you can see in the file system here
we have an index.html file also a
styles.css file and finally we have an
images folder which contains my avatar
it's a png file called pair.png
now starting with the html it's just a
very simple setup with the html tag and
then the head tag which links to the
styles.css
as for the body it has one direct child
which is a div which will work like kind
of the container for our business card
and inside of that div we have an image
tag we have an h3 with my name we have a
paragraph with the title and an h4 with
the location
moving over to the css we only have one
rule here we're setting the margin to 20
pixels on the body
and if you remember how this works when
we're not specifying either margin top
margin bottom left or right
just setting the margin in general these
20 pixels will be added on all four
sides on the top on the left bottom and
right and that's simply because i want
to avoid that these elements touch the
edges of the mini browser
so
there's a problem though as you can see
the image isn't rendering properly it's
just an icon that is as far as i can
remember not how my face looks like and
the problem is in the image tag
so i want you to try to fix that and i'm
not going to give you any more hints
rather than if you are stuck try to
google html file paths that should help
you so go ahead and give this one a shot
and then i will show you how to solve it
as well when you return back to me
okay let's do this
let's take this string right here and
paste it into google there you can see
that the top result is a w3schools
article let's head into that one here
you can see file path examples let's
zoom in on this one and if we have image
source equals picture.jpg which would be
the same as we have here although our
image is called pair.png that means that
the file is located in the same folder
as the current page
well is that the case now looking at our
current page index.html you can see that
the image is not located in the same
folder as the index.html because the
image lives inside of the images folder
so what we then might need is something
like this where we do images slash and
then the picture name
here it means that the picture is
located in the images folder in the
current folder and that looks correct
the images folder is in the same folder
as index.html and the headshot of me is
located inside of that images folder
that means that we can try to do images
like that slash run the code oh
there we go
we have my avatar imported and are ready
to move on to the next scrim i'll see
you there
okay now we're gonna do a little bit of
housekeeping here because this image
element actually has a serious flaw
because it lacks an important ingredient
that all image tags should have which is
called the alt text or the alternative
text
and that is simply an attribute that is
written like this alt equals and then
inside of quotes you are to write a
description of the image so here it
could be for example pierre
smiling like that however if we run this
code now we can see that seemingly
nothing has changed so why do we at all
write these old texts well first of all
it makes your site accessible because
imagine that a person who is visually
impaired or who is blind is trying to
visit your website in that case they
would use a screen reader which goes
through the html and reads it out loud
to the user
and as for the h3 tag it would be simple
for the screen reader to read out loud
what that says because that is text
however for an image like this one you
need to add an alt tag to describe the
image so that the screen reader has
something to read out loud and secondly
this also works as a fallback if your
image doesn't render properly because
let's say you have a spelling mistake in
the source attribute for example an
extra r well in that case the image
won't render but the alt tag provides as
a backup so that the user seeing this
can kind of understand what was at least
supposed to be there and finally writing
alt text will help your site rank higher
on google meaning you get more search
traffic and that is because the alt tag
most likely provide important metadata
about the image so that google knows how
to use it in a search results page and
if your site is not accessible it might
be punished in the form of ranking lower
so with that in mind let's look at how
to write these old texts and the first
thing you need to know is that you
should not include for example image of
because that's simply not necessary the
screen reader knows that it is an image
because it is an image tag
secondly should be concise meaning less
than 125 characters because a lot of
screen readers will cut off after this
limit has been reached and finally a
trick you should use in order to come up
with a good old text is imagine that you
are describing this image to a person
over the phone so let's try to do that
with an example
here we have an iconic image of muhammad
ali in a boxing match and one way to
write an old text for this could be just
a boxing match but it would actually be
a pretty poor way of describing it
because there's so much more going on
here you have plenty more characters you
can use in order to describe it so a
better one would be two boxers in the
ring one lying down and the other
standing up
that's a good factual explanation but
we're not quite there yet because it
isn't actually describing this iconic
moment when muhammad ali knocked out
sunny listen so if you were to describe
this over the phone you would probably
understand that this description is
pretty shallow so what i would rather
write as an old text for this image
would be muhammad ali in the boxing ring
screaming at sunny listen after knocking
him out that in my opinion properly
describes the intent of this image what
the person who has decided to show this
image on a website is trying to convey
so with that example in mind
i want you to
write what you think is an appropriate
alt text for this image go ahead and do
that right now and then i will show you
what i would write when you return back
to me
okay let's do this
we'll do alt equals quotes and here i
would use my name pair harold bergen
and you can see i'm smiling and i'm
looking at the camera i think that's
important so i'd write smiling at the
camera
finally the background is really playful
and colorful
so i want to include for example
with a
colorful
background like that so if yours was a
bit simpler or shorter don't worry about
it the most important thing is that you
add an alt text and do as best as you
can and actually plenty of developers
never add this so just by adding it you
are actually separating yourself from
most other beginners so with that let's
just move on
the next thing we're going to do is
shrink this image to a suitable size for
our business card because as it is now
it is far too big
so i want you to head over to the
styles.css and solve this challenge you
are to set the width of the image to 150
pixels
and you need to use a class to select
the image element so go ahead and give
this a shot right now
okay hopefully that went well let's now
do it together so first we need to
actually create the class that we are
going to select from the css so let's
head over to the html file here we'll
just do
class equals and i'm going to call this
one an avatar
like that actually now that we have
three of these
on the image element i think for
readability purposes
it works well to break them into three
lines
i think this is a little bit easier to
read then i'll head over to the
styles.css and target the class dot
avatar
and reset the width
to 150 pixels now rerun the code there
we go
so great job solving this challenge
let's move on
okay now you're soon going to start
building the layout of this card however
right now the card kind of blends into
the background there's no separation
between the card and the background so i
want to add a little helper style in
order for us to more clearly separate
the card from the background and for
that we need to grab hold of the outer
element of the card and can you take a
guess what kind of html element do you
think should wrap the entire card
if you guessed a div that is correct
and heading over to the html you can see
we are actually already wrapping the
entire thing in a div so here we have
our container div or card div or
whatever we want to call it
so what i want you to do now is to first
give that div a class and actually i
think you should call it card and then i
want you to select the card class in css
and give it a dotted blue border this is
our helper styles it'll give us a little
blue border around the element so that
we can see how our card div kind of
behaves
and also as you can see from the design
here
none of the elements
touch the edge of the border so it seems
like there's some padding in play here
let's just add 20 pixels of padding on
all sides of the card as well
so go ahead solve these three challenges
and then i'll of course show you the
solution as well
okay let's do this
so first we need to give the card div a
class
i'll head over here and do class equals
card
i'll run this code so that we have this
class in the dom
the next step is to select the class
by doing card
and then adding a border if you remember
from previously that is done through the
border property which takes three values
the first one being the thickness of the
border i'm just gonna set it to one
pixel the second being the quality for
example solid or dotted or dashed or a
few others we're going to use the dotted
one and the color will be blue and there
you can see
boom
we have a border around our entire card
and this will make it a lot easier for
us to work with the card now that we can
see it clearly on the page
finally we want to add 20 pixels of
padding because as you can see here the
elements touch the border on these sides
and we don't want that we want some
space so we'll do padding
20 pixels like that
and there we go
we have solved the challenge
with this in place i think we're ready
to start moving on with fixing the
layout and as you can see on the
finished design here there's a big
difference between this one and our
current one and that is that the current
one is vertical whereas this one is more
horizontal so they stack up differently
we want the image on the left hand side
and the text on the right hand side not
everything on top of each other so
basically we want two columns one for
the image and one for the text
and as you might remember from
previously flexbox helps us create
columns so let's now just experiment by
adding display flex to the card
let's see what happens oh wow
okay so what happened there it actually
turned every single element into a
column in itself that's not exactly what
we want here
so display flex
isn't the entire solution so what we're
going to do now is go out on a tangent
learn a little bit more about this
flexbox concept in css and then return
back to this business card project once
we're ready to build a layout like this
so let's move on and learn more about
flexbox
okay so let's say that you've built some
kind of software as a service and now
you want to sell it then you might have
a page like this
where people can upgrade to pro and they
can choose the individual plan which
gives them one gigabyte and no support
or the enterprise plan which gives them
10 gigabytes and priority support now
i've purposely not given any design to
this example as i wanted to make it as
easy as possible to grasp but hopefully
if you are to create a pricing page to
make it look a lot better than what we
have here so you can see the html right
here for the entire pricing layout i've
wrapped it in a div and i'm using an h2
unordered list a button and so on now
let's say that you instead of having
this one column layout here where
everything stacks on top of each other
you want this two column layout where
you have the individual plan at the left
hand side and the enterprise plan at the
right hand side well if so we know that
flexbox will help us create columns but
if we try turning our container that is
the div with the class of pricing
into a flexbox
you'll see that
it'll break the layout just as we saw in
our business card example because what's
going on here is that flexbox
takes every single item that is every
single direct child
and turns it into a column in itself so
we get a column for the h2 for the
unordered list for the buy button for
the h2 again and so on and this is
obviously not what we want it's far from
this two column layout right here
however there's one hint to be drawn
from this example and that is that if
you check out the unordered list here
see that it has two children of itself
li element
and those two are not their own columns
they are in the same column stacking on
top of each other so it seems as if
flexbox only turns the direct children
into their own columns
so the direct children are the h2 here
the ul the button but not the list items
and once we know that we can use that
knowledge in order to get to this layout
because this layout has two columns that
means that our flexbox container should
have two direct children not six as it
has now and how can we achieve that
well we want this group to be inside of
a direct child of this container and we
want
this group of html elements to also be
inside of another direct child of the
flexbox container so what we'll simply
do is we'll wrap both of these
inside of a div
like that
and we'll indent it for readability
purposes
let's try to run this code having
wrapped one of the two groups into its
own div
and there you can see the four
individuals plan now stacks up just how
we want it
but the rest of the layout is still
broken so we need to do the same thing
down here
like that
run the code and there we go
now our flexbox container actually only
contains two items
this div and this div as it doesn't care
about what's inside of both of those
children it only cares about its direct
children and the result is that we get
the layout we wanted here at least in
terms of having two columns
there's still a problem with lacking
space in between these two children but
we're not going to deal about that right
now for now i'm gonna send you back to
the business card example so that you
can use this to improve our layout
okay we are back at our business card
example and now i want you to use what
you've just learned in order to fix our
cards broken column layout because you
are going to make this card into a two
column instead of a four column which it
is now set as the image name
title and location at four different
columns
but instead we want two columns one for
the image and another one for the text
elements
so
this challenge is solved in the html as
you know we already have a display flex
on the card and the only thing you need
to do is one change inside of our
flexbox so hopefully you're able to do
that go give it a shot and then i will
show you the solution as well
okay hopefully that went well let's do
it together
so the problem is that flexbox treats
each of these elements
as a single child and thus each of them
get its own column
however we only want two columns so we
want these three to be governed by one
flex child so we need to wrap them
inside of a div 12. we'll do like this
open the div and then close the div down
here
and we'll indent these so that we get
some better readability now you can see
the flexbox only has two direct children
this one and this one and that means
that we should get two columns in our
layout and yes we do
brilliant of course there's still a long
way from this design to this design but
we are making great progress here so
let's just keep up the pace and move on
to the next scrim
okay i think looking at this example now
i gotta admit that i'm pretty pleased
with this border one pixel dotted blue
here i think it serves a very nice
purpose which is to highlight for us how
our card is being laid out on the page
so wouldn't it be nice if we could use
that exact technique on other elements
on the page as well for example the
children of the flexbox container that
is this image right here and the div tag
that would have been really neat and we
can do that by for example just copying
this one and adding it for example to
the avatar see there the avatar is got
that blue border as well
however wouldn't it be neat if we
in our html could just quickly apply a
class to any element for example this
one and it would get the same thing as
well so basically the argument i'm
making is that we should create a
dedicated class for this blue border
and what that is is a utility class aka
a class that only sets a single css
property so let me show you how this
would work
let's say that we for example want a
class to make our text italic
then we'll simply do class equals
italic like that
if we run this code nothing has happened
because the class hasn't been created
yet but here we can create the italic
class
and do
font style
italic like that
and now you can see
the name is in italic
now if we want to reuse this we can just
do
class
italic here as well from the code and
the location is also italic and if we
want the entire card italic we can even
add the class here up on the container
element itself
run the code and now this has been
inherited down to all of these elements
and if you're a bit confused about what
i'm doing here it is simply adding two
css classes to a single element do that
simply by adding a space in between the
two classes okay
let's
get rid of these
like that
and delete this one as well now what i
want you to do is create a utility class
for the dotted blue border this is the
styling we have here and then give the
class to both flexbox children in the
html that is the flexbox items you can
see
here and here and also
i think you should give the same class
to the card as well so that you can
remove this line 10 here so go ahead and
give this one a shot and then i will
show you how to do it afterwards as well
okay hopefully that went well let's
start out by creating the class
all right border blue here
and then inside of it i'll just
cut this away and paste it in here
instead now we have a utility class for
blue borders
i'll copy it
and add it
to this flex item and as a second as to
the
image element if we run this code you
can see now both of these
have the blue border around them let's
also add the border blue class to the
flexbox container run the code and boom
there we go now we have an even better
overview over how our elements are laid
out
okay with these blue borders around the
flexbox children it's pretty easy to see
that our layout is pretty far from how
we want it to be
because here you can see in the card
that there's some space in between the
two elements whereas in our example
they're completely crammed together and
also pushed all the way to the left hand
side whereas here they're kind of spaced
out there's some space on the left-hand
side in between the element and also
some space on the right-hand side so
they're kind of spaced out in a nice way
and now i want you to add that
horizontal space around the flex
children there's a flexbox property that
does this and you've seen that property
before however you might have forgotten
it if so then google justify content and
you might find the answer i'm not going
to give you any more hints than that
because if you have forgotten about it
it is a great practice to google it
then once you've figured out the answer
go ahead and add the horizontal space so
that our example becomes a little bit
more like this layout
and just so you know you only need to
add one property for this not multiple
so give it your best shot and then i
will show you the solution afterwards as
well
okay let's do this so the property is
called
justify content
a little bit of a weird name i agree but
that's how it is
and here we can use a range of different
values and the one we're looking for is
called space
around like that and now you can see
both elements now have some space around
them and also we could do space between
then all of the available space will be
between the two items
or we could even do
center as you've seen before then
there's no space in between them but
both of them are centered
and end pushes it all the way to the end
and start keeps it at the start
so this is a super powerful property and
we want the space round value for it as
you can see it's at least getting closer
to the layout we have in our finished
design
so great job let's move on
okay time for a new challenge you are
going to set a fixed width on the card
and then center it on the page because
its behavior is a little bit weird right
now as you can see if we enlarge in the
screen the card gets enlargened as well
and that makes the spacing between the
elements look super weird the aspect
ratio becomes very different from a
business card so we don't want that
instead we want the width to be 400
pixels
so it should be a fixed width and then
we also want the card to be centered on
the page now one thing i want you to
notice when i enlarge in this is that
the card is a display block
even though we've set it to display flex
so that means that flexbox containers by
default our display block and hopefully
you remember from previously that
display block takes up all the available
space in the horizontal axis
and there is also one of the three
ingredients you need in order to center
an element using margins so hopefully
you remember from the google project how
to center block elements so go ahead and
give this one your best shot and then i
will show you the solution as well when
you return back to me
okay let's do this i'll start by setting
the width
to 400 pixels like that now you can see
if we enlarge the screen the card is
stuck to the left-hand side of the
website
so in order to fix that and instead
center it we'll use margins and
hopefully you remember that we'll do
margin
left
and set that to auto that pushes it all
the way to the right hand side because
all of the margin is now on the left
hand side but then in order to even it
out and center it we'll do margin
right as well and set that to auto
and the result of having an equal margin
on the left hand side and the right hand
side is that the card is centered so
great job on solving this challenge
let's move on
okay now let's talk a little bit about
css inheritance and why is that
important well css inheritance allows
you to write so-called dryer code and
dry hair stands for don't repeat
yourself meaning that with css
inheritance you can write less code
though still receive the same result and
that's a good thing because less code
means a smaller surface area for bugs
and it also means that you will be a
more efficient developer
so let's have a look at how css
inheritance works in practice
here i've pulled in a wikipedia article
in our mini browser a really wacky
article about a dancing plague that
happened in 1518
in modern day france where either dozens
or hundreds of people took to the street
and danced for days without no one
really knowing the reason so this is
really weird but properly documented
from multiple sources and here is an
illustration i have no idea what caused
this dance epidemic but i think the
modern theory about their grains being
poisoned by fungus that gave them the
same high as you get from lsd sounds
pretty reasonable
anyway let's not get too far into this
rabbit hole what i want to do is use
this article in order to show you how
inheritance works
so if we head over to the html here you
can see that we are using a bunch of
different tags h1 h4 h2 paragraph and so
forth and let's now say that we want the
text in this article to be aligned to
the center and not to the left side well
then a very poor way of solving that
would be to target the age one first and
then do text align
center like that and then the center is
text and then we can copy that we can do
the same for the h2 and there you see
the h2 is centered
and then we can do it for the
paragraph like that and so on and so on
however
this is not a drive we are repeating
ourselves a lot here and it's not
necessary because
since
the h1 and the h4 and all of these live
inside of the body they will also
inherit some properties from the body
tag so what we can do instead is just
delete all of these now it's back to
left aligned and then here we can add
text align
enter like that
now all of these
elements inside of the body are centered
so as simple as that however there's
only a certain set of properties that
are inherited and actually most
properties are not inherited so then
you're probably wondering well how do i
know which are inherited well let's do
what we always do when we are unsure of
something when we're coding we'll google
it which css properties are inherited
here's the stack overflow question let's
click into that
and scroll down to the first answer and
you can see here is a list of all
inheritable properties you can see it's
down to 19 if we scroll a bit down down
to 41 in total that is quite a lot
however you only need to care about very
few of these one of them being the text
line that you just saw and the others
being the font properties so font family
font weight font size and so on and
finally also the color other than that
don't worry about any of these at this
point you're going to learn some of them
later but to be completely honest
there's a ton of css properties here i
have never heard about before i recorded
this scrim okay now it's time to get
your hand on the keyboard so i want you
to navigate to this stack overflow
question this one right here
and then pick a few random inherited css
properties
and then add them to the body tag up
here to see how they work
you probably have to google them to
figure out what kind of value you should
set to the properties but that's also
just good practice now some of these
just warn you are meant for screen
readers or audio for for example speech
rate and volume and stuff like that so
they might not result in any visual
change on the page but others will so
just pick a few try it out see how it
works in order to experiment a little
bit you can click on this image to get
to the stack overflow question
and then when you have experimented with
a couple of properties i will see you
back in the next scrim
okay now it's time for a challenge in
the business card project because you
are going to center the text inside of
the paragraph and the h4 elements
and that is the
paragraph right here which says
front-end developer and the h4 right
here
because as you can see
both of those elements are now crammed
all the way to the left hand side
whereas in our finished design
they are aligned at the center of this
flex children
directly underneath the name pair harold
borgen and if you're wondering why we're
not caring about centering this one it's
because it takes up the full width of
the container so you can't center or
left or right align it because it takes
up the full width anyway it is the
element that actually decides how wide
this container should be
so
you will only see the paragraph and the
h4 change when you fix this
and the way you should do it is by only
adding one property and then have
inheritance take care of applying that
property to both elements so you're only
going to write one line of code i'm not
going to tell you where you should add
that line of code you have to figure
that out on your own and i'm also not
going to tell you what the property is
called for the value you'll give it but
you have seen it before
so hopefully it's not that foreign to
you so jump into the code and try to
solve this challenge now then of course
revert back to me when you want to see
my solution
okay hopefully that went well now we're
going to use the text align property and
set it to center
but before we do that we need to decide
which element we should target with that
property should we add it to the entire
body for example if so it'll inherit
down
from the body
into the card and then into our flex
children right here and then finally to
these elements as well that works
perfectly fine we can actually try it
text align
center and boom
these two are now centered however
imagine that this card is a part of a
bigger website if so we've now centered
all text inside of the body
which is where all of the html both now
and in the future will live so this
might have second order consequences
perhaps you want to have a nav bar with
a title that isn't text align center but
rather text line right or left
so actually i think it's better to scope
this to for example our card we at least
know now that all the text we currently
have in our card should be aligned to
the center so let's do that instead
let's just remove it from the body and
paste it in here and now we're not
causing any unwanted second order
effects outside of the card so this is
in my opinion a better solution but if
you added it to the body that is a
perfectly valid solution as well so
don't feel that you did a mistake in
coding there's always plenty of ways to
solve things and there's rarely one
right answer there's just consequences
for whatever choice you make so really
good job doing this let's move on
all right now the fun stuff remains
which is adding colors according to the
specified design here so this is a
really rewarding little challenge
that'll make a ton of difference as
you'll go from this boring white layout
here to a nice colorful layout so you're
going to add these three colors as you
can see i've added the hexadecimal
values for each of the colors the black
the blue and the purple
the purple is the border at the bottom
here the blue is the background color of
course and then finally you might wonder
well what's the black well that is
actually the text color as the text here
isn't pure black
as it uses this shade of black instead
now you might wonder well
how do i create this order at the bottom
here i've only learned how to create
borders around an entire element
previously well the way to solve any
problem when coding is to google it so
let's just write border bottom css in
google there you can see a w3schools
article click in on it and here it has
some code examples which we can zoom in
on
set the style of the bottom border for
different elements and here it shows us
how to set the border bottom so we do
border dash bottom and then for example
5px solid red well that's exactly how
we'd set the border itself except that
we would omit this dash bottom in the
property name so you'll use the exact
same technique you've used for the
entire border just with this extra word
added to the end so hopefully you'll be
able to do that so here is the design
and a final thing i'm going to do before
i'll leave it to you is to remove these
blue borders here because we don't need
them anymore so let's head into the html
i'm going to mark the border blue
utility class we've added do command
plus d that enables you to select
multiple instances of whatever you've
highlighted and then
boom i'm going to remove it like that
then also we don't need any class in the
div
for this flex children anymore in the
code our borders are gone
i'll leave this for now
in case you want to add it back again
but now it's your turn
go ahead and try to solve this challenge
and then of course i will show you the
solution when you return back to me
okay hopefully that went well let's now
do it together i'm going to start with
the blue background as that'll make the
biggest difference so i'll do
background
and copy this hex value like that very
good
then i'll do the text color that is
color
and copy the one right here
yes not as visible as the previous
change but something surely happened
we're now using that shade of black for
the text and finally the purple border
bottom will be added by doing border
dash
autumn
and then let's try two pixels and we
want to use solid
then the purple color
okay we can see a thin border at the
bottom let's have a look at the design
it looks like it is definitely thicker
here so let's crank it up a little bit
for example six pixels
yes that looks pretty good to me
actually so
really good job reaching this far you
are very close to the end right now so
let's just keep up this great pace and
finish up this project over the next few
scripts
okay now i want to talk a little bit
about fonts because fonts are actually
really important let's say that you for
example have created a computer
specialist company called click lovers
well you might want to think about which
font you choose in that case or if
you're the owner of the megaflix shop
you should also think carefully about
which font you choose finally if you are
the head of the wig and pen association
make sure that your font spaces out
words correctly now these are of course
extreme cases and they're all on prints
you'll rarely see cases as bad as this
on the web but fonts really matter
online as well let's take wikipedia for
example here is a random article about
people who have died from laughter as
you can see wikipedia has this very
serious nice font but if we change that
to something like comic sans you can see
the text gives a whole different type of
association it went from being very
serious like this to being more like a
comic book
so when you are building projects it is
important that you choose a font that
kind of suits your project
so let's move on to look at how it works
technically under the hood
because when you visit a website for
example scrimba.com you visit it via a
client that could be your mobile tablet
desktop or whatever
what happens is that when you type
www.scramble.com into the url bar it
sends a request to scrimbus server and
then the server says yeah okay you want
to visit our website yeah of course here
you go and it takes everything you need
in order to run the scrimba in the
browser that is the html the css the
javascript the assets which can be
images and videos and so forth then also
the recipe for the font and then it
sends that back to the client
however for some websites they won't
send you the recipe for the font over
the network because they will instead on
their website use a font that most
likely is already pre-installed in your
client that is also called a web safe
font meaning that the recipe for
rendering that font exists in most
clients now of course there might be
some clients that don't have that
specific font but in almost all cases
it's safe to use one of the web safe
fonts without sending the recipe for it
over the network
so what are these web save fonts well
here is an article on v3 schools where
you can see all of the web save fonts
for html and css so when you're using
these you don't have to send the recipe
for the font over the network
now for our digital business card we're
only going to use web save fonts but
later down the line you'll also learn
how to pull in external fonts so that
you can go outside of these 10 fonts as
they don't really give you a lot of
flexibility so with that in place let's
look at how you actually use a font in
css
so in order to set the font you first
target normally the body and then type
out font family and then the name of the
font and here you can see we've typed v
e and that triggers vs code which is the
editor powering scrimba to come up with
suggestions for you you can see it
doesn't only suggest verdana which is
the font we want it also adds a bunch of
other fonts after it
all separated by comma so if we hit
enter now boom then we've added what's
called a font stack and what this means
is that if the browser finds the verdana
font installed it finds the recipe for
that font well then it will use it
however if it can't find it if verdana
isn't installed in the client's computer
then it'll try to find geneva which is a
pretty similar font if it can't find
geneva it'll jump on and try tahoma and
if it can't even find tahoma it says
well give me any sans serif font and
sans serif is a category of fonts so
here it's just saying give me any font
from this category and there are mainly
two categories sans serif and serif here
you can see an example of both of them
serif fonts contain these decorative
strokes at the end of the letters you
can see it here
here
here where's sans serif is without those
decorative endings
so sans then means without or not or
something like that you get the point
okay that was a lot of theory now it is
your turn you are going to set the font
here to verdana and also make sure to
remember to get the entire font stack so
that we have backups in case the client
doesn't include the verdana font
so go ahead and do that right now
okay hopefully that went well what you'd
want to do is font family colon
start typing and then the editor
suggests the entire font stack though
you won't see that now because the
scrimba dom recorder doesn't record it
however i can see it so i'm just gonna
hit enter and boom the editor suggested
this entire font stack with me
we have changed the font let's verify
that by removing it boom yeah that's
different from this
so really good job we've actually now
completed the design for our business
card however there's a little issue with
our code because this is how noobs write
their margins and i want to teach you
how the pros do it so let's move on to
the next scrim where you'll learn
exactly that
okay now it's time to learn about the
shorthands for margin and padding and
you've actually been exposed to one of
them already which is that if you have
the same value on the margin top right
bottom and left you can reduce those
four lines into one margin 10px then the
browser will take this 10px and apply
them to all sides so these four lines
are identical to this one down here now
the question becomes what happens when
you have four different values for
example 10 px 20 px 30 and 40. well if
so you have to do like this
margin and then 10 px 20 30 40. so the
first one is margin top the second one
is right the third one is bottom and the
fourth one is left so now you're
probably thinking well how can i
possibly remember this order and the
trick is to think of the clock
it starts at the top then goes to the
right then goes to the bottom and then
goes to the left so with that in mind i
want you to improve this code here
which creates the japanese flag in css
because as you can see this red circle
here which is
a div
has a few styles applied up here but
down here we've used the non shorthand
way to set the margins
setting some margin on the top so that
the circle is pushed down
nothing on the right and the bottom but
100 pixels on the left so that it's
pushed to more or less the center of the
screen given that the screen is as wide
as it is right now so i want you to
translate this into using the margin
shorthand instead go ahead and do that
right now
okay hopefully that went well i'm going
to actually comment these lines out now
you can see the red circle is up in the
left corner and then i'm going to do
margin starting at the top should be 40
pixels then the right side 0 pixels and
the bottom should also have 0 pixels and
then the left side which should have 100
pixels and there we go we are back at
the exact same layout so great job if
you manage to solve this
now there's another scenario i want to
teach you about as well which is if we
have top and bottom as one value and
right and left as another value if so
you can actually reduce it to margin and
then only two values here you do 10px
and auto because 10px is top and bottom
and auto is left and right so the way to
think about this is that the first value
controls the
vertical line the y-axis and the second
value controls the horizontal line also
known as the x-axis so with that in mind
let me change this a little bit i'm
going to go back to the funky way of
writing this and i'm actually going to
improve it a little bit because if we
want to center the circle we shouldn't
hard code a margin left because that'll
only work on this screen size when we do
like this it's not centered anymore so
let's instead use the better technique
of using auto on the left hand side and
the right hand side and also just to
make sure that no elements are allowed
to appear directly underneath our circle
i want to add 40 pixels to the margin
bottom so now i'll make it a little bit
easier for you and separate these two
with this in mind
can you reduce these four lines into two
go ahead and give that a shot right now
okay let's do this
i'll comment out these and if you
wondered what shortcut i used for that
i'm using command plus k plus c but that
is on a mac keyboard i'll comment this
out
then i'll do margin first we'll set the
vertical axis it should have 40 pixels
at the top and the bottom so that is
40px and then we'll set the horizontal
axis which is auto like that and boom
there we go we have it centered at least
horizontally regardless of how wide the
screen is and we have reduced four lines
into one so great job let's move on
okay now you're gonna take what you've
learned about the margin shorthand and
use that in order to reduce these two
lines into one so you're going to
replace the two margin properties with a
single margin shorthand and of course
after you've done that the card should
still be centered as it is now
so go ahead and give this one your best
shot
okay let's do this so i'm going to start
by removing both of these
now you can see the card is aligned on
the left side
so in order to fix this we'll do margin
and then the first property we'll set
will be the vertical line meaning margin
top and margin bottom because we're only
going to set two values and when we do
that each of the value dictates two
sides either top bottom or left right so
we'll set zero as the first value that
means margin top zero and margin bottom
zero
then for the second value which dictates
the horizontal margin meaning left hand
side and right hand side we'll set of
course auto and there
you see now the card is still centered
and we have reduced two lines into one
so great job solving this challenge
last time we deployed a project we first
added our code to netlify which then
again took care of deploying our project
to the web now while this works
perfectly fine the way the pros do it is
to go via an intermediate service and
step called github and then let github
take care of sending off the code to
netlify so that it's deployed to the web
and the reason you want this kind of
architecture is because github allows
you to collaborate on your code with
other developers so now we are going to
deploy your business card using this
technique the first thing you need to do
is head over to github if you're
watching this course on scrimba you can
just click on this slide right here but
if you're following us on youtube just
head over to github.com and you'll get
to the exact same page once you're there
i want you to click at the sign up
button that'll open up a form where you
have to add your email create a password
and also choose a username once you've
done all that click the continue button
which then sends you to this onboarding
screen where you can add a little bit of
information about yourself or just click
on the skip personalization option if
you are impatient once you've done this
you'll see a dashboard yours is probably
not as filled with information as mine
though that doesn't matter what we're
going to do now is click on the plus
icon in the top right corner there it
opens up a menu where you are to choose
new repository the repository is the
backbone of any software project this is
where you'll find all the project files
and github along with the git protocol
takes care of tracking all the changes
that has been done to the repository
from its birth though we're getting
ahead of ourselves right now we are just
going to give it a name which you type
in here in the repository name field
like that i'm going to call it business
card and then i'm not going to touch any
of the options here i'm just going to
scroll down and click create repository
and there we go now we have to upload
our files we can do that in many
different ways right now we're just
going to do the very simplest one so
what i want you to do is click on the
uploading and existing file link right
here as that'll take you to a drag and
drop field quite similar to what we saw
at netlify earlier here i want you to
open up the business card folder which
you created on your local computer in
the previous scrim mark all of the files
and then just drag and drop them into
the rectangle at github once you've done
that you'll see all of your files listed
just scroll a little bit down and then
we have to do something called commit
changes which might seem a little bit
weird and complicated but don't worry
about that right now i'm just going to
go with the recommended text add files
via upload and then hit commit changes
and boom there we go we have a
repository on github which includes all
the code we need for our business card
now if you were to collaborate with
other developers on this project they
would push their code up to this
specific repository and you would also
probably create issues for tasks you
want to do and work with something
called pull requests which is when you
want to merge someone's changes into the
code base and there's also a ton of
other things you can do here but we're
not going to worry about any of that
right now because the only thing we want
to use this repository for right now is
as an intermediate step before our
deployment so let's head over to netlify
and make sure you're logged in so you
see the previous project we deployed and
right besides it you can see this button
called add new site click on it and
choose import an existing project here
you're able to choose github click on
that and it'll open this pop-up menu
where github asks where you want to
install netfly because that's what
you're doing now we're installing
netlify on our github profile click on
your github username in my case peer
borgin and here i'm just going to leave
all the settings as they are scroll down
and hit install and there we go now you
can see that netlify has pulled in your
github profile and has your repositories
listed i have a bunch of repositories so
i'll have to search for the business
card i'll write business and there we
can see it when i click on this
repository it is imported into netlify
and here i can adjust some settings but
i'm not going to do any of that as usual
just scroll down to the bottom and hit
deploy site and there we go the
deployment is now in progress so we'll
have to wait a little bit and then once
this image turns into a screenshot of
your site it is deployed so clicking on
this link will open up our business card
really good job though i hope your
business card looks a lot cooler than
this as you were to personalize it in
the previous scrim
actually to prove to me that you and
personalize this i want you to head over
to twitter and share your deployed
business card do as michael rocket does
here and mention me if you want to
alongside a link to your project and
perhaps even a screenshot of it that
would be super cool so go ahead and do
that right now and then i'll see you in
the next scrim
woohoo you've just completed the
business card section of this course
that is very well done now let's have a
little look at what you've learned
starting out you learned about image alt
text which is a really important html
attribute that makes your sites more
accessible next up you learned about
flex child containers which means that
we took this flexbox layout here the
card and made sure that it only had two
direct children so that is one container
and two flex items so that these two
stacked up besides each other on columns
however we wanted the content inside of
the second column to be on rows and for
that reason we had to turn this flex
child into a container in itself so that
these three could stack on top of each
other you also learned about inheritance
for example here with the card class
where we set the text line to center and
that propagated all the way down from
the card via the div and down to its
grandchildren the text elements that
contain the data for the business card
and also you learned about shorthands
more specifically the margin and padding
shorthands where we instead of
specifying each margin like the top left
right and bottom we just use the
shorthand zero auto to set zero on the
top and bottom and then auto on the left
and right
and then you learned about web save
fonts which are these fonts that you can
use pretty much without worrying about
whether or not they are installed on the
user's computer because in the overall
majority of cases they actually are so
they are safe to use and we took a look
at color palettes which is critical to
know about as colors often make or break
a design and then finally you learned
about github and how to create a
repository for github and use that as an
intermediate step when getting your code
from your local computer and up to the
world wide web via a netlife deployment
so this was a lot of things to learn i
can totally understand if you are a
little bit overwhelmed now take a little
break and let these concepts mature in
your mind and then i will see you back
here when you are ready to move on with
the course
welcome to the section where you are
going to build a space exploration site
here is the example you're gonna build
as you can see it has this super neat
background image that animates and it
really breathes life into the site we're
also using google fonts to pull in this
custom space-ish font right here and
we're doing a lot of interesting things
with some subtle text shadows this
underline and more
so there will be plenty of new things to
learn in addition to reinforcing html
and css concepts you've previously
learned
so let's launch into this section
okay let's get started building our
space expiration site as you can see
i've set up a basic html structure for
you here it is very simple as the body
simply contains an h1 title and a button
as for the css there is no as we are
going to add that now so the first thing
we're going to do is fix the background
here because we don't want the white
background we want to have an image of
the universe in the background later
down the line we're going to change that
to an animated image so that it looks
like a video playing in the background
which is even cooler but as for now
we're just going to do a standard
background image as we're going to work
on this for a while and i don't want to
have an animated image looping in the
background as we work as i think that's
a little bit annoying so let's start out
with just a static background image and
just so you know background images is
something different than how you've used
images up until now where you've done
img src some kind of jpeg like that
instead background images are not in the
html they are added in the css file and
i'll talk about that let's just find a
cool background image and then deal with
how to implement it into our app and the
service i prefer to use for finding cool
images for your web design is unsplash
because the quality of images here are
really good so they will take your web
design to new heights and you can use
them freely however you want so if i
search here for universe
we'll get a ton of nice images let's
scroll a bit down as you can see there's
plenty of good candidates here but i
think this one is particularly nice so
i'm going to click in on it it is
created by guillermo ferla and you can
see it's really popular have over 12
million views already now if we want to
download this you can click on the icon
up here and download it range of
different sizes
and i've actually done that and placed
it here in the images folder so here you
can see universe.jpg
so let's see how we can add this to our
app what i'm going to do is target the
body because we want the image to span
across the entirety of our page so we
need to add the background image to the
body we'll use the background image
property here we'll utilize something
called a css function don't worry about
why it's called the css function
just remember that the way to do it is
by writing url
open parentheses and then inside of the
parenthesis you refer to the image
source just as you do in the image with
the img tag it is using quotes
so inside of the quotes we'll write the
path to this exact image and the way we
do that is first by navigating to the
images folder so images then slash going
into the folder choosing the universe
up jpeg and boom there we go suddenly
our background changed however there's a
couple of problems here our h1 is now
almost invisible since by default the
text is black and the background is very
black as well so i'm going to change the
color to white like that
much better
also this image is thousands of pixels
wide whereas our browser is not that
wide so notice that if we make it super
wide we still only see edge of the
galaxy more or less the center of the
image so what we need to do is shrink
our browser down to like a couple of
hundred pixels wide which is what we
want
and then make our background image
shrink so that it's squeezed into the
width of this browser
the way we do that is background size
and value cover boom there we go now the
width of the background image is exactly
as the width of its container
which again is exactly as wide as the
browser itself meaning that the browser
and the background image has the exact
same width and it looks pretty good i'm
not going to give you a challenge on how
to do this right now as you'll get
plenty of practice using background
images later in this course so with that
let's just move on to the next scrim
okay in this two part challenge you're
going to improve the design of our app
first i want you to center the text and
button and then style the button
according to the provided design and
that is found here in the slide as you
can see the button is slightly different
from how it is right now not too
different but certainly it has some css
properties applied and i'm not going to
tell you which because this is a good
way for you to train your design eye
when you design the button i want you to
use a class in order to select it so not
just using an element selector like we
do here
so go ahead and give this a shot and
then i will show you the solution as
well when you return back to me
okay let's do this
first we got to center the text on the
button and here you can use a range of
different options either using margins
or flexbox or text align
you've learned plenty of ways to center
elements now
i'm going to choose the easiest one
which is to apply a text align center in
the body element because as you know
this centers not only the h1 but also
buttons
okay with that out of the way let's move
on to the button
first i want to give it a class and i
think btn is a good class name so let's
add it to the html as well like that and
run the code so we have it applied in
the dom
now let's have a look at this design
the first thing that is apparent to me
is that this button has more space
around the text as you can see here it's
a bit more crammed so that is the
padding property
let's write 10 pixels just on all four
sides of the padding
having a look at this button right now
you can see that this one is a bit more
rectangular whereas this one is a bit
more squared now because in this design
here
there's more space on the left and right
hand side then the top and bottom
and if you remember the shorthand we can
do this by for example starting with 5
pixels on the top and bottom
and 10 pixels on the left and right
and that looks much better
maybe it's a little bit higher so let's
do 6 and
12. that looks pretty good to me
now the next thing i want to change is
the background color
it's not totally apparent but actually
this one has a white background color
whereas this one has the default button
background color which is a bit grayer
it's not that easy to see because of the
background here it looks pretty white
compared to the black background but it
is actually not entirely white something
you'd know if you worked with buttons in
html for a while as they always have a
default grayish background color
background
white like that okay
now it suddenly became apparent that it
also has a border in this default
styling whereas that's not the case in
our provided design
so let's do border
we can do none like that
and with that it looks like we have
completed our design as these two look
identical as far as i can see so really
good job let's move on
okay now you're gonna get a new
superpower in your tool belt called
google fonts and that is a service that
gives you access to over a thousand
different high quality fonts that you
can use in your projects
and the reason you need to learn about
this now is because the font we have
here isn't good enough in my opinion it
is a little bit boring for a space
project what we want instead is
something like this which looks a lot
more sci-fi-ish however this font isn't
one of the so-called web save fonts you
learned about earlier which is already
installed in most operating systems this
is a very custom font so we have to use
google fonts in order to bring it into
our project
and here you can see the google fonts
interface it's located at
font.google.com
and if we scroll a bit down you can see
it contains a range of very different
fonts
now it has a search feature up in the
top left corner but it's actually not
that good to be honest it's better to
just use regular google search when
searching for google fonts so let's do
that instead the way i found the font
we're going to use now is just by
googling sci-fi
and then google font and then google
suggested this orbitron font so if we
click into it you can see here it is if
we scroll a bit down you can see we have
to choose specifically which styles we
want so i'm going to choose this 400
regular style by clicking on select this
style like that and you can see the
panel on the right hand side and it is
clear that we have chosen the orbitron
font and the regular 400 font weight
also let's click on this extra bold in
case we want to build some text on our
site and there we have that one as well
now if we want to use this on the web we
can embed it by simply copying a piece
of code into the head of our html and
that is the code you want to copy
and then paste it in
exactly here next up we also have to
specify it in our css and that's done by
pasting this line
into our css for example in the body tag
i'm not going to do this for you though
scrimba is all about you doing things on
your own getting your hands on the
keyboard so now i want you to head over
to google fonts fetch the orbitron font
in these two styles
and then do whatever you need to do in
order to make the orbitron font render
properly on our site i'm going to leave
you here with this screenshot because
make sure to compare
this design with what you get in the
mini browser because there might be
something you need to do down in the btn
selector and hopefully you're able to
spot that if not no worries because i'll
be here showing you the solution when
you return back to me
good luck
okay let's do this
so first we're to take this snippet of
code right here and then paste it into
our html like that we'll then need to
run the code so that it is imported into
our project
and then next up it is the styles which
we're going to set here let's copy that
line of code and then simply paste it in
right here and boom drawing the
exploration now looks like our project
right here
however this one also has the orbitron
font applied to the button
but we don't have that we still use that
boring old font that we had previously
why is that well that's actually because
buttons
don't inherit font families
so here the h1 has inherited the font
property from body but the button has
not so what we need to do here is
specifically tell the button to have
this font family and we can do that in
two ways one way is through using a css
value you haven't learned yet and that
is
the inherit keyword
as you can see now it does inherit from
the body but only because we've
specifically told the button to do
exactly that what i'm assuming you did
instead which works perfectly fine as
well is simply to paste in the font
family orbitron on the btn class as you
can see that also works well so
hopefully you were able to spot this if
not nowhere is it was just a little
gotcha i left here let's move on to the
next scrim
before we move on from the subject of
fonts there's one more technique i want
to teach you because in some cases
google fonts might actually not be
enough and that's typically the case if
you want very specific fonts for example
let's say that you are building a
godfather website in honor of the
classic film well in that case you'd
probably want to get a hold of the real
godfather font though google fonts
doesn't host that one because it is
simply too specific for them to care
about
so you'd most likely have to find this
font somewhere on the world wide web and
there are great services for this for
example
1001font.com there if you search for
godfather they actually have it so you
can click into it scroll a little bit
down and click download so what you then
did is kind of downloaded the recipe for
the font and if you open up the folder
you got you'll see a ttf file that's a
file format for fonts what you then can
do is simply drag and drop that file
into your file system like i have done
right here you can see i have the
corleone.ttf file now what i can do is
use the add font face rule in css so
simply writing an at and then font dash
face and then open up the curly brackets
and write two properties the source
which should use the url technique
pointing to the ttf file which i'm doing
right here and also i need to tell css
what name i want to give this font in my
style sheets and i'm just going to
choose corleona for now but i could have
chosen whatever name i wanted now i'm
able to target the h1 and use this font
family so i'll do font family
or leona and there you can see i have
the godfather font so i'm off to a great
start on my tribute page so now what i
think you should do is actually try and
do this yourself find a random font
online download it so you get a hold of
the ttf file drag and drop that ttf file
into the file system here on scrimba and
use the add font face property to make
that font available in your stylesheets
once you've done that i will see you in
the next scrim
now you are going to learn about the
span tag because in the next scrim you
are going to create an underline under
the exploration word and in order to
achieve that you need the span tag so
let's take a little step back from our
space exploration site and learn all
about this awesome tag
the example we're going to use in order
to learn the span tag is of banner ads
you've probably seen these before and
you've browsed the web for example on
new sites
and many of these are actually so-called
html5 ads where they're built using html
and css and it's actually a little bit
sad how many clever developers in this
world who are spending all of their time
in their best years and getting more
people to click on these ads through
making them more invasive more
eye-catching and more targeted but
that's the name of the game so we just
have to accept it and you are now going
to do exactly that you are going to make
this ad more eye-catching so that
hopefully more people click on it and
visit our scammy casino
so how do we do this well looking at the
html you can see the div wrapper has a
class of add which sets the background
color border and the text alignment
inside of this green rectangle and there
are two elements inside of the ad that
is the h1 and the h3 and it says click
here so what we want to do is make this
hair word pop out more so how do we do
that we can't target the h3 itself
because that'll style the entire
sentence we only want to style this word
and this is where spans come in here we
can write span like that
open the tag before the word and close
it directly afterward if we now run this
code seemingly nothing has happened
because spans are invisible unless you
give them styling
so they're kind of like the div as divs
neither provide any styling unless you
give it to it specifically although the
difference is that spans are in line
whereas divs are block-based
so to demonstrate that if we change this
to div what would happen to run the code
is that it would break the hair word
onto a new line because divs are display
block they take up all the available
space in the width
where spans do not do that only take up
the space they need in order to make
room for this content
what we now can do is give this span a
class
i'm going to call it cta that's short
for call to action because that's
normally what these kinds of elements
are called and in the css we'll do cta
let's just see that it works
by doing color red yes there we can see
we have now only targeted the hear word
this doesn't look particularly good
though so let's instead do something
that makes it look a bit more like a
button
for that we need a border in my opinion
for example two pixels and we want it to
be solid and here let's steal the color
from the border around the ad so that we
reuse it a little bit i think that can
look nice yeah okay here you can see
that it's added a border around the word
it is very crammed on the left and right
hand side so let's try to add some
padding let's just do five pixels or
something
actually i think we can do five pixels
on the top and 10 pixels on the left and
right yeah that looks much better and
then to make it pop out even more so
that it doesn't blend into the overall
background we have on the ad itself
so i'm going to do background well now i
happen to have a nice brown color here
which i think looks decent with the
other colors here
so now it is a lot more easier to see
that you are going to click here on this
thing that looks like a button as it
stands out more and hopefully we have
increased the click-through rate with
0.02
and thus made our boss really happy
so great job
now that you've learned this let's
return back to the space exploration
site and put your new skills to the test
okay now you're going to create this
neat little underline under the
exploration word
and i want you to do that using a span
and a class as for the specific design
of the underline and what kind of css
property you are to use that is
something you'll have to figure out on
your own
so go ahead and give this a shot good
luck and i'll see you on the other side
okay hopefully that went well
let's do it i'm going to start with
adding this spam to the html
it should wrap the exploration word so
spam like that
and then i'm going to give it a class
i'm going to call this class underline
because it'll only have one job and that
is to give the expiration word the
underline so this class is something
we've talked about earlier it's a
utility class it only has one job and
that is setting a single css property so
if we run the code now nothing has
seemingly happened but we do have this
in our dom meaning we can select it in
the css we'll do dot underline
like that let's just try and set the
color to red to see that it works and
yes it does indeed work
but that's not the effect we want we
want to set the underline and what is
this underline well it's actually just a
border bottom we do border
bottom like that
two pixels
solid
white you can see yes we indeed get a
border under it
however this border looks a little bit
thicker so i don't think two pixels is
the correct thickness i think we want to
have something like four
yes
that looks pretty good to me
so we have solved this challenge and we
are ready to move on
okay now we are going to add this spacex
logo at the top here and while you're
adding it you're going to learn a whole
new concept in html and css
namely a close custom of the class
attribute which is called the
id attribute and the way to use it is
simply by writing id instead of class
but now you're probably wondering why
would we use this id if we now try to
rerun this code you can see that our
underline is gone
and that is because when you are using
an id like this
you have to refer to it in the css not
by using a dot but instead by using a
hashtag there you can see now our border
bottom is again applied to our example
so now you're probably wondering well
why would we want to use this it just
further complicates things by having
both ids and classes to worry about and
the thing is they serve two different
scenarios you should use an id if you
know that your element is unique and
you'll only use it once so id of
underline should only be applied once in
this entire document whereas class is
something you can reuse again and again
it's meant for reusage so if you for
example wanted a button here
that also said for example f a cues
then a class is what you use in order to
make sure that this button has the same
styling as this button but if you did
that with ids
and turned the btn here into an id this
would be invalid html
browsers are very forgiving so it
probably would work technically the
styling would be applied but you just
shouldn't do it
now as for this idea of underline here i
actually don't think it makes sense to
use an id
because this underline here could
perfectly fine be a part of our design
system and also be applied at multiple
other sections and paragraphs throughout
our entire page as we build out this
space exploration site so i want to have
the freedom to be able to reuse this
later as well even though i'm only using
it once now so i'm going to turn this
into a class again
rerun the example now it's not applied
and then go from the id selector to the
class selector in css by replacing the
hashtag with a dot and there it is
applied
so that was a long intro the reason for
that was that i want you to render this
spacex logo you can see i've added the
spacex.png image file up here
and then i want to give it id
because this spacex logo at the top here
is most likely unique we probably don't
want to have multiple centered spacex
logos at this size so this is kind of
our main logo and you can give it that
id main logo
then in the css you need to select the
logo using whatever id you have given it
and then as you'll see you'll have to
reduce its size that's why you need this
css rule right here because it is far
too big this image finally i'm going to
remove this faq button so that we're
back to our original design now it's
your turn take over and try to solve
this challenge
okay hopefully that went well let's do
it we're going to render it using an imd
tag
and the source will be
first images and then slash
spacex dot png
like that if we run this you can see oh
wow
that is not exactly what we were looking
for it's far too big this image so we
have to reduce its size and to target it
we're going to use an id and i'm going
to call this main logo like that
now if we head to the style.css
we'll do hashtag main dash logo and here
we have to reduce its width so let's try
with for example
perhaps this is 200 pixels i don't know
let's try
200 px like that oh
that was a bit too large in my opinion
so let's reduce it further
to 100 pixels and yes that is
much more like our design in my opinion
looking pretty good so with that we have
solved the challenge great job
now we're going to breathe some more
life into our example here because
it works fine with this static jpeg as
the background image but wouldn't it be
a lot cooler if it was animated so you
could see the stars flying around and in
our images folder we now just happen to
have a file called galaxy dot web p
what's that let's just try to replace
this universe jpeg here with the galaxy
webp file
so i'll do galaxy
dot
web p and boom
the galaxy webp is an animated image in
which you see a bunch of stars around
the galaxy and to me this looks a lot
cooler than what we just had
now you might wonder what this web p
here is and that is just an image format
pretty similar to so-called gifs gif and
gif is what you recognize from all over
the web in animated images like this one
right here which you've probably seen
before so webp is used exactly as gifs
are on the web however it has a better
compression so it's more compact and
doesn't use as much data as gifs use
when they're sent from a server to a
client
so we want to use webp where we can
and now you might wonder well where did
you find this galaxy.webp image that is
on a site called giphy giphy that is a
search engine for gifs so i just
navigated to it searched for galaxy
scrolled a little bit down and found
this neat looking galaxy gif here
created by the european space agency now
this is a slideshow so you can't see
that this gif is now being animated but
it actually is because i just saved this
image to my local computer and then
uploaded it to the images folder right
here now if you want you can also click
on the share button here and click copy
gift link and then you can simply paste
that link into this url and then that
will give as you see the exact same
result but i prefer to rather use the
version which we've imported into our
project right here in case the griffey
file might change at some point or
something however for experimentation
purposes i think you should head over to
griffe search for a few images and just
paste them in right here and see how
that affects our example just so you've
got familiar with using giphy and
pasting external urls into the
background image property in css
so go ahead and do that and then i will
see you in the next scrim
one thing i like to do when working with
images as backgrounds is to fetch colors
from the image and use it in the design
because that can often look pretty cool
so let me show you exactly how to do
that
we can use coolers these servers you're
already familiar with because if you
click on the more option in the nav bar
you can choose pick palette from photo
that'll take you to this image picker
where you can choose an image by
clicking on the browse an image and
either upload the image or paste a url
to it
once you've done that you're taken to
this nice tool
where you can either drag and drop this
picker around on the image until you
find the color you like or you can use
this range input here as that'll
automatically try to find interesting
colors in the image for you and then it
generates a palette as you can see right
here
now let's say we like this palette then
we'll click export and save palette and
we have it in our dashboard
now it only has three colors but that
doesn't matter i'm only going to use one
of these that is the blue one because i
think it would be cool to use this blue
color
as the text color on our site so i want
the h1 and the button text to have that
bluish color and the way i'm going to do
that is change the color of the body
here because that is where the h1 gets
its color from it is the only element
inheriting from the body at this point
so i'm going to do like that this is the
hexadecimal value i got from coolers and
as you can see i think it looks pretty
cool
and also let's keep the underline white
because i think it makes sense to have
that in a different color now moving on
to the button we'll do
color
and paste it in again and there we go
now here i think actually this applied
text could be a bit clearer because the
contrast with the background is just
okay at this point
because with this blue color i think the
thin letters became a bit too thin
now a final thing i want to do with this
apply text here is make it a little bit
bolder make it stand out a bit more and
luckily we imported
not only the regular font weight with
the orbitron font family but also the
800 font weight to the extra bolt
so what we can do now is actually
do
font weight
and then press bold and there you can
see
it actually bolded the text
or we could use the value directly
which is 800 that'll give us the exact
same result as the font weight property
can both take numerical values and named
values so the numerical values range
from 100 200 300 400 and so forth up
until 900 and the named values are for
example normal bold and so on so
we imported 800 so let's just write 800
here with that i think our example looks
pretty good so let's move on
going to space is definitely a risky
affair so i want to add this terms and
conditions apply text underneath the
main section of our site however i don't
want to add this this is scrimba so
you're going to do it of course but i'm
going to give you a set of detailed
instructions so that you know how to go
about doing this
so you're going to start with wrapping
the hero section in a div and the hero
section is the one you can see on top
here it's very often called a hero
section in web design and it's probably
called that because kind of serves as
the user's first glimpse of the company
and the offering and has this kind of
prominent place towards the top and it
usually extends full width so it is kind
of the hero of the website so in our
case it is these three elements right
here the logo title and the call to
action button and those should all be
wrapped inside of a div and then i want
you to move the background image that is
the animated galaxy image
from the body and over into this div now
as you do that you'll notice that you'll
have to add some padding to this hero
div as it'll look really crammed if you
don't add that then i want you to add
the terms and conditions apply in an h3
below the hero section and then finally
a problem you'll probably come across is
that the body tag has some default
margins which right now doesn't bother
us but which will become apparent once
you change this layout so go ahead and
give this one your best shot and when
you return back to me i'll show you how
to do it as well
okay let's go i'm gonna start with the
hero section div i'm gonna add it right
here i'll give it an idea of hero
because it is unique so it's okay to use
id
then i'm going to indent this in
and run the code and seemingly nothing
has happened because as you remember
from previously divs don't have any
default styling to them so what we need
to do is
target the
hero
and then move the background properties
from the body
to the hero and there we go
as you can see it doesn't look
particularly good now as i said we will
be forced to deal with the padding in
the hero because you can see here this
logo is really crammed all the way up to
the top and there's no space underneath
the button so let's add padding
and on the top maybe we want 10 pixels
like that yes on the right hand side we
don't need anything for now but on the
bottom we want a lot of padding maybe
we'll do 40 pixels like that and then on
the left hand side you don't need
anything either
so here we have the padding
now let's add the terms and conditions
apply h3 below the hero
that's just
like this adding an h3 terms and
conditions apply like that
from the code and there we go it has
already the color we want since we have
set the blue color as the text color on
the body so it inherits the color
property from the body however as you
can see are still not quite done because
something has happened with the margins
on the site or at least the margins of
the body has become more apparent
because now the entire body isn't filled
with the background image anymore so
we're suddenly noticing that the body
has some default margins on all sides we
don't want that
so we're gonna neutralize that by doing
margin zero and boom there we go
we have completed the challenge now
there is one more thing which is a
little bit problematic which is that if
you watch this on a mobile for example
so that the exploration word is located
directly over the galaxy the readability
syncs quite a bit because the text color
blends in with the background and we
will fix that is by using a shadow
technique on this text so now you're
going to learn exactly that
text shadow is a really nice tool to
have in your web design toolkit as it
can make your designs much better
so here i've created a very simple
imitation of the netflix logo with the
red background and white text
as you can see i've pulled in a font
which kind of looks like the netflix
font it's not really the same but it's
close enough
and
it is an h1 and i've set the font size
to 80 pixels now what if i want to have
a black shadow like this
as that makes it look even more like the
classical netflix logo i can achieve
that by on the h1 which is the element
that includes the netflix text as you
can see here i can add a property called
text dash
shadow which must contain three values
so just bear with me here as i'll write
all three of them out and then i'll
explain it
i'll do zero pixels zero pixels black
and seemingly nothing happened
that's because i first wanted to show
you the third value here black that's
pretty simple that's just the color of
the shadow and as you can see here it is
black
the two other values dictate the offset
of the shadow on the horizontal line and
the vertical line so if i add for
example 5px here you can see that now
the shadow appeared it's as if it's
sticking out to the right of the letters
5 pixels if i do the opposite minus 5
pixels it'll stick out 5 pixels on the
left hand side
as you can see
there's no shadow below and above
because that's dictated by the second
value
so if i turn this back to five
and on the
vertical one do for example
30 then you can see that the shadow got
pushed far too much downwards
if i do minus 30 it's pushed upwards
if i do 5 pixels it's pushed only 5
pixels downwards which looks pretty good
actually it is indeed the design we were
looking for so summarize here the first
value is how many pixels you want to
push the shadow to the right
the second value is how many pixels you
want to push the shadow downwards and
the third is the color so what i want
you to do now
is try to make the shadow look like this
as you can see now it's on the left hand
side and below like as if the sun is
shining from the top right corner
so take a guess at how you need to
change this line 11 here in order to get
that effect go ahead and do that right
now
okay hopefully that went well
what you need to do
is basically
put a minus in front of the first value
like that
that shifted the shadow from being on
the right hand side of the letters to
the left hand side
okay changing it back again
now i want to teach you
body fourth value you can add to the
text shadow property and that is the
third pixel value so here you can also
write for example
5
px and what happened now
if we compare what we have here right
now with how it was before we added that
value you can see that previously the
edges of the shadow were sharp there's
no blur
whereas here they're kind of fading over
into the red color behind it
and this is called blur if we reduce
this one to zero again the edge is sharp
again now if we do something crazy like
50 you can see that it is so blurry that
it just looks a little bit like
background that's a little bit dirty so
let's get it back to zero again here
what i want you to do now is
try to achieve this shadow go ahead and
give that a shot right now
okay hopefully that went well let's have
a look you can see the shadow is above
and to the right of the letters let's
fix that first
to have it on the right of the letters
we need plus value on the first one we
want to push it to the right and we want
to have it above so we don't want to
push it downwards as we're doing with
this value so we want to minus it
pushing it upwards
like that
and now the only difference is that this
is a lot more blurry whereas this is
completely sharp so let's try five
pixels here as well and boom there we go
that looks pretty correct to me
so great job doing this challenge before
we move on i have just a final trick i
want to show you which is a little bit
of a hack but super useful because let's
say that for example the background here
was
white smoke instead of the red color and
white smoke is a very white color with
just a little bit of gray in it as you
can see it looks really bad now we can
hardly see the letters we can clearly
see the shadows if we now
set zero pixels on the two first values
but keep the blur well then suddenly
there's no shadow but there's just a
glowing effect around the letters making
them visible even though they are in
almost the same color as the background
and if we make this smaller for example
one you can see the line around the
letters look a little bit sharper since
it's very little blur now if we do like
20 each letter gets a lot of blur around
it and thus making them visible
so that is a little trick to use
normally with small values on the blur
in order to make your text stand out a
little bit more in the situation where
your text color and your background
color is a little bit too similar and
this is very relevant if you have a
background image in which the contrast
between that image and the text color is
a little bit too weak so then you'd use
this hack to make your text stand out
despite the similarities between your
text color and the background image so
that was quite a lot about text shadows
but now you know it so we are ready to
move on to the next scrim
okay now we are going to fix this
problem of the text blending too much
into the background when it is broken
into two lines and thus are located
exactly over the galaxy in the
background image here because the
readability is a bit too low now in my
opinion and i want you to fix that by
adding a blurred border around the h1
tag using the technique you just learned
you should set the blur to 4 pixels and
the color to black so go ahead and do
this right now then i will show you the
solution as well when you return back to
me
ok let's do this so first we need to
select the age run and we've been really
good at using ids and classes here so
instead of just selecting the element
i'm actually going to give this one an
id of title because we probably only
have one title on the page
so running this
and navigating back into the css file i
can select the title and then i need to
use the text shadow property we want
both the horizontal offset and vertical
offset to be zero pixels
we're not actually doing creating a
shadow here the effect we want is more
of an outline so then without any offset
but for pixels blur it'll blur a black
shadowish effect around the entirety of
all the characters so if you look at it
now and look closely there is a
slight blurred black border around the
letters
it's not that easy to see but if you now
look at this while i comment out that
css rule you'll see the difference so
keep looking at the exploration word and
i will comment it out
now
now i'll comment it back again
there
comment it out
comment it back in again so so hopefully
you saw that it changed here in a little
bit
so now the readability is a little bit
better
great job
now i'm not sure if you're aware of this
but you're the best because you've
completed this section and that is very
well done plenty of people who have
started this section has never completed
it
you're not like them so i am really
proud of you and let's take a quick look
at what you've learned starting out you
learned about background images more
specifically you learned about the
background image property and the url
function and also the background size
property in css and setting that to
cover we also then used a webp format in
order to get this animated image in our
hero section which is super cool and
really breathes life into our website
and then you learned about google fonts
we imported them
up here in the head section and then you
set the font family like this
fonts do so much for the design of
websites so this is an important thing
to know as a web developer and you also
learned a new html tag which is the spam
tag which you can see right here it is
what allowed us to create this underline
under the expiration word
which it did in combination with a
utility class
the underlying class which only has one
job and that is to set the underline
whatever element it's applied to and
then also we learned about ids which is
another attribute in html that you
target in the css using a hashtag and at
the very end we did a really cool trick
with the text shadow property in order
to make the readability of our title
here a little bit better
so you've learned some key concepts in
this section now is the time for you to
get up stretch maybe get a cup of coffee
or whatever you prefer to recharge
because be sure to do exactly that and
then i will see you in the next section
welcome to this section where you are
going to build a birthday gift site and
it is just so cool because this site is
something you can use for whenever a
friend or family member of yours has a
birthday so what you do is basically add
their information to the header here and
then we have these gifts so for example
this one saying here's how happy i am
for you today and when the birthday boy
or girl hovers over the image they will
see a nice gif that makes them feel
truly appreciated
going down we have other gifts how
people react when you enter the room
this is meant to make them feel really
good looking
and here if i had to describe you with
one word genius so you make them feel
really smart
next up the only person as badass as you
is of course james bond
and then rounding it up with a little
toast
so hopefully you have someone special to
send this site to like nikki for example
who despite being a computer-generated
image created by an ai also is one of my
best friends so i am looking forward to
make nick happy on his birthday let's
just get started with this section
okay it's time for your first challenge
what you're gonna do is create this
basic design here for the header of our
app and it's pretty far from what we got
right now as you can see in the
styles.css we have no styling at the
moment so our site looks pretty dull
you can see everything is left aligned
and the image of nick is far too large
plus we're lacking the appropriate fun
taking a look at the html here it's just
a very simple structure with an h1 an
image tag an h2 and an h4 inside of the
body so nothing special there
the font that you will use is called
happy monkey and it is a google font so
you're going to have to head over to
google font to fetch it and then embed
it into our project as you can see in
the provided design the image of nick
should be rounded and not squared as it
is right now so you'll have to figure
out how to make an image round and yet
again you'll find the answer if you
google it finally i want you to consider
how you should select the image so
should you use a class selector an id
selector or an element selector you can
use any of them but i want you to think
about it and try to figure out what you
think makes most sense go ahead and do
this right now and then i of course will
show you the solution when you return
back to me
okay hopefully that went well
let's do it together i want to start
with centering everything and for that
i'm going to do
body
and then set the
text align to center like that
as you can see that indeed centered our
elements next up i want to fix the image
it is here and i think it makes sense to
use an id selector here because this is
kind of the main image of our birthday
boy and i don't think we'll duplicate it
across the page so it is unique meaning
we can use an id so i'll do id equals
and then bff for best friend forever
because nick is my bff please don't make
fun of me because my bff is a
computer-generated image but that is
just how it is and then i'll do dash img
just to make it a little bit easier to
understand what it is based upon the id
name
then i'll run the code so that that is
applied to the dom
and heading over to the styles i'll do a
hashtag bff.img
like that and first i want to fix the
width of it it's far too wide this looks
more like 100 200 pixels so let's try
width of 150 pixels like that yes that
is pretty much what we're looking for
and hopefully you figure out how to make
an image round and the way to do it is
to use the border radius property which
you've seen a couple of times by now and
the maximum border radius an element can
have is 50
and boom
there it is completely round
all right the final part is to add the
google font the happy monkey font that
is a very birthday-ish font actually i
found it just by googling google font's
birthday then happy monkey was the top
result clicking into that we'll select
it by clicking select this style and
then we'll copy the links here so that
we can embed it into our project i'll
paste that into the head of our project
then copy the font family rule so that i
can paste that directly in as well now
i'll have to rerun so that the font is
embedded and yes there we go that is as
far as i can see exactly the design we
were looking for
so great job let's move on
okay your next challenge is to colorize
the app because i wanted to look like
this with a nice blue background pink
border and white text and as you can see
i've provided the hexadecimal values for
the pink blue and white colors here so
your job is simply to figure out where
you need to add these and what kind of
css properties you're gonna use
go ahead and do this right now
okay hopefully that went well let's do
it together
i'm to start here in the body taking the
blue hexadecimal value and setting it
as the background of the body boom there
we go
next up we want to set the color
property here
to
white just just six f's after each other
like that
now that is inherited down from the body
into all of these okay final step is the
image as you can see it should have a
border around nick and it should be pink
so here we'll use the border property
and let's try six pixels because it
looks pretty thick it should be solid
and then
we'll copy the hex value from pink and
paste it in right there and actually
that looks about right to me
so great job let's move on
there is one problem with our site at
the moment which is that if we run these
two colors through a contrast checker
for example userway.org
you'll see that our accessibility
actually fails because the contrast
ratio is too small so what can we do to
improve this given that we want to keep
the colors we have what we can do is use
the trick you learned in the space
exploration section because pay
attention to what happens to this text
if we add a thin black border around the
text using the text shadow property so
this is without the text shadow property
and this is with it as you can see the
text now stands out more as the black
contrasts well with both the white and
the blue background and is also pretty
subtle so the text still looks white
but it's just a little bit more visible
and in my opinion i think the
readability here is pretty good so what
i want you to do now is write the css
for this exact technique
so add a thin blurred border around the
h1 h2 and h4 elements using the text
shadow technique you learned in the
space exploration section you're gonna
set the blur to one pixel and the color
to black okay hopefully you remember how
to do that give it your best shot and
then i will of course show you the
solution as well when you return back to
me
okay let's do this so let's start with
the h1 here and here i'm just going to
use an element selector as we'll have a
lot of h2s and h4s throughout the site
and i think we want all of them to have
this style so there's no point
separating it into a class
so text
shadow
setting the first two values to zero
pixels since we don't want any offset
vertically or horizontally but the third
value the blur should be set to one
pixel and then the color is black and
boom there we go we have that thin
outline which improves the readability
and now you probably did something like
this added a whole new rule for the h2
and yet another one for the age
four
and if you did that is completely fine
that is how i expected you to solve this
challenge
but i do want to show you a little trick
which allows us to reduce all of these
into one line and that is simply by
using a group css selector where you
simply add multiple selectors on one
line so what you do is instead of just
writing a tron you write h1 comma
h2 now we can delete the h2
because this rule is applied to both the
h1 and the h2 and likewise we can just
add the h4 here as well like that now we
can remove all of this as you can see
the thin border is applied to all of the
elements now it is really important that
you actually use a comma here and not
just add it like this this means
something entirely different and we're
not going to learn about that right now
as it's outside of the scope of this
section so make sure you have the commas
and then you can use this technique and
i happen to know that we also want this
text shadow to be applied to our h3
elements down the line and also our
paragraphs down the line so i'm just
gonna add them here so that we don't
have to think about this as we add new
elements to our site later down the line
so
great job let's move on
now we want to take this pink background
that we have around the image and apply
it behind the h2 and the h4 element so
that it looks like this so let's try the
most intuitive approach and see how that
works that would be to target the h2 and
the h4 i'm going to use this comma
selector here to target both
simultaneously as we've done up here and
then we'll set the background
to this pink color right here however as
you can see that did not give us what we
wanted because heading elements like h2
and h4 are by default display block so
they take up all the available
horizontal space so let's then try to
turn them into display inline and see
what happens then
ah that did not work well either because
when they're in line they're actually
narrow enough to be on the same line and
actually jump up to the line above with
the image which also is display inline
so let's remove the display inline as
well and the way to actually solve this
is to use a technique you haven't
learned yet now i'm just going to show
it to you fast and then we're going to
take a closer look at how it works in
the next script because what we can do
is head into the body which is the
container element for these two and for
all of our elements actually and do
display
flex that stacks things up on a
horizontal line turning every element
into its own column but we can change
that by doing flex direction which now
is set to row by default and that might
sound a little bit confusing since i've
always said that flexbox turns every
element into its own column and yes it
does that however what it also does is
make sure that all of the elements are
in the same row so that is why it's
called flex direction row because rows
go from left to right you can see
there's only one row from left to right
here which becomes even clearer if you
do like this and all the elements are
inside of the same row now in order to
flip this we can simply change row from
column like that now all of the elements
are stacked on top of each other again
in one column because a column goes from
top to bottom so this is just one column
now with that in place we can use
another css property in that flexbox
give us which is called align
items and set that to center and boom
there we go
now this was probably pretty confusing
and you were not meant to understand
this right now which is why we're going
to take a little digression here and
look closer at how flexbox works and
then return back to this example where
you will code it up yourself and
properly understand it
if you are to become a flexbox master
you will need to know align items
luckily though it's not that hard to
learn because it is a close cousin of a
property you already know which is
justify content so let's pretend that
the two of us for example work in a lab
together well if so we'd have our lab
equipment which you can see here inside
of our lab which is this green rectangle
right here and what we're going to do
now is use flexbox
along with justify content and line
items in order to organize our lab
equipment in different ways in our lab
so let's have a look at the code
the html is very simple it's just a
container which has three divs and each
div hold exactly one piece of lab
equipment visualized via an emoji
if we head over to the css you can see
that the container has a border and a
fixed height so that's why we get this
green rectangle the items have a width
and a height there's some margin in
between them and some padding on the
inside i've set the font size and also
added a border and finally
something you haven't learned yet but
i've added a gradient background so that
the color slightly fades from a darker
shade of green to a lighter shade of
green in the background now you are
going to learn about the linear gradient
later on so don't worry a second about
this right now just accept that it is
how it is and let's get going with the
organizing so as you can see by default
the lab equipment
the div status are stacked on top of
each other because as you remember divs
are display block
however if we turn it into a flexbox
layout
each of the item gets its own column and
as a consequence they stack up on the
horizontal line so far so good and if we
set the justify content properly it'll
arrange these in different ways along
this horizontal axis so if we do center
for example they are centered if we do n
they are pushed all the way to the end
and yeah you know the deal so what align
items does is instead of controlling the
horizontal line which i from now will
call the main axis it controls the cross
axis which is the vertical one going
from top to bottom
so
let's turn this back to start and do
align items
center
boom there you can see now it pushed all
of the three items down to the center so
that they are centered vertically
meaning they are centered along the
cross axis and then i can combine this
with the main axis which is justify
content that controls the horizontal one
going from left to right for example do
end here and boom then we are still
vertically aligned so we're in the
middle but we are pushed all the way to
the right hand side along the main
horizontal axis so the values you are
going to use for line items to begin
with are start center and end whereas
with justify content as you know you can
use start center and end but also these
space around space evenly and space
between properties okay let's move on to
the challenge what i want you to do is
follow my orders on where we should
leave our lab equipment because i want
you to do it in very specific ways
starting with this position here where
they're all squeezed down in the bottom
left corner so go ahead and modify
justify content and align items to
achieve that layout right now
so to achieve this layout you can see it
is at the bottom of the cross axis the
vertical one so we'll do end online
items but it is at the start of the main
axis because it is pushed all the way to
the left meaning that we should do start
up here and there we go we have solved
it
okay
new challenge i want you to achieve this
layout go ahead and do this right now
so here we can see we are actually
centered both along the main axis
horizontally and the cross axis
vertically
so i'll try center
yes and center again and there we go
okay final one i want you to organize
the equipment like this
go ahead and do it right now
okay hopefully that went well the first
thing i'll notice here is that all of
the items are squeezed to the top so
align items should be start
and there's some space around the
elements
so we need to try one of these for
example space around space evenly or
space between so let's try for example
space between
hmm
that didn't exactly achieve what we
wanted because there should be some
white space on the left side and the
right hand side here whereas these two
are squeezed all the way to the end so
maybe we can do space around instead yes
that looks exactly like what we want
so really good job solving these three
challenges before we move on there's
just a small thing i want to tell you
that is something you might see from
time to time which is that if i now
remove the height
of our items
see then they just became a little bit
higher because the content inside of it
wants a little more height but that was
besides the point what i wanted to do is
also remove the align items let's see
what happens oh wow it turns out that
flexbox in the cross axis actually
stretches the content like this and the
reason it didn't happen previously was
because our height property overrode
that stretching so what this means is
that line items
by default has the value stretch
when we do for example start it's no
longer stretched and it's pushed to the
start
so this might feel very confusing and
the only reason i want to tell you about
it now is that when you are in a flexbox
layout and you notice that something is
stretching in a way you don't want it to
stretch the prime suspect you should
look at is align items and experiment
with that so be aware of that but don't
worry too much if you found this a
little bit confusing it's totally okay
let's just keep up the pace and move on
to the next scrim
now you're going to learn about flex
direction
because there is one problem with our
lab system now that is that regardless
of how we change around on the align
items and justify content let's center
an end for example our lab equipment
will always stack up besides each other
they'll be on the same row and there's
no way to get them to stack on top of
each other but maybe that's how i prefer
to leave my lab equipment for the night
but regardless of how we change to
justify content and align items that is
now impossible now we could of course
remove the display flex and then these
divs will stack on top of each other by
default
so by doing this now they stack on top
of each other
however
justify content and line items
no longer work so if i try changing
these
nothing happens because these properties
work inside of a flex box not inside of
a random div that by default is display
block
so we need the display flex
like that in order to make these work
however what we can do is change the
flex direction
so first let me just both of these do
back to start and then i'll do flex dash
direction
and it by default is a row because as i
said they stack up alongside of each
other on a row but if we change this to
column boom there you can see now they
suddenly stack on top of each other as
if they are in the same column as
columns go from top to bottom so now we
are back to the original layout we had
before we made this into a flex
container but justify content and the
line items now work
however they work in a little bit of a
different way than you might expect
because
as you remember i previously talked
about the
main axis going from left to right and
being the one controlled by justify
content whereas the cross axis going
from top to bottom and also being
controlled by align items
well when we change the flex direction
and our items stack up differently on
top of each other we also change the
main axis so this is no longer the cross
axis it is the main axis and it's
controlled by justify content whereas
the horizontal one is no longer the main
it is the cross and it's controlled by
align items so we basically flipped
align items and justify content
so if i now do justify content end
it'll jump downwards whereas previously
they would have jumped to the right
and if i now do align items and it'll
jump to the right whereas previously
align items control the vertical
position so this is probably a little
bit confusing now you should not feel
bad if this feels overwhelming this will
take time to mature in your mind and
it's totally okay that in the beginning
now you're just experimenting with these
values in order to get the layout you
want and not really remembering exactly
why it works as it works so let's now
give you some practice i want to clean
up my lab equipment and i want it to be
like this
so go ahead and change around on these
two values in order to achieve that
layout
okay
what we need to do is on justify content
i want to center it so that it's
vertically centered but then we want to
align it to the start on the left hand
side
yes that is correct
okay new one
achieve this layout
okay
here we can see some space in between
the items so i think we need to use
space between on justify content
yes looking good
but we are aligning to the left we want
to align it to the right instead so
align items should probably be end
instead of start and boom that is
correct final layout
this one right here give it a shot right
now
okay we can see that they are all
squeezed towards the top so i think
we'll do justify content
start
like that
yes this is good but we want to center
it as well
so we'll do a line items center and
there we go
so
great job doing this let's just move on
okay now we're going to put your freshly
acquired flexbox skills to the test
because you are going to turn this
layout here into
this layout
so first i want you to wrap the html
element in a div with an id called
header so that is
all of these items right here
and then you are to select this header
and then use flexbox to achieve the
layout from the design slide and as you
might have guessed you will need to use
flex direction and align items to solve
this so go ahead and give this your best
shot
okay so we'll start in the html
create active opening tag and close it
off down here
indent this
run it no change scene in the mini
browser
that is to be expected
because we'll have to target it and
style it
so i'm gonna do header and then first
display flex
that forces all of the elements into one
row because it is flex direction row by
default
however we don't want that we want
everything in one column so we'll do
flex direction
column like that now they stack on top
of each other which is just what we want
but there's a problem the two elements
here are stretching and the image of
nick is left aligned it's not centered
so i think we need to change the align
items
align
items
into center
like that and there we have the layout
we wanted
so great job let's move on
okay now you're going to fix up the
design for this 24 years old element and
the date element right here because i
want it to look like this here you can
see that there's some space between the
content of the element and the edge of
the element and there's not as much
space between the elements and also the
edges of the rectangles are a bit softer
but before you start doing this there's
a couple of things i want to do
because here the h2 and the h4 have no
ids or classes they are just selected
using the element selector and also
using a selector list separated by
commas and i don't think we should do
either of those first of all we probably
don't want all of our h2 and h4s on the
page to be styled according to how it
looks here up in the header so we
actually want to give these two ids i'm
going to call this one b day age
and this one
b day date running this code so that we
got it applied and then in the css
instead of using element selectors we'll
use id selectors be they age
and delay date and then finally let's
avoid applying styles to both of these
simultaneously let's work with one or
the other because this is really an
optimization and writing code which is
so called dry short for don't repeat
yourself and while that is a good thing
i want you to focus on the core css now
because this will introduce a little bit
more complexity so let us instead just
keep it simple so i'll break this into a
new line so we got the birthday date
rule here and then copy the exact same
thing to the be they age
like that okay
now it's time for your challenge
you are going to make the b day elements
look like the provided design slide like
this so go ahead and do this right now
okay hopefully that went well let's
start with the age element as you can
see there is some space around it that
is padding most likely so let's add
padding for example 10 pixels and see
how that works if we compare that with
what we have in the design it looks
pretty good but i think we shouldn't
have 10 pixels on each side i think the
padding on the left and right side is
meant to be slightly larger than the top
and bottom as we've often seen with
buttons and layouts in general so for
the top and bottom we'll do 5 pixels and
left and right 10 pixels that is what we
are looking for as far as i can see okay
next up there is some border radius here
as well not that easy to see but it
definitely is there so we'll do border
radius five pixels for example that
looks pretty good to me and now let's
just try to copy this down to our
birthday date and see how that works
here you can see except for the fact
that there's much less space between the
elements here they look pretty similar
as far as i can see so we need to move
on to the margin let's try first and
remove all the margin from the birthday
date margin 0 like that now it's quite a
lot closer and whatever margin comes
from the h2 element that probably has a
bit too much margin bottom so let's
rather control that by doing margin
bottom for example 10 pixels and yes
that looks pretty good to me let's also
look at the margin top here it is too
much space between the age element and
the image so if we do margin top by 10
pixels there that looks pretty good but
it's perhaps still a little bit too much
let's do five instead yeah actually i
think we got it so the final step then
is to convert this into a shorthand
because we know how to use shorthand
don't we we want 5 on the top and 10 at
the bottom then we'll do margin 5px for
the top 0 for the right hand side 10px
for the bottom and 0 for the left hand
side
and there we go now if your solution is
slightly different from mine perhaps you
used
slightly different margins border radius
padding that doesn't really matter give
yourself a pat on the back regardless of
how you solve this and let's move on
okay now you are going to create the
first gift section of our site
so as you can see it contains a title a
little hint about hovering over the gift
and then there's the image itself now
the hover effect is not a part of this
challenge you're only going to work with
this hard-coded gifs cover at this point
and that gift cover has been added up
here in a images folder which i've just
created as we now have two images so i
wanted to gather them together in this
images folder that means that i've also
changed the image of nick or the source
that is referring to the image of nick
in the html it now contains the correct
path into the images folder so the
challenge is described in detail here i
want you to start by creating a gift
section div that will wrap all of the
elements for the first gift and then i
want you to add the h2 h3 and img
element so that is the title which is an
h2 the hint which is an h3 and finally
the image itself and i want you to give
them all their own classes so that you
can use the classes to select the
elements when you are to style them
according to the design and as a final
hint the image should be 400 pixels wide
so go ahead and do this right now
okay hopefully that went well so i'll
start by heading over to the html and
create the markup
so we wanted a div to begin with
i'm going to create that and then give
it a class of
gift section like that and inside of it
we wanted first an h2 for the title
which should contain the following text
let's run this and yeah ah nice
we can see that the text already has the
correct font and also the slight shadow
around it okay very nice let's then give
it a class as that or something we
should do with all elements
i'll call this gift
title like that and there was the h3
with the following text and i'll give
that a class of gift hint as you can see
i'm using gift and then a description i
think that makes it easy to understand
that these are all somewhat related to
each other
finally the image element
should have a source of images slash
gift
cover dot jpeg and also a class of
gift img all right let's run this code
and as you can see everything is being
rendered though the image is far too
large so we need to get going with the
styling all right
i'll start with the image so dot
ift imd and give it a width of 400
pixels yes that is much better and that
is centered because of our text align
center up here very nice okay let's just
carry on with this one you can see it
has a white border so let's do
border
looks to be something like six pixels or
something and solid white
yep pretty good and finally a border
radius because the corners here are a
little bit rounded off so let's try
order radius at 10 pixels for example
and yeah that looks pretty much like the
design for the image nice okay next up
is the spacing as you can see we have
far too little space from the gift
section itself to the header section
above
and i could add that to the top element
here to the title for example but it
makes a lot more sense to add it to the
container element itself because it
should control how far it is between
this container and the container above
so let's do gift section
margin top and for example 50 pixels
that is much better and looks pretty
much like what we have here now you can
see that the space between the title and
the hint is very limited it's not that
much space whereas here the default
margins for the h2 and h3 elements
create quite a lot of space in between
them so now we probably have to work
with both the default margin that the h2
has at its bottom and the default margin
which the h3 has at its top it doesn't
really matter what we start with let's
for example just start with the gift
hint and see what happens if we set the
margin top actually let's bring it up on
the side here now we've not done
anything with the margin top at all
let's set it to zero
you can see
nothing happened okay that must be
because the margin top here and the
margin bottom under the h2 collapsed
into each other and the margin bottom
for the h2 was probably larger than the
margin top for the h3 so removing it
served no purpose
that means that we also need to try and
remove the gift titles margin at its
bottom
set it to zero for a couple and there we
go now they're really crammed into each
other actually too much they should have
a little bit of spacing in between them
so let's try to instead of reducing that
to zero we set it to for example 10
pixels that looks much more like the
design we have here very good so you
probably had different names on your
classes and different margins and
perhaps different borders and radiuses
that doesn't matter the important thing
is that you gave it a shot and got some
kind of result hopefully resembling this
so no matter what you did
great job let's carry on with this
course
okay now we're going to prepare our
project so that we later can add the
hover feature so we're not going to add
the hover feature right now we're just
going to set the stage for it
and in order to do that i'm going to
first mess up this project a little bit
and then it'll be your job to fix it
because
we are not going to use the image tag
here in order to display this gift
instead we are going to use a div tag
so i'm changing this into a div which
means i also need to close it like that
because divs are not self-closing as img
tags are and then next up divs don't
have a source attribute so we can't use
this in order to display the image if i
now run this you can see boom suddenly
our image is gone this src attribute has
no place here because instead we are
going to render this image through the
css background image property so i'm
going to remove this one if we run the
code again you can see nothing else has
happened and moving over to the css
now it is your job to turn this weird
line here into something that looks like
this which is exactly what we had before
i messed up the code here so you are to
fix the
gift img div because i kept the class
right here
so that it looks like the provided
design
and a little bit of a hint it needs a
height and if you wonder how much i want
it to be a square so equal width and
height it also needs a background image
which is how you'll render this gift
cover it also should be centered again
because as you can see here this looks
very much left aligned so basically
what's happened here is that the div has
zero height because the div has
no content inside of it so the only
thing that's visible is the border which
spans 400 pixels starting from the left
hand side and over towards the right
hand side so go ahead and give this a
shot and then i will show you the
solution when you return back to me
okay let's do this
first it needs a height and it should be
a square meaning equal width and height
so let's just do
it and set it to 400px like that
as you can see we now have a empty div
on our page next up we're going to set
the background image so how do we do
that well you've seen that one before
background image url and then point it
to the images folder and the
gift
cover dot apec and there you go
but what is happening here it seems like
we only kind of see the top left corner
of the image that is because the image
itself is huge much larger than this 400
by 400 pixel container so we need to use
our good old friend
background size and set that to cover
and that squeezes our large image into
the current width we have available here
now finally why isn't this element
centered anymore well the centering of
the image used to happen because the
text line is set to center but text
align will only center inline elements
inside of its container and as you
hopefully remember divs they are not in
line they are display block and you
might have tried to do
this play
in line like that
then you can see that doesn't really
work
then our width property and height
property gets this weird underline
underneath them because they are simply
ignored by css because you can't force
the width and height of an inline
element as they should only be as large
as the content inside of them are and
this div doesn't have any content so we
can't really use display inline what we
rather can use is the margin technique
you learned earlier the one where you
set the left and right margin to auto
because that works on elements that are
display block and which have a set width
so let's do margin 0 on the top and
bottom and auto on the left and right
and there we go
we have it centered we are back to our
original design and we've set the stage
for our hover effect which nick is going
to be so glad to experience so it's
really cool that you've made it this far
and let's just keep up the pace and move
on to the next scrim
in order for you to build the next
feature for our birthday gift site you
will have to learn about the hover
pseudo class so let's take a step back
from our birthday project and learn all
about this hover pseudo class for it
i've created this little fictional
website for a restaurant it's just a
very simple site that has three divs
that are meant to be navigation items
where you can look at the menu book a
table or order catering if we head over
to the css you can see that the only
styling here is a set of rules that are
applied to the divs that is the three
menu items what i've done is simply
aligned the text to the center i've set
the text color to white given it's a
margin some padding on the inside of the
menu items i've added this red
background color cranked up the font
size and also made the font bold now
what would be really nice is if these
elements changed slightly when the user
hovered over them so that we gave the
user some visual feedback hinting to the
fact that these should be clicked and
also just making the site feel more
alive and that is where the hover class
comes in because what we can do now is
if we target the same divs and then add
a colon
hover and opening up the curly brackets
then we can write specific rules that
only are applied when the element is
being hovered over so for example we can
change the background color to this
color right here and this hexadecimal
value probably doesn't tell you anything
but i can disclose that it is a slightly
darker shade of this red hair so now if
i hover over the items boom you can see
that the background is suddenly a little
bit darker than the other items so this
gives a nice feedback to the user so
what's going on here is that
this line takes precedence over this
line
when any div is hovered over and we can
also for example increase the font size
40 pixels let's see how that works
all right now it really stands out when
you hover over one of the elements
and let me show you a cool trick to
prepare you for your next challenge
because what you can do is actually do
background image and then as you know
use the url css function and point it to
a image source i happen to have a image
lying around in the file system right
here let's try them so eyes dot
jpeg we now hover over the item we can
see our good friend nick staring back at
us
that is
probably the creepiest restaurant menu
i've ever seen but the point is only
that you can change the background image
on hover so hopefully this has prepared
you for your next challenge because when
we return back to the birthday gift site
you are going to work with this hover
class in order to help nick unpack his
gifts so let's return back to our main
project
okay now we are getting into the fun
stuff here because now we're going to
create this epic feature where nick when
he hovers over the gift paper gets
revealed an underlying gif that makes
him feel happy and appreciated on his
birthday
so the challenge is described here you
are to swap the gift paper image out
with the happy gif when you hover over
the gift paper so the happy gif is added
here in the images folder i'm not going
to show it to you i want you to solve
this challenge in order to see this gif
now the gift paper image you are to swap
out is
this div right here
as you remember we gave it a background
image which is the
giftcover.jpg file which also is in our
images folder so go ahead and solve this
challenge right now and then i will show
you the solution when you return back to
me
okay hopefully that went well what we'll
do is first target this gift img here as
we want to create a hover effect on it
so i'll do gift imd colon hover
now whatever css properties and values
we are setting inside of these curly
brackets will be applied when the user
hovers over
this gift image and what kind of
properties do we want to change well
it's actually only one just the
background image here so i'm going to
copy that one paste it in and we don't
want it to be the giftcover.jpg we want
it to be the happy dot if like that
let's see how this works i'll move the
cursor down towards the image and when
it crosses over we see phoebe and rachel
from friends being super happy for nick
on his birthday and i don't know about
you but if someone told me that they
would be this happy for me on my
birthday it would make me feel so
grateful and appreciated so we are
really doing a good deed creating this
website and you know what you've done a
great deed for yourself in terms of
getting this far in the course you have
crushed through so many difficult css
concepts so phoebe and rachel are also
cheering for you take a moment to
appreciate that and then i will see you
again in the next scrim
okay now that we've made sure that nick
feels appreciated on his birthday
through this phoebe and rachel gif let's
make sure he also feels really good
looking because now we're going to
create this gift right here which says
how people react when you enter the room
and the gif will show when he hovers
over this element is this hot gif up
here i'm not going to show it to you now
you're going to have to solve the
challenge to see it and speaking of that
let's have a look at the challenge text
so you are to create the next gift which
uses the hot gif and its html structure
should be like the previous one but
without the gift hint element because as
you can see here we have this hint
written in parentheses however that's
not needed for this one i think nick
will probably get the point by the time
he scroll down to this one so let's just
skip it but other than that you can
simply copy paste this section and then
of course change the text as well
however you will need to do some more
things as well
because
now that you have multiple gifs on the
page you cannot use the gift image class
to set the background image on hover
that is this one right here because if
you have multiple gift image elements on
the page well then every single one of
them will just show this happy gif and
that's obviously not what we want so
instead each of the gifts will need a
unique id that controls which background
image that should be shown when the user
hovers over the element okay that was
probably a lot to parse for you but if
you didn't quite catch it just go ahead
and try to solve the challenge because i
think you will see this problem sooner
or later anyway you definitely will
actually so make it your best shot and
then of course i will show you the
solution when you return back to me
okay let's do this
so starting in the html by simply
copying this one right here and pasting
it down here removing the gift hint
because we don't need that and then
updating the title let's run the code
now and here we can see the first
element with phoebe and rachel let's
scroll a bit down and there we have our
second element though it still shows
phoebe and rachel
so that is a problem and that is because
as i said this gift image class
just sets the background image on hover
to the happy gif on both of these
elements right now so we can't use a
class for this we need a unique id but
we're not going to remove the class of
gift img because it
actually gives
a lot of styling actually all the
styling to the element
so it's only the hover pseudo class that
needs to be applied to something else so
let's instead now on the first one here
add an id that we'll call gif dash img
happy
we'll run the code so that it's applied
and then instead of referring to the
generic class here refer to this gift
img
happy
id
now if we run the code
you can see that it works on the first
gift though the second gift now lacks a
hover effect and that is because the
only hover effect we've applied now is
on this specific id here on the first
gift previously we used the generic gift
img class so it was applied to all gift
images but now the hover only works on
the first one so what we need to do is
use this exact technique
but on this section as well so i'll
create an id
on this section
and call it gift dash img
dash pot
i'll run the code so that it's applied
and then since i'm lazy i'll copy this
if img happy should be changed to gift
img hot because that is our new id that
targets that element
and we don't want to show the happy gift
we want to show the hot gif
so let's see if this works here we are
at this section when we hover over the
image we see someone looking pretty
interested in nick so i think he will
feel really good looking and hot on his
birthday when he sees this gif so great
job solving this challenge let's move on
as you can see over in the file system
i've added a genius gif and a badass gif
so your job is now to create the genius
and badass gift sections they should
look exactly as the hot section so i'm
not going to give you any more
instructions other than giving you the
titles so that you can just copy them
from here instead of writing them out on
your own
so go ahead and create these two
sections right now and then i will show
you the solution when you return back to
me good luck
okay let's do this
so i'm going to start in the html file
because we're simply going to copy paste
this one
two times
then i'm going to add the titles i'll
copy this one and paste it in
here and copy this one
and paste it in
here okay
let's run this
now you can see we have the hot gif and
then the genius section which still has
the hot gif underneath it that's to be
expected and there we have the badass
section which also still has the same
gif
so now we have the sections rendered on
the page at least but we need to fix up
the css so
lazy as i am i'll copy this one there it
says gift image hot
the first one will be the genius one so
i'll do genius instead
and that should refer to the genius gif
now that we have this in place we can
just give this class to the respective
image like that
running the code
and we have the happy gif we have the
hot gif and then
the genius gif
that is pretty cool i surely think nick
will appreciate this compliment okay the
final one here the keyword is badass so
i'll change the id
to badass now that we are in the html
and moving on to the css
copy this
and change from genius to badass because
that's the id we just created and the
gif we want to fetch out from our images
folder is the badass.gif
let's open up our example again scroll
down to who is the only person as badass
as you it is of course chuck norris
all right
we are done with this challenge
great job let's move on
now it's finally time to add the very
last gift and that is the chairs gift so
you're gonna add this section but
there's a little difference between this
section and the previous ones because as
you can see here it is not squared but
rather more rectangular so what i want
you to do is give the gift section a
height of 200 pixels which is different
from the original height that we
controlled up here on the gift img class
where we set it to 400 pixels so the way
you are to change this or override it is
by selecting the gift img shares id
which you are going to create just like
you've created ids for all the other
gift images as well and then you're
going to set the height on that element
which essentially means to override the
previous height and finally here is the
text as well along with the chairs gif
up in the file system here and i really
think you'll enjoy this one so go ahead
and give it your best shot and then i
will show you the solution when you
return back to me
okay let's do this i'll start in the
html by again copy pasting
the previous section and here i need to
change the text first
so i'm going to do
like that
and then we're not gonna have badass
rather it's shares
so running this we can see we have a
squared image in place that's not
exactly what we want so we need to do
the next step which is to use this id
which we just created and override the
height
i'll do height 200 pixels like that and
there we can see it is now just as we
want it the final step then is to use
this hovered pseudo class in order to
change the background image to chairs
i'll copy this one
and do
chairs instead and now if we hover over
it we see leonardo dicaprio in a smoking
giving us a toast
really nice
and one thing i want to mention here is
that you might be a little bit confused
as to why this height property takes
precedence over this height property
and it is actually not because this is
written further down in the css file
actually if we remove it to even
further up in the css file even though
css reads from the top and then
downwards this still takes precedence
over this
and that is because of something called
specificity which means that the more
specific a css selector is the higher it
will be prioritized and this id selector
is a more specific selector than the
class because as you know only one
element can have an id whereas multiple
elements can share the same class
so ids are more specific than classes
now i don't want to get more into
specificity we're going to learn more
about that later in the front-end
developer career path for now i just
wanted to mention it in case you were a
little bit confused so we have now done
all of the gifts
and we have a super cool birthday page
we can send to nick there's just a few
things left and then we are completely
done with this epic birthday site so
i'll see you in the next scrim
now you are going to create the footer
for our site and it should have a
paragraph that says want to create your
own birthday gift site take this html
and css course with a link to well this
exact html and css course
and i want you to configure the anchor
tag so that it opens up the link in a
new tab if you've forgotten how to do
that well then you simply have to google
it
i've provided the link right here and
also the text so that you don't have to
write that out on your own however
outside of that i'm not going to give
you any more hints but i want you to
notice that there is some spacing around
this paragraph both above it and beneath
it you can see it doesn't touch the
bottom of the site and also it is
centered it's about as wide as the
images themselves and it's also in
italic
so you're gonna have to figure out how
this translates into css i think you can
do it go ahead and give it your best
shot and then i will see you again when
you return back to me
okay let's do this
so i'll head over to the html and add a
paragraph which i'll give an id of
footer and let's paste in the text
like that and also the
link
else we need to create
an anchor tag
and it should be around
this html and css course so we'll start
the anchor tag here
do an ahrefs
and then in order to open the anchor tag
in a new tab we'll do target equals
underscore
blank
and then we'll close it off at the end
here
let's run this
okay so we have now something that looks
not too far from our design it's decent
but still a lot of things lacking
first of all this text is far too wide
it should be more or less the same with
as the images
so let's do
footer
set the width to
400 pixels
okay what happened now well we do have
text line center but now that this is
400 pixels wide and it's still a display
block element as paragraph is that the
text line center won't center the
content here inside of its container so
we need to center it using the margin
technique meaning that we'll do margin 0
at top and bottom and then auto add left
and right
yes there it is centered but actually we
do want some margin at the top and
bottom because as you can see right here
it has some spacing above and a little
bit more spacing beneath it so let's try
40 pixels on top
yeah that's pretty good
and now 40 pixels at the bottom that's a
bit too much in my opinion here it looks
more like 20 or something so let's
rather than do 20 pixels like that now
we have 40 at top auto at left right and
20 at bottom and that looks pretty good
to me
however one obvious thing we need to fix
is that this anchor tag should also be
white so i'm going to target the element
itself
new color white like that
now i think the final step we have is to
make it italic and that's done up here
where we can do font style
italic
and there we go that looks identical in
my eyes
so really good job i'll see you in the
next scrim
okay now we're going to talk about
gradients and that's something you've
probably seen many times in nature
though not really thought much about
because for example because the sky is
full of gradients here you can see a sky
that kind of fades from a light blue
color into a whitish color and this fade
is basically a gradient
here's another example where it starts
almost black at the top and then slowly
fades over into purple and then again
into a orange-ish or light brown or i
don't know what you want to call this
color but you get the point it's fading
from one color to another and this is
very often used in web design you can
and you can do it with css pretty easily
let's for example remove this background
image of the gift card from our gifts
now you can see it's just transparent
and then instead we'll write background
and linear dash gradient
and then two parentheses so this looks a
little bit like the url keyword we write
when we want to refer to images meaning
that this is also a so-called css
function now inside of the parentheses
we simply write the two colors we want
to fade from and to so let's do from red
to blue and boom there you go now you
can see that all of our gifts fade from
red down to blue and by default it
starts with the first color at the top
and then the second color at the bottom
so let's try to mimic this image here in
css
i happen to know that there's a css
color called
light sky blue
so if we start with that one
and go down to
white
and have a look at this gradient here
actually
to me it's kind of similar to this one
we have here not quite but you get the
point okay
now i'm gonna remove this
give us our gift cover back and then
give you a challenge because now i want
you to change our site's background into
a gradient that goes from blue at the
top to pink at the bottom and
let me show it to you let me and let me
here show you how it will look i'm going
to do some magic now i'm going to knit
my fingers and then the gradient and
then the gradient will be applied
automatically
pretty nice now you can see the bottom
here is pink and if we scroll up it
slowly fades over into blue
and at the top it's totally blue so this
makes the site slightly more fancy which
i think is cool and matches the birthday
team so now i'm going to knit again and
the gradient will be gone
like that now our site is blue
all the way from the bottom to the top
and it's your job now to get the
gradient back so go ahead and do that
right now
okay let's do it so the property we need
to fix is the background on the body
because we need here a linear
gradient
going from the blue color it used to
have to
the pink color which we've been using as
a border of our image of nick so then
i'll simply paste that one in right here
now it should be fading from blue to
pink
let's see we can see the blue and yes it
looks like it is slowly fading towards
pink
really good job now you've learned a
super cool css technique i'll see you in
the next scrim
okay now that you've completed the
birthday gift site i want you to make it
your own so first try to think of
someone whose birthday is upcoming it
could be a friend a family member a pet
or basically whomever if you need some
ideas you can head over to on
thisday.com and click on birthdays
that'll show you a bunch of celebrities
was born on this exact date as you can
see here the birth dates are
chronological so you probably have to
scroll a bit down until you find someone
you've heard about rolling it down will
show us that louis vuitton was born on
this day in 1821 or scrolling even
further we can see that also meghan
markle was born on this day so if you
find a celebrity you like here this is a
perfect opportunity to make this site
about them and what i mean about that is
that i think you should change the gifts
to something suitable for that person
and also of course change the copy as
well accordingly and if you want to go
even more above and beyond create entire
new sections or even style it
differently depending on how you want it
to look that is great practice for your
design and product skills in general
finally once you've done that i want you
to download the code files so that you
have them locally on your computer if
you've forgotten how to do that it's
pretty simple just click on the gear
icon in the bottom right corner here and
click download as zip as you can see it
now downloads this zip which in my case
is called project parentheses 45 so once
you've found someone to create this
birthday site about made the appropriate
changes and downloaded the code you are
ready to move on to the next couple of
scrims where we are going to deploy it
to the web
on its way from your local computer up
to the internet your code is going to
take a slightly different path this time
around because while it worked perfectly
fine to just drag and drop your files
onto github.com that's actually a pretty
clunky way of doing it so instead we're
going to use a dedicated tool for
interacting with github and that tool is
called github desktop because that's the
way the pros do it when they interact
with github they always have a tool in
between them and the service which helps
them push code up to github and also
pull code down from github and just to
make things a little bit more complex
for you here what's actually going on
under the hood is that both github
desktop and github.com rely on a piece
of software that's called git
what is git well some devs who think
they are really smart will probably tell
you that git is open source distributed
code management and version control
system but you should regardless of how
smart you are just think of git as a way
to keep track of file changes so that's
it git helps you keep track of how your
project files change over time and
actually you don't need to know anything
more than that in order to get started
using git via github desktop because
this desktop app abstracts away a lot of
the complexity with git and as long as
you know how to use this app you don't
really need to know much about what's
going on under the hood so let's just
get started and download github desktop
right away if you are following this
course via scrimba you can just click on
this slide right here but if you're
watching it via youtube just head over
to desktop.github.com
once you're there click on the download
button so that your browser starts
downloading the zip file for this app
and once that's done open up the app
install it on your computer and once
you've authenticated with github in the
app you should see a screen that looks
more or less like this
the first step you're going to take here
is to click on this button that says
create a new repository on your hard
drive because that's what we want to do
we want to create a repository aka a
folder on your computer that holds all
of our project files what you'll then
see is this little modal where you have
to give your repository a name so i'm
going to call it birthday gift site and
then you are to head down to the local
path field and click on choose because
what you now need to tell git and github
desktop is where on your computer you
want your project to live i'm going to
navigate to my dev folder and just click
open and then create repository that'll
change github desktop into this
dashboard that you will interact with
the earth a gift site repository using
the various buttons now you can see that
it says no change files because our
repository is empty in order to verify
that let's click on the show in finder
button when we do that you can see that
github desktop has created an empty
folder on our local computer and i have
it here right above the project zip i
downloaded in the previous scrim so i'm
going to click on the zip file then
double click on it so that i'm unzipping
the files select all of the files and
then drag and drop them over into our
repository like that when you then
return back to github desktop you will
see chuck norris staring you straight in
the face because as you can see on the
left hand side here all of the images
and project files have been registered
so click down on the index.html file
there you can see they're all in green
which means that these are new lines of
code ready to be added to the git
repository in order to add all of this
content to a repository you have to head
down and write a commit message in the
bottom left field right here i'm going
to just say commit initial files and
then to perform the commit we'll hit
this commit to main button don't worry
about what main means at this point and
also if you're a little bit confused
about what a commit actually is don't
worry too much about that what we're
just doing here is telling git that we
want to add a bunch of files to the
repository and we're also adding a
little description so that in the future
it'll be easier for other developers to
understand what you were thinking when
you added these files so let's hit
commit to main that removed all of the
files which was intentional but actually
here my computer did something annoying
max have a tendency to add a so-called
ds store file which is something mac
uses to handle metadata for a folder we
don't need that in our project so i'm
actually just going to right click on it
and delete this file entirely by
clicking on discard changes now once
i've done that the dashboard is back to
how it was before we committed the files
so it has this publish repository option
both here and up at the top this means
sending off our code to github that's
obviously what we want to do so i'm
going to click on publish repository and
also give it a name i'm going to give it
the same name on github as we have
locally calling it birthday gift site
and also i'm going to uncheck this keep
code private because we want our project
to be open source and then i'll hit
publish repository now the final step is
to click on this button right here view
on github and boom here we go we have
created a repository locally on our
computer and published it on github via
github desktop just as the pros do it so
really good job we are ready for the
next step which is to deploy this site
to the web which we'll do in the next
scrim
now that you've pushed your birthday
gift site to github it's time for us to
hook it up with netflix so that you can
deploy it as well so head over to your
netlify dashboard and there click on the
add new site button and choose import an
existing project there just click on
github which then brings up this search
menu where you can search for the
birthday gift site click on it and then
leave all the site settings as they are
just scroll to the bottom and click
deploy site then you'll see this
familiar dashboard again and as always
the only thing you need to do here is
wait until this image here turns into a
screenshot of your site which is now
does meaning that your site is available
on this url
now hopefully your birthday site is not
about nick at this point it's about
someone else and i definitely think you
should send it off to that person or if
it's about a celebrity or whomever at
least share it with the world and once
you've done that give yourself a pat on
the back and i will see you in the next
scrim
at this point you know how to use github
desktop locally on your computer how to
push code up to github and then have
netlify deploy it to the world wide web
that is really good however you're still
lacking one important tool because what
happens if you want to change your code
and then push it up to github and deploy
it again well in that case you'll have
to use a code editor locally on your
computer so that's exactly what you're
going to learn in this scrim we are
going to use a code editor that you
actually have been using quite a lot at
this point though you might not be aware
of it it is called visual studio code
and it's actually what powers scrimba
under the hood though as you can see
from the screenshot here it looks a
little bit different from the scrimba in
browser editor as we've done some
modifications to it and stripped it down
a little bit okay so in order to get
visual studio code running locally on
your computer you have to head over to
code.visualstudio.com
or if you're watching this scrim on
scrimba just click on this slide and
you'll get to the landing page once
you're there click on the download
button that'll start a download process
of the app and you'll also get to this
getting started page however i'm going
to talk you through it so you don't need
to read through this guide once it's
downloaded just unpack the zip and
install it on your computer and then
you'll get to a screen which looks like
this here you can see a bunch of
onboarding steps but we're not going to
worry about them right now just click on
the back arrow in the top left corner
and there i want you to click at the
open option because that'll open up the
finder menu which you are to locate to
the folder for the birthday gift site
click on open and there you can see the
birthday gift site listed under the
explorer tab on the left hand side i'm
going to remove this get started file
here so i'm going to click on this x
icon like that and then i'm going to
click on the birthday gift site to open
up the folder moving on to the
index.html file when we open it you can
see that it looks quite a lot like how
it looks on scrimba the editor right
here though we at scrimba have created
our own color theme so we're not using
the default one you can see right here
but other than that it's quite similar
now let's make a change to this code
push it up to github and get it deployed
the change i want to do is just very
simple i'm going to change this name
from nick's birthday into pierce
birthday if i then save this with
command plus s or control plus s you can
see that the file turns yellow means
that it has changed and also to verify
this let's open up finder alongside a
browser window and just drag and drop
this index html into the browser because
then we can see that it says today is
pears birthday so by pointing our
browser to the local index.html file we
have verified that yes the changes have
been saved though this is just available
for me locally it has not been deployed
yet so we got to do that as well and the
way we get these changes up to github
and then up to netlify is as you
probably guessed via the intermediate
step of github desktop so if we navigate
to the desktop app there you can see
that it has noticed that we have changed
line 10. you can see the red line 10
right here which is the previous version
before we saved our code and the green
line which is the new version after we
saved our code so now we have to tell
git that we actually want these changes
to be incorporated into our repository
we have saved them locally but we
haven't saved them or aka committed them
to the github repository so by having
this file checked and writing a commit
message down here in the bottom left
corner we can commit this change and
thus save it in git i'm going to give it
the commit message change the name to
pair and then hit the commit button now
all of our local changes have been
committed as you can see it says zero
changed files but what we did get is
this number one up here and an option
called push origin and that means
pushing our changes up to github so if i
click at that you can see it starts
doing some stuff under the hood and then
if i click on view on github it'll open
up the github browser and there on the
row here which lists the index.html file
you can see that our commit message
changed the name to peer was added to
this project one minute ago that is very
promising if we now head over to our
netlify dashboard you can see that
nitpify has already picked this up here
under builds you can see that one of our
projects is now being built and in this
tab as well you can see we have one
concurrent build going on and then after
a little while you can see boom it's
completed i'll click into the project
and open up the url and there you go it
says today is pears birthday so now you
have a really powerful local dev
environment and also an automated
deployment process that ensures that
when you push changes up to github
they'll also be reflected out in the
world wide web so again give yourself a
pat on the back this might have been a
little bit overwhelming i totally get
that but over time as you do this more
and more it'll become second nature
it is not just nick who deserves a
congratulation you two my friend deserve
exactly that congrats on completing this
section now let's have a look at what
you've learned starting out you learned
about the align items property which
allows you to align items in a flexbox
container along the so-called
cross-access and speaking of access you
also learned how to flip the flex
direction between column and row so row
is what's used by default but we set it
to column here because row would make it
look completely wacky so instead we want
a column that stacks things on top of
each other next up you learned about the
super cool hover pseudo property which
enabled us to create the feature where
when nick hovers over the image the
underlying gif is exposed and then of
course you learned about gradients also
a really neat little trick that allows
us to
slowly fade from blue to pink on the
background here here we can see how we
did that with the linear gradient on the
background of the body
and then we also took a quick look at
how to group selectors together by using
the comma in between a bunch of
selectors we could apply the style once
instead of having to repeat this rule
again and again throughout our style
sheet
and you also learned about github
desktop how to set up a repository
locally on your computer and use this
tool to push it up to github and finally
how to use vs code so that you now have
a proper local development environment
where you can build stuff change it push
it up to github and finally then get it
deployed
so with all of this your brain is full
of new knowledge meaning that you should
feel free to take a break right now to
let the concepts mature in your mind and
then i will see you in the next section
when you are ready
welcome to the final section of this
course and here it is time for you to go
solo and what do i mean about that well
you know how i've kind of been peeking
over your shoulder helping you step by
step throughout all of the projects
we've built
well
that time is over
now i'm going to remove the training
wheels and you will have to build a full
project on your own because that's
actually the only way you can know
whether or not you've truly learned html
and css
so you're going to build a so-called
solo project and the project is a home
page for your hometown you can see it
here on the right hand side this version
right here happens to be about my
hometown or the place i grew up in oslo
norway it's a part of the city called
tushov however the point with this is
not for you to build exactly this but
rather build a website about a place
area city or country that you care about
and you have a connection to because
when you do that and then share it in
the discord community it'll give an
opportunity for other students on
scrimba to get to know you better and
hopefully you'll enjoy building it as
well because that is about the place you
care about
now i'm going to go deeper into the
content of the solo project in the next
scrim but for now there's one thing you
need to do and that is to head over to
figma.com because figma is the design
tool in which you'll get the design for
your project it is the most popular
design tool these days it can kind of be
seen as the github equivalent for
designers so i want you to click on this
image right here and then you'll be
taken to figma.com there click on sign
up and create an account and i also want
you to click on this image right here
because that'll take you to a quick 10
minute figma tutorial which bob's a role
our teacher here at scrimba created
specifically for students who need to
learn a little bit of figma in order to
do solo project here on scrimba so you
can either watch this right now or you
can wait until you've started the solo
project when you feel the need for some
guidance through the figma interface the
reason this is at youtube and not here
on scrimba is because learning a
browser-based tool like this is actually
better to do via a regular video than
via slides here on scrimba so with that
let's move on and take a closer look at
the actual solo project
now it is time for you to solve your
very first solo project the hometown
homepage and here it is as you can see
it is a website that consists of three
sections the hero here has a background
image and a heading and subheading
there's the activities section which has
a title and three columns each one
containing an image a heading and a
paragraph and then there's finally this
card at the bottom which is meant to
introduce you to a tourist guide for
this area
and you might look at this and think how
on earth am i supposed to create all of
this
well take a look at each of the elements
and think back at what we've done in
this course for example this hero
section here with a background image and
another section beneath it well that's
pretty similar to what we did in the
space exploration site and these two
headings right here with the background
colors well that's what we did in the
birthday gift card with the year element
and the date element and as for the card
down here i think that resembles our
business card quite a lot
finally the three columns we have in the
activities section well that looks like
a job for flexbox if you ask me and
we've used flexbox multiple times even
the way we use it here where actually
all of the three flex children the items
are containers in themselves which
contain an image a heading and a
paragraph so i think you got this let's
then look at the specific requirements
first of all you're going to build it
from scratch or i'm saying that with
quotes because i've actually added a
little bit of a skeleton here for you
so you can see what we got basically a
version with hardly any styling but with
some of the elements in place you can
see there's the hero section here
there's the activity section it doesn't
have all the data but at least the three
images and then there's the guide
section at the bottom here obviously
though it looks terrible because the
only styling i've applied is some margin
0 on the body and i've aligned the text
to the center and also limited the width
of the images to 100 pixels
so you can use this as a starting point
if you want or you can wipe it out and
do it completely from scratch that's up
to you next i want you to make sure that
you do use classes
flexbox the background image property
and also the color palette that i'm
providing as you can see in the css here
are the hex values for the color palette
i'm using and also i have a link to
coolers here you can click this image
and you'll be taken to the color palette
and then once you're done if you are up
for it there are some stretch goals
first make it about your own hometown
country or whatever place you like i
hope everyone wants to do this because
when you share it in the scrimba
community we will get to know you a
little bit better secondly if you use a
different color palette your site will
be even more unique and if you add a
google font you can really level up the
design because i've not done that and as
a result the font here is a little bit
boring also if you want to go crazy find
a way to use the hover sudo class on any
of these elements that would be super
cool and finally you could add entire
new sections that would be so cool
however do remember that these stretch
goals are optional you don't have to do
them but i would encourage you to give
it a shot if you have the energy so
moving on to get to the actual figma
file click on this image right here and
if you get confused do remember the
figma tutorial i talked about in the
previous scrim you can click on this
link right here to get to it now if
you're watching this on youtube these
links have also been added to the
description below the video and they are
in the corresponding github repo for
this course finally you can do this solo
project either locally on your computer
or here at scrimba if you do it here at
scrimba i would recommend you to click
on the three dots in the bottom right
corner and choose fork to new scrim as
that will give you your very own scrim
to work on instead of just working on a
note on the timeline of this specific
lesson so i will leave you with these
requirements so that you can look back
at them when you need to with that i
wish you the best of luck you got this
happy coding
hold on a second did you just complete a
five hour long online course
wow that is phenomenally well done you
should be proud of yourself because out
of all the people who start this course
this is the amount of people who
actually complete it and you belong in
that group you are not a quitter however
at this point you might wonder what now
what should i learn next and i think you
are ready now to get started learning
javascript the programming language that
powers the web and there are many ways
to do that online one of them is the
frontend developer career path that we
have here at scrimba which aim to take
students from zero to hireable as
front-end developers and you've actually
taken the second module of this career
path because module two consists of the
course you've just gone through so you
can jump directly to module three where
i will teach you the basics of
javascript however there are plenty of
other resources out there where you can
learn javascript so this is just if you
like my style and scrimba in general
regardless of what you do i think you
should celebrate yourself so go ahead
and deploy the final project you created
that is the hometown homepage and share
it with the world and if you've already
started creating an online portfolio
this project is a great first thing to
add to that if you have feedback for me
regarding this course i would love to
hear it you can click on this link to
get to my twitter profile and this link
to get to my linkedin profile and if
you're watching this on youtube i've of
course added the links in the
description below the video as well so
with that there's just one final thing i
want to remind you and that is that you
are awesome the fact that you have
completed this course gives me a lot of
confidence in you on your journey
towards becoming a professional web
developer good luck with your learning
journey going forward and thank you for
taking my course